THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
ON EDUCATION FINANCE.
PLEASE TAKE THE ROLE.
MCCARTY. HERE CHAVEZ HERE.
MURATSUCHI.
VOEPEL YOU.
CORMAN'S ESTABLISHED.
OKAY.
GREAT SAID TODAY WE HAVE THE
HEARING.
FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
AND WE HAVE MULTIPLE YOU SEE
BUDGET ISSUES.
I DISCUSS THE FIRST WE'LL GET AN
UPDATE ON THE FIVE ACTION ITEMS
THAT YOU SEE WAS ASKED TO
COMPLETE AS PART OF LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET AGREEMENT. LATER THE
STATE AUDIT AND WE WILL GET
UPDATES.
ON THAT AND SEE HOW DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE FEELS ABOUT FREEING
UP THE FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS. BY
MAY THE FIRST PURSUANT TO THAT
ARRANGEMENT.
IT WILL THEN HERE.
FROM THE PERMANENT FINANCE AND
THE UC ABOUT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL AS WELL AS THE
YOU SEE.
REQUEST FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDING
PURSUANT TO THE REGION.
BUDGET ACTION ABOUT LATER WILL
DISCUSS THE OF PROP FIFTY SIX
ISSUE. AND.
MET MEDICAL FUNDING. AND THEN
WE'LL TALK ABOUT OFFICE THE
PRESIDENT IN THE UC PATH ISSUES.
AND THAT OVERALL OF COURSE WANT
TO TALK ABOUT THE.
.
THE THE MARQUIS I RESEARCH
UNIVERSITY IN CALIFORNIA
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA. AND TALK
ABOUT HOW WE CAN CONTINUE TO
HAVE A THRIVING UNIVERSITY BUT
ALSO EXPAND ACCESS FOR
CALIFORNIANS AND THAT'S.
ONE ISSUE THAT'S GOING TO BE
GOING THROUGH ALL THESE AGENDA
ITEMS AS HOW THIS CAN RELATE TO
US CONTINUE TO MAKE SURE WE
HAVE.
ACCESS FOR FUTURE CALIFORNIANS
TO ATTEND EITHER YOU SEE SO WITH
THAT LET'S GET GOING AT ISSUE
NUMBER ONE
.
YEAH BERMAN A FINANCE.
GOOD MORNING JAX WELL DEPARTMENT
FINANCE OF THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
BUDGET ACT HELD FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS FROM UC'S APPROPRIATION
TO BE RELEASED. WHEN THE UC
COMBAT MET FIVE EXPECTATIONS
THESE EXPECTATIONS WERE THAT THE
UC WOULD ONE.
COMPLETE DOT THREE ACTIVITY
BASED COSTING PILOTS TO ACHIEVE
A TRANSFER.
ENROLLMENT RATIO OF ONE
TRANSFER STUDENT FOR EVERY TWO
NEW. ENTRANT FRESHMEN STUDENTS.
THREE THAT THEY WOULD IMPLEMENT
THE STATE AUDITOR'S
RECOMMENDATIONS.
FOR THAT THEY WOULD ADOPT A
POLICY ENDING SUPPLEMENTAL
RETIREMENT PAYMENTS TO SENIOR
MANAGEMENT NEW SENIOR MANAGEMENT
REPLACED. AND FIVE THAT THEY
WOULD RELEASE ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION REGARDING THE
UNIVERSITY'S FINANCES.
I THE UC HAS UNTIL MAY FIRST
TWENTY EIGHTEEN TO PROVIDE THE
DIRECTOR FRANCIS SUFFICIENT
EVIDENCE THAT IS MADE A GOOD
FAITH EFFORT TO MEET HIS
EXPECTATIONS. AYE AND THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ASSUMES THE
RELEASE OF THE FIFTY MILLION AND
CURRENT. AND IN OUR CONVERSATION
WITH YOU SEE IS ON GOING ON THIS
MATTER FIGURE.
THANK YOU LA UP DECENT CONCENTRA
SILLY รณ I THOUGHT IT WOULD
HELP IF I FIRST WALK THROUGH ON
SOME OF THE UNCERTAINTY
SURROUNDING SOME OF THE
CONDITIONS THAT.
ARE IN THE SUIT ISSUE.
IF YOU TURN TO PAGE THREE OF
YOUR AGENDA IT ACTUALLY LISTS
EACH OF THE FIVE CONDITIONS.
AND THERE'S UNCERTAINTY
ASSOCIATED WITH EACH OF THESE
CONDITIONS THAT'S BECAUSE OF THE
DIRECTOR OF FINANCE WILL
ULTIMATELY MAKE.
THE FINAL DETERMINATION WHETHER
OR NOT YOU SEE HAS MADE A GOOD
FAITH EFFORT TO MEET EACH
CONDITION.
THAT SAID THEY'RE THEY'RE
DUSTING TO BE.
SOME ISSUES WHERE IT APPEARS
THAT YOU SEE HAS.
AND MADE AN EFFORT TO MEET
THOSE CONDITIONS
IF YOU LOOK ON PAGE FIVE AYE YOU
SEE HAS INDICATED. ON THAT FIRST
ISSUE FOR ACTIVITY BASED COSTING
THAT.
.
THEY'VE LONG ASSERTED THAT THEY
WOULD BE ABLE TO MEET THAT
CONDITION THAT THEY WERE IN THE
PROCESS OF FINALIZING THE REPORT
ON THAT.
AND THEY'VE ALSO THE REGIONS
RECENTLY ADOPTED A POLICY
REGARDING.
SUPPLEMENTAL RETIREMENT
PAYMENTS.
AND IN A DECEMBER REPORT YOU SEE
DID DEVELOP A LIST OF SYSTEM
WIDE INITIATIVES
SO DOES DO THAT THERE'D THERE'D
IT APPEARS THAT YOU SEE HAS.
AT LEAST MADE AN EFFORT TO MEET
THOSE ARE MADE A GOOD FAITH
EFFORT TO MEET THOSE.
REQUIREMENTS IT'LL ULTIMATELY BE
UP TO THE DIRECTOR TO MAKE THAT
DECISION.
OF THE IF THE TERRITORY THINK
THERE'S THE MOST UNCERTAINTY IS
INVOLVED THE STATE AUDITOR'S
RECOMMENDATIONS AND OF THE
TRANSFER ISSUES WE WANTED TO
TOUCH ON EACH OF THOSE VERY
QUICKLY.
REGARDING THE AUDITOR
RECOMMENDATIONS RETURN TO THE
FOLLOWING PAGE ON YOUR AGENDA
THE PAGE FOR.
I'M YOU CAN ACTUALLY SEE EVERY
SINGLE RECOMMENDATION THAT THE
AUDITOR MADE THAT WAS DUE IN
APRIL TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
IN A JANUARY UPDATE TO THE LED
TO THE STATE REGARDING THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS THE AUDITOR
NOTED THAT YOU SEE HAD FULLY
IMPLEMENTED ONE OF THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS.
PARTIALLY IMPLEMENTED ANOTHER
THAT LEFT MOST OF THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS LEFT TO BE OF
IMPLEMENTED. A LOT HAS CHANGED
SINCE JANUARY SO YOU HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ASK YOU SEE ABOUT
HOW IT FEELS.
AND IT HAS MET THESE REPAIR
RECOMMENDATIONS BUT THE AUDITOR
DID NOTE. ON SOME CONCERNS THAT
IT IT HAD SEEN SOME SIGNALS FROM
THE UNIVERSITY INDICATING
THE UNIVERSITY MIGHT NOT MAKE A
GOOD FAITH EFFORT TO IT
IMPLEMENT SOME OF THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS.
SO FOR THAT REASON WE DO THINK
THERE'S SOME UNCERTAINTY HERE
REGARDING WHETHER OR NOT.
THE AUDITOR AND ULTIMATELY THE
DIRECTOR WILL DETERMINE WHETHER
YOU SEE HAS A MANY GOOD FAITH
EFFORT TO MEET THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS.
ON THE TRANSFER ISSUE.
.
WHAT WE THINK IT'S A BASED ON
DATA THAT WE'VE SEEN FROM YOU
SEE IT'S VERY LIKELY THAT TO THE
CAMPUSES RIVERSIDE AND SANTA
CRUZ WILL NOT HIT THEIR TWO ONE
TRANSFER FRESHMEN TO TRANSFER
RATIO?
I BECAUSE OF THAT IT THE
ADMINISTRATION WILL. HAVE TO
MAKE A DETERMINATION ON WHETHER
OR NOT YOU SEE MADE A GOOD FAITH
EFFORT TO. ACHIEVE THAT RACIAL
RATHER THAT WHETHER IT ACTUALLY
WILL ACHIEVE THAT RATIO.
ANDIN DETERMINING THAT
DETERMINING THAT IT APPEARS THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION WILL MAKE
THIS.
WHAT ASSESSMENT BASED ON?
AND AMMO YOU THAT YOU SEE
RECENTLY OUR.
AGREED TO WITH OF THE COMMUTER
COLLEGE CANCERS OFFICE REGARDING
TRANSFER REFORM. JUST A SOME
BACKGROUND THE STATE HAS LONG
TRIED TO SIMPLIFY THE TRANSFER
PROCESS FOR STUDENTS ON
HISTORICALLY STUDENTS HAVE FACED
DIFFERENT TRANSFER REQUIREMENTS
DEPENDING ON WHICH CAMPUS THEY
WANTED TO TRANSFER TO. SO IF
THEY WANTED TO TRANSFER TO A UC
CAMPUS OR YOU CSU CAMPUS OR EVEN
WITHIN THE SYSTEM EACH CAMPUS OF
HAD ITS OWN TRANSFER
REQUIREMENTS.
AND THAT MADE IT DIFFICULT FOR
STUDENTS TO SORT OF PLAN WHICH
COURSES THEY WANTED TO TAKE.
ON AN EFFORT TO REFORM THAT THE
STATE'S.
REFORM THE TRANSFER PROCESS
BETWEEN CSU IN THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES BY ESTABLISHING
SOMETHING KNOWN AS ASSOCIATE
DEGREE FOR TRANSFER.
WITH THAT DEGREE DOES IS IT
ALLOWS STUDENTS TO.
COMPLETE AN ASSOCIATE DEGREE
WITHIN SIXTY UNITS AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE ANY GUARANTEES
THAT THAT'S IN WILL BE ADMITTED
SOMEWHERE AT THE CSU SYSTEM. AND
BE ABLE TO COMPLETE OF A PROGRAM
AT CSU WITH AN ADDITIONAL SIXTY
UNITS
SUCH THAT THE STUDENT HAS A
PATHWAY TO COMPLETE SOME OF FOUR
YEAR DEGREE WITHIN FOUR YEARS OF
FULL TIME STUDY.
OTHER SECONDARY BENEFIT STUDENTS
ALSO COMPLETE AN ASSOCIATE
DEGREE IS PART OF THAT PROCESS.
YOU SEE HAS HAD ITS OWN TRANSFER
PATHWAYS ON THERE THAT THAT HAVE
SOME CROSS OVER TO AND THAT CSU
AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
ASSOCIATE REFER TRANSFERRED BUT
THERE ARE SOME DIFFERENCES.
ON IT THEY JUST THESE PATHWAYS
GENERALLY REQUIRE SOMEWHAT
DIFFERENT COURSES IN A NUMBER OF
CASES OFTEN MORE.
MAJOR PREPARE TO RECORD SAYS
THEY DON'T GUARANTEE A STUDENT
CAN COMPLETE WITH A HUNDRED
TWENTY UNITS THEY DON'T
GUARANTEE A STUDENT CAN GRADUATE
I I CAN.
IS ADMITTED TO THE SYSTEM.
AND THEY'RE THEY'RE THEY'RE JUST
TRANSFER PATHWAYS ARE NOT
ASSOCIATE DEGREES.
I'M WHAT THE SUMMER YOU DOES
BETWEEN YOU SEE AND AND THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AS YOU SEE IS
COMMITTING TO.
CHANGE ONE OF THESE WHICH IS TO
GUARANTEE STUDENTS ADMISSION TO
THE UC SYSTEM IF IF THEY I'M. A
COMPLETE ONE OF THE UC I
TRANSFER PATHWAYS.
IT ALSO LISTS OTHER THINGS YOU
YOU SEE MIGHT EXPLORE IN THE
FUTURE AT ONE OF THOSE OPTIONS
FOR EXAMPLE IS THAT YOU SEE IS
CONSIDERING CREEK THAT. WORKING
WITH THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO
CREATE A SEPARATE AN ASSOCIATE
DEGREE FOR TRANSFER THAT'S
SPECIFIC TO YOU SEE.
AS YOU THINKING ABOUT THE SORT
OF A DECISIONS REGARDING TRANCE
REFORM WE WOULD JUST ENCOURAGE
YOU TO THINK ABOUT WAYS TO
SIMPLIFY THE TRANSFER PROCESS.
I'M FOR STUDENTS WHETHER OR NOT
THEY GO TO SEE US YOU WERE YOU
SEE.
ONE OF THE POSSIBILITIES THAT
MIGHT RESULT FROM SOME OF THESE
POLICY CHANGES THAT YOU SEE IS
CONSIDERING IS THAT IT COULD
JUST ADD A LITTLE MORE
COMPLEXITY. THAT'S BECAUSE
STUDENTS WILL FACE BOTH AN
ASSOCIATE DEGREE FOR TRANSFER OF
FOR CSU OR THEY COULD TAKE ONE
FOR YOU SEE BUT THEY STILL FACE
DIFFERENT REQUIREMENTS FOR EACH
SYSTEM SO IF THEY'RE IF THEY'RE
TRYING TO PLAN AND. THINK ABOUT
GOING INTO ONE IS SORT OF ON.
I THINK ABOUT GOING TO A YOU YOU
SEE CAMPUS BUT THAT HAVE SORT OF
A BACK UP CSU CAMPUS THAT MIGHT
BE LESS SELECTIVE THAT THEY
STILL FACED IF THEY MIGHT STILL
FACE DIFFERENT OF COURSE
REQUIREMENTS SO. THAT THAT COULD
ADD TO SOME OF THE COMPLEXITY
THEIR.
SO THOSE ARE JUST SOME THINGS TO
THINK ABOUT IS YOUR REVIEWING.
F YOU THINK YOU.
THANK YOU.
YOU THINK.
SAY EVER TANNING FOR UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA THANK YOU SO MUCH
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TO YOU TODAY. UP AS THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE STATED.
OF WE WERE PROVIDED WITH FIVE
CRITERIA WITHIN THE CURRENT YEAR
BUDGET THAT WE HAD TO MEET IN
ORDER TO. OUGHT RECEIVE FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS CURRENTLY WITH
HELD.
AREN'T THOSE ARE LISTED ON PAGE
TWO OF THE SLIDE HAND OUT THAT
ARE PROVIDED TO YOU. OF AMNESTY
LA ARTICULATED.
.
TWO OF THESE RECOMMENDATIONS ARE
AT.
UP R. IT HAVE NOT YET BEEN FOUND
TO BE FULLY COMPLETED BY
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE BUT WE DO
BELIEVE THAT THEY WILL BE FOUND.
A TO BE ADEQUATELY COMPLETED OF
ON SLIGHT THREE I DISCUSSED THE
TRANSFER RATIO. FOR OUR
CAMPUSES.
AND SO FIVE OF OUR CAMPUSES HAVE
AT THIS POINT FULLY ATTAINED A
TWO TO ONE.
UP FRESHMAN TRANSFER RATIO.
.
SENATE CREWS AND RIVERSIDE
CAMPUSES REMAIN ABOVE THE RATIO.
HOWEVER THEY BOTH CREATED BOTH
CAMPUSES CREDIT PLANS
FOR HOW THEY WILL INCREASE THEIR
TRANSFER STUDENTS AND ATTAINED A
TWO TO ONE RATIO.
FOLLOWING THESE PLANS.
RIVERSIDE CAMPUS WAS ABLE TO.
INCREASE ITS APPLICATIONS FOR
TRANSFER STUDENTS BY NINETEEN
PERCENT.
THIS LAST FALL
SO GREAT PROGRESS IS BEING MADE
ON THAT FRONT AND WE BELIEVE
THAT WE WILL. IN.
WITHIN A SHORT AMOUNT OF TIME.
ATTAIN A TWO TO ONE RATIO ON
THESE CAMPUSES.
IN ADDITION TO WORKING TOWARDS.
A TWO TO ONE RATIO ON THE
RIVERSIDE AND. US SANTA CRUZ
CAMPUSES.
OUR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
REQUESTED AN ADDITIONAL CRITERIA
OF THEM. OF MEMORANDUM OF
UNDERSTANDING BETWEEN THE UC AND
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
UP AS DAILY NEWS STATED TO
INCREASE THESE TRANSFER
PATHWAYS.
FROM COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO THE
UC I WANTED TO DISCUSS THIS A
LITTLE BIT.
WITH FEW THIS AMMO YOU WERE
SIGNED ABOUT ONE WEEK AGO.
ON SLIDE FOR.
I HAVE SOME INFORMATION ABOUT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
ADMISSIONS POLICY. AT THE
UNIVERSITY ORNATUS THE ACADEMIC
SENATE THAT DETERMINES THE
ADMISSIONS CRITERIA FOR OUR
STUDENTS ARE ACADEMIC SENATE HAS
BEEN VERY FOCUSED ON OUR
STUDENTS BEING READY FOR
UNIVERSITY LEVEL WORK.
AND BEING READY FOR THE MAJOR
INTO WHICH THEY ARE ADMITTED.
THE CSU ASSOCIATE DEGREE OF
TRANSFERS MORE FOCUSED ON.
GENERAL EDUCATION REQUIREMENTS
AND NOT ON THE MAJOR INTO THE
WHICH THE STUDENT. IS REQUESTING
ADMISSION.
CURRENTLY WE HAVE SIX UC
CAMPUSES.
BUT HOW OF UP. MACHINE
GUARANTEE.
FOR SPECIFIC MAJORS TO USE.
AGREEMENTS HAVE BEEN PLACE
SINCE THE NINETEEN NINETIES AND
CURRENTLY ABOUT ONE THIRD OF OUR
TRANSFER STUDENTS ENTERED THE UC
SYSTEM THROUGH THESE TAG
AGREEMENTS.
IN ADDITION SINCE TWENTY ELEVEN
WE PUT IN PLACE TWENTY ONE
TRANSFER PATHWAYS.
WHICH APPLIED TO ANY YOU SEE FOR
SPECIFIC MAJOR.
THE STUDENT CAN TAKE A SET OF
COURSES AND IS READY TO COMPLETE
THEIR MAJOR WORK WITHIN THAT
MAJOR AND CAN APPLY TO ANY YOU
SEE HAVING COMPLETED THAT SET OF
COURSES.
PRESIDENT PAUL TANA'S NOW
CONVENE THE TRANSFER TASK FORCE.
WHICH IS EXAMINING ADDITIONAL
WAYS TO.
MAKE THE TRANSFERS EASIER. FOR
STUDENTS AND PROVIDE.
A CLEAR PATH.
FOR THOSE WHO MAY NOT HAVE HAD
IT PREVIOUSLY.
OUR ACADEMIC SENATE IS NOW
WORKING ON AN ASSOCIATE DEGREE
OF SCIENCE
WITH COMMUNITY COLLEGES THAT
WOULD GUARANTEE ADMISSION FOR
THOSE STUDENTS WHEN PHYSICS AND
CHEMISTRY.
WHO HAVE A QUALIFYING GPA?
AND THEY WOULD BE READY FOR
THOSE MAJORS.
THEN SO WE BELIEVE THAT ON THE
TO THE ONE WHERE MAKING
EXCELLENT PROGRESS AND THAT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. IS VERY
LIKELY TO FIND US.
IN COMPLIANCE IN FACT.
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
DIRECTOR REGARDING OUR CAMPUS
PLANS WROTE TO.
OUR PROVOST AT THE EFFORTS
DESCRIBED IN THOSE PLANS
APPEARED TO BE A REASONABLE
STEPS TOWARD ACHIEVING TO EXPECT
THAT RATIO. SO WE'RE MAKING VERY
GOOD PROGRESS.
THEN. THE NEXT LARGE ITEM THAT
WE HAVE TO CLEAR THE NEXT BIG
HURDLE IS DE AUDIT RESPONSE.
THE AUDITOR REQUESTED TEN
ACTIONS.
OF WITHIN ONE YEAR OF THE AUDIT
RELEASED SO APRIL TWENTY FIFTH
TWENTY EIGHTEEN SO IT'S JUST.
UP A WEEK AWAY WE HAVE TO
COMPLETE TEN TASKS AND THOSE
AREN'T SLIDES FIVE AND SIX.
BUT THE PACKET THAT I PROVIDED
TO THE FIRST SLIDE.
SHOWS THOSE ACTIONS THAT ARE AT
THIS POINT COOLEY.
COMPLETE.
WE.
.
SOME OF THESE HAVE A STE PHASE
ONE AND PHASE TWO PHASE ONE
BEING IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN OF FACE
TO BEING IN. TWENTY NINETEEN.
SO SOME HAVE BEEN VOTED ON BY
THE REGION'S AND SOME THE
REGIONS HAVE HEARD AN ITEM WHERE
THE. INITIAL RESEARCH HAS BEEN
PRESENTED.
BUT.
WE ARE NOW WE HAVE.
.
THERE'S BEEN A WORKING GROUP.
THAT HAS LOOKED AT THE.
COMPARABLE PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
SECTOR PAY DATA.
AND.
UC OP HAS PERFORMED EXTENSIVE
INDEPTH ANALYSIS OF INTERNAL
EXTERNAL DATA TO DETERMINE HOW
BEST TO INCORPORATE STATE
POSITIONS IN THE UNIVERSITY
SALARY SETTINGS METHODOLOGY.
AND THE REGION'S WERE PRESENTED
WITH THOSE FINDINGS IN MARCH.
THEN.
.
DO YOU.
REGION'S HAVE ALSO.
.
SO THE BALLOT EVALUATION
IDENTIFICATION OF NEEDED CHANGES
TO EMPLOYEE BENEFIT POLICIES.
TO INSURE THAT WE HAVE
SAFEGUARDS IN PLACE.
CHANGES WERE MADE THE POLICIES
FOR CAR ALLOWANCES MEAL LIMITS
HOTEL RATES REALLOCATION
ALLOWANCES. MOVING REIMBURSEMENT
AND SENIOR MANAGEMENT
SUPPLEMENTAL RETIREMENT
CONTRIBUTIONS
AND THE REGION'S FORMALLY
ADOPTED A POLICY AROUND THOSE
RETIREMENT CONTRIBUTIONS AT
THEIR MARCH MEETING.
.
AND SO FORTH THESE CRITERIA WE
HAVE COMPLETED WE HAVE HAD OF
WORK.
WORKING INTERNAL WORKING GROUPS
THAT HAVE LOOKED AT THESE.
AREAS AND HAVE PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
WORKING EXTREMELY HARD TO
COMPLETE.
A COMPLETE SHE'S
CRITERIA.
AND FOR EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THEM
ACTION HAS BEEN TAKEN
INTERNALLY.
AND PRESENTED TO THE REGION'S.
FOR UPDATES
FOR THOSE THAT.
.
ARE DO LATER AND FOR THOSE THAT
THE REGENTS.
HAVE OUR POT NEW POLICIES THE
REGIONS HAVE ACTUALLY VOTED
THEM.
INTO PLACE.
IN THEIR.
DURING THE CURRENT YEAR.
AND I THINK
ALL'S DOT THERE AND PAUSED
BURNING QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY
HAVE.
ON THIS ISSUE.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS MR MEDINA.
TO YOU SEE IF YOU COULD.
.
SHARE WITH US.
THE OBSTACLES THAT.
YOU.
THAT UC RIVERSIDE AND YOU SEE
SANTA CRUZ FACED.
AND TRYING TO MEET THE.
TWO TO ONE RATIO ON TRANSCRIPT
BICU WHERE OF WHAT OP SCHOOLS
WERE IN THEIR WAY.
FOR SEMI WAS DIFFICULT FOR THEM
TO REACH.
THAT RACIAL
YES THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
SIR OF FOR UC SANTA CRUZ ONE OF
THE LARGEST DIFFICULTIES WITH
THE LACK OF STUDENT HOUSING AND.
DE AGREEMENT WITH THE TOWN OF
SANTA CRUZ AT THE CAMPUS WOULD
LIMIT GROWTH THIS MEANS THAT
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO CHANGE
THE BALANCE OF THE EXISTING
ENROLLMENT. ON THE CAMPUS FOOT
PICS LIKE THE LONGER.
TO CHANGE THAT AND ALSO. SANTA
CRUZ HAD A LACK OF QUALIFYING
APPLICATIONS.
FROM BOB TRANSFER STUDENTS
NEARBY THEY HAVE BEEN EXTREMELY
AGGRESSIVE TO. SEND.
RECRUITMENT
US STAFF TO NEARBY COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND EVEN FURTHER OUT.
TO CAREER FAIRS AND.
.
TO THE TO THE.
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CAMPUSES TO
LET STUDENTS KNOW ABOUT BY
UNIVERSITIES UPS UC SANTA CRUZ.
AND ALSO THE FINANCIAL AID
AVAILABLE. SO THE STUDENTS FEEL
MORE COMFORTABLE APPLYING.
A RIVERSIDE HAD A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF FRESHMAN APPLICANTS.
.
THE TRADITIONALLY A AND.
I THINK THE RATIO IS SOMETHING
LIKE.
THREE THREE FRESHMEN ENTRANCE
TO.
A A TRANSFER STUDENT AND THAT
CAMPUS ALSO WAS NOT VIEWED BY
TRANSFER STUDENTS AS A. VIABLE
OPTION.
SO BY SENDING THEIR ADVISORS
OUT THERE COMMUTE COLLEGE
CAMPUSES AND TALKING TO STUDENTS
ABOUT.
DE OPTION IF YOU SEE A LOT OF
THE STUDENTS VIEWED YOU SEE AS
TOO EXPENSIVE AND DIDN'T REALIZE
THAT WE ACTUALLY HAVE A VERY.
.
GENEROUS FINANCIAL AID PROGRAM
WHERE FIFTY SIX PERCENT OF OUR
STUDENTS DO NOT. END UP HAVING
TO PAY TUITION BUT HAVE THAT
TUITION FULLY COVERED BY GRANTS
AND INSTITUTIONAL AID.
AND ONE STOP WORD BEGAN TO GET
OUT RIVERSIDE WAS ABLE TO
INCREASE THEIR TRANSFER
APPLICATION RATES BY NINETEEN
PERCENT.
THANK YOU I I I KNEW THAT THEY
HAD FACED A VERY.
VARIOUS DIFFERENT OBSTACLES SO
THANK YOU.
JEFF JARVIS.
.
WE'RE. TALKING ABOUT IT.
NOW.
YOU TALK FOR DIVIDE UP FROM THE
ACTIVITY BASED COSTING THAT YOU
CONDUCTED.
SO THANK YOU SIR I ACTIVITY
BASED COSTING REPORT.
I HOPE YOU'LL HAVE WITHIN A WEEK
VEGAS IT'S DONE WEARS A BLUE
WAITING FOR FINAL SENATORS BY
THIS FRIDAY. OF THE CAMPUSES
THAT PARTICIPATED WERE UC
RIVERSIDE COLLEGE OF HUMANITIES
ARTS AND SOCIAL SCIENCES UC
DAVIS DEPARTMENT CHEMISTRY
MECHANICAL ENGINEERING AND
PSYCHOLOGY. AND UC MERCED
INTERIORS OF CHEMISTRY COMPUTER
SCIENCE AND PSYCHOLOGY.
AND.
OUR LARGER.
DATA SYSTEMS ON THE CAMPUSES
HALF TO COMMUNICATE WITH EACH
OTHER OR. THE. ANALYSIS SIMPLY
ISN'T.
NOT RELIABLE THAT THERE WAS A
MASSIVE HURDLE RIVERSIDE WAS AN
OBVIOUS CHOICE BOARD THIS
BECAUSE THEY HAD. IN PLACE A NEW
ACCOUNTING SYSTEM THAT CONNECTED
THEIR. FINANCIAL ACCOUNTING WITH
THEIR CLASSROOM DATA. AND.
STUDENT SUCCESS RATES DATA PALM
AND THEY WERE ABLE TO DO
ANALYSIS MORE BROADLY.
BUT WHAT WE ALSO FOUND WAS THAT
THE ANALYSIS TENDED TO BE VERY
SILO THAT IT WAS NOT.
COMPARATIVO FROM ONE UC TO
ANOTHER AND EVEN FROM ONE
COLLEGE TO ANOTHER ON CAMPUS IT
WAS DIFFICULT TO MAKE THOSE
COMPARISONS.
BECAUSE NOT ALL OF THE.
THE ACTIVITY BASED COSTING
TRIES TO CAPTURE. A VERY
DETAILED PRODUCTION COST FOR.
POSSIBLY A NEW STUDENT.
A UNIT OF EDUCATION RATHER THAN
THE WAY WE CURRENTLY DO IT IS
LOOKING AT LARGER SCALE MARGINAL
COST ACROSS.
THE ENTIRE SYSTEM OF A NEW
STUDENT.
SO IT WAS VERY DIFFICULT TO
OBTAIN DETAILED LEVEL.
DATA TO ACTUALLY DO THAT
ANALYSIS.
A LOT OF THE MANAGERS COMPLAIN
THAT THE. ACTIVITY BASED COSTING
PROVIDED THEM WITH COST DATA BUT
NOT WITH QUALITY DATA. SO THAT
THERE WAS NO WAY TO TELL WHICH
COURSE WAS ACTUALLY MORE
EFFECTIVE. OR WAS OF A BETTER
QUALITY THAN ANOTHER.
AND A.
THEY WERE BUT RECESSED INTO THE
HOT.
THE.
IN THE DISCUSSION WE HAD FOUR
YEARS AGO AND I KNOW YOU ARE
HERE THAT.
ONE OF THE VALUES OF ACTIVITY
BASED COSTING WHICH
ACTUALLY COME FROM THE
EDUCATIONAL WORLD.
THERE'S NOT JUST JUST DETERMINE.
THE COST OF AN ACTIVITY BUT THE
EFFICIENCY OF THE ACTIVITY.
SO YOU TELLING ME.
THAT.
FROM THE UNIVERSITY.
WHO TEACHES ACTIVITY BASED
COSTING?
DOESN'T HAVE THE ABILITY.
TO DEVELOP A MODEL TO DEFINE.
THE EFFICIENCIES AND
EFFECTIVENESS IN THE COST.
CURRENTLY WE DON'T HAVE THE DATA
SYSTEMS TO BRING IN ALL THE DATA
NEEDED FOR THE COMPLETE ANALYSIS
ON OUR CAMPUSES.
YOU KNOW NOT HERE BUT IT MAY BE
AT A LATER TIME FOR A GET OUT
HERE SO I WOULD LOVE TO HAVE A.
DISCUSSION WITH SOMEBODY FROM
THE UC WHO WAS PUT IN A POSITION
TO. MANAGE THIS PROCESS.
COME TO MY OFFICE AND HAVE THIS
PERSON COME IN.
TAKE SOMETIME TO EDUCATE ME ON
HOW YOU ATTEMPT THIS EFFORT.
I YES SIR I CAN MAKE THAT HAPPEN
THANK YOU.
SOME ARE TAKING YES I LIKE DEATH
FORMER FINANCE ON.
YOUR POSITION ON. WHETHER THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA IS.
ADEQUATELY A PROPERLY ADOPTING
THE AUDITOR'S RECOMMENDATIONS.
.
WE'VE YET TO SEE UC'S EVIDENCE
OF THE EVIDENCE IS DUE MAY
FIRST.
OF COURSE YOU'VE SEEN THE.
JANUARY AUDIT REPORT BUT AS THE
LA A SAID THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
ACTIVITY SINCE JANUARY WE LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING THE UC'S
EVIDENCE REGARDING AUDIT
IMPLEMENTATION. AND WILL REVIEW
IT THOROUGHLY.
ARE THE PARTICULAR AREAS THAT
YOU'RE CONCERNED ABOUT AT THIS
POINT.
AT THIS TIME. AS AS THE THE
ALIAS AT ONLY ONE OF THE AUDIT
RECOMMENDATIONS HAS BEEN
CONFIRMED IS COMPLETED BY THE
AUDITOR. THAT LEAVES NINE SO
THERE THERE'S A LOT OF ROOM FOR.
TO IT TOOK DIDN'T THERE'S
THERE'S THERE'S A LOT LEFT TO DO
WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO SEEING
WHAT. YOU SEE IS DONE AND AND
WHAT THE AUDITOR'S RESPONSE TO
WOULD USE HIS ACTIONS WERE START
THINKING.
THANK YOU I HAVE A. QUESTION
THAT'S SOMEWHAT RELATED TO ISSUE
NUMBER TWO BUT OUR OUR STAFF NOT
SIT IN THE IN THE COMMENTS.
WE'RE GOING TO HEAR A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT YOU SEE REQUEST AND
CERTAINLY FRIEND STUDENTS AND
ADVOCATES AS WELL.
ABOUT.
.
IT FULLY FUNDING THE YOU SEE TO
IT TO MEET THEIR THE REQUEST OF
THE OF THE SET SEGMENT. BUT
THERE THERE REALLY ISN'T.
RESOURCES FOR ENROLLMENT GROWTH.
WE WE KEEP IT THAT THE REQUEST
CONTINUE THEIR ACCENT FROM LAST
YEAR. SO ONE THING THAT WAS
FOUND IN THE AUDITS. THAT THE
SUBCOMMITTEE ACTUALLY WORKED ON
LAST YEAR.
ARE THESE SYSTEM WIDE PROGRAMS
INITIATIVES.
AND THAT CAN EVALUATION IS AS
FAR AS WHETHER OR NOT THOSE ARE
STILL. ADEQUATELY RELEVANT IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AS WHEN
THEY WERE ESTABLISHED IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN GOING BACK
TWENTY THIRTY OR SO LAST YEAR OF
COURSE AS WE KNOW WE.
WE'RE ABLE TO REDIRECT SOME OF
THOSE FOUR. IN ENROLLMENT.
EXPANSION AND WANTED TO ASK YOU
SEE IT IS THAT.
A CONTINUED.
ACTION ITEM FOR YOU ALL BECAUSE
THAT CERTAINLY WAS SOMETHING
THAT THE AUDIT TALKED ABOUT WE
TALKED ABOUT.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TALKED
ABOUT SO.
WANTED TO FOLLOW UP ON THAT.
I YES THANK YOU SIR. THE YOU SEE
OP AUDIT IMPLEMENTATION PLAN
INCLUDED.
SO DEFINING OF THE VARIOUS
PROGRAMS AND INITIATIVES WITHIN
THE UC OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT.
AND THEY HAVE BEEN CAREFULLY
REVIEWED AT THIS POINT.
.
THE AUDIT IMPLEMENTATION PLAN
HAVE INCLUDES WORK STREAMS FOR
VARIOUS EXAMINING VARIOUS
ASPECTS OF YOU CO P.. AND ONE OF
THESE IS DEFINING THE SYSTEM
WIDE INITIATIVES AND
ESTABLISHING BUDGET TARGETS FOR
EACH OF THEM. SO GOING FORWARD
FROM HERE.
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN IS IN
ORDER TO IMPROVE MANAGEMENT
REPORTING AND TO DRIVE BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF ALL PROJECT
TRACKING AND ACCOUNTABILITY USE.
AS THIS LIST THE PROGRAMS WILL
BE REVIEWED ANNUALLY AND WILL BE
PRESENTED TO THE REGION'S FOR
CONSIDERATION OF WHICH PROGRAM
SHOULD BE SCALED BACK AND WHICH
ARE. UP PROVIDING USEFUL NEST
BUT THE AMOUNT OF DOLLARS BEING.
ALLOCATED TO EACH OF THOSE
PROGRAMS
SHARE WHAT I THINK THERE'S TWO
PARTS OF THAT ANY TALKED ABOUT
THE TRACKING IN TRANSPARENCY
THAT'S.
THAT'S A PART OF IT AND WE WEEK
WE'VE HAVE THAT THE LAST TWO
YEARS BUT AS FAR AS.
MAKING RECOMMENDATIONS.
TO TO POTENTIALLY DO SOMETHING
ELSE WITH WITH THOSE RESOURCES
SO WHAT DO YOU THINK IT IS THE
TIMELINE THAT WE COULD SEE. A
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE REGENTS.
AND THAT YOU SEE ON THAT CONCERT
WITH SOMETHING THAT THAT WE
COULD DO ON OUR OWN BUT HAVING
FEEDBACK FROM.
THE THE UC IS CERTAINLY HELPFUL.
OF THE UC OP BUDGET WILL BE
CONSIDERED BY THE REGION'S AND
THEIR MAY MEETING. AND.
YOU HAVE IT AGENDA ITEM LATER
ON DO YOU SEE A PIECE BUDGET
SPECIFICALLY IMPACT STATE BUDGET
DIRECTOR COULD DISCUSS THAT WITH
YOU FURTHER AT THAT TIME.
BUT GOING FORWARD THE EXECUTIVE
DO YOU SEE PRESIDENT AND.
THE FINANCE TEAM WITHIN UC
OPIATE AS WELL AS THE STUDENT
SERVICES ACADEMIC TEAMS WILL
CONSIDER PROGRAMS THAT ARE
NECESSARY AND. DEVELOP AN ANNUAL
BUDGET FOR THE REGION'S TO
CONSIDER AND CONTINUE. PROGRAMS
THAT ARE PROVING TO BE
EFFECTIVE.
AND NOW THAT WE HAVE REALLY DONE
A LOT OF THE BUDGET TRACKING WE
HAVE A BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF.
OF WHICH PROGRAMS ARE PROVIDING
RESULTS FOR THE DOLLARS SPENT.
SO ARE YOU SUGGESTING THAT THIS
MAY NOT BE A RECOMMENDATION FOR
FOR THIS. BUT BUDGET YEAR
POTENTIAL ACTION AND
REDIRECTION.
HE SAID AS A MATE REPORT BUDGET
REPORT COMING OUT FROM THE
REGION'S WITH WOMEN BY THAT IN
MAY THE REGION'S WILL CONSIDER
THE USE YOUR P. EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN BUDGET. THE REDIRECTION
OF FUNDS FOR INVOLVEMENT IN
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN HAS ALREADY
BEEN. BROAD CATEGORIES HAVE BEEN
DETERMINED. AND WORK COMMUNICATE
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IN
DECEMBER TWENTY SEVENTEEN NOW
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT FOR THAT FOR
THE NEXT YEAR OF COURSE UC'S
DIFFERENT THAN CSU WEEK YOU KNOW
BUDGET. FOR TWO YEARS IN ADVANCE
FOR A FRIEND ROME ITSELF.
THERE'S A GLARING GAP IN THAT
THE ACTION WE'RE GONNA TAKE THIS
YEAR WOULD HAVE.
AT ZERO RESOURCES TO FURTHER
EXPAND YOU SEE FOR OUR
CONSTITUENTS SO.
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT PRIORITY FOR
US WELL WE THINK THAT THE
ACTIVITIES CURRENTLY UNDERTAKEN
BY YOU SEE OPIUM THESE PROGRAMS
AND INITIATIVES CAMPED.
VERY WELL BE REDIRECTED TO
CAMPUSES FOR.
ENROLLMENT OR OTHER ACTIVITIES
BECAUSE YOU SEE OP HAS DISTINCT
FUNCTIONS APART FROM THE
CAMPUSES THAT ARE MORE
EFFECTIVELY DONNA SYSTEM WIDE
LEVEL. THOSE INCLUDE THINGS LIKE
OUR BOND MANAGEMENT OUR
INVESTMENTS ARE LEGAL.
AND THEN THERE ARE CERTAIN
SYSTEM WIDE INITIATIVES THAT CAN
BE BETTER SERVED FROM A CENTRAL
LOCATION SUCH AS OUR GLOBAL FOOD
INITIATIVE.
AND ALSO.
SERVICES FOR DOCTOR STUDENTS.
SO WE CURRENTLY DO NOT HAVE.
PLAN FOR ENDING ANY OF THOSE
PROGRAMS WHERE IF YOU SEE OP
FUNDING WERE TO BE REDUCED.
SOME OF THOSE PROGRAMS THAT.
LEGISLATIVE MEMBERS ARE THAT
SERVE A WIDE POPULATION ON OUR
CAMPUSES.
WOULD SUFFER.
AND THERE WOULD HAVE TO BE A
SERIOUS DISCUSSION ABOUT.
THE ELIMINATION YEAH. WELL I
GUESS THAT'S A DESIRE FROM THE
SUBCOMMITTEE IS WE WANT TO
CONTINUE.
TO TO LOOK AT THAT BECAUSE.
WHEN WE'RE HOME IN OUR DISTRICTS
CONSTITUENTS DON'T ASK ABOUT
SOME PROGRAM.
IT'S BURIED IN PAGE SEVEN
HUNDRED OF THE REGION'S BUDGET
THEY ASK.
WHY CAN'T OUR?
COMMUNITY MEMBERS GET INTO THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA. AND
THAT'S THE ISSUE THAT WE HEAR
NUMBER ONE AND IT'S WELL CAN USE
YEAR AFTER YEAR AND SO I THINK
WHAT WHAT I'M TRYING TO TELL YOU
IS WE ARE COUNTING ON THE UC.
TO WHAT WE ARE BURGER I DO OUR
BEST TO TO FULLY FUND.
THE UC BUDGET REQUEST LIKE
WE'RE GOING TO TALK ABOUT ISSUE
NUMBER TWO. BUT THAT PROVIDES
NOT ONE PENNY TO EXPAND ACCESS
YOU SEE ACCESS FOR CALIFORNIANS
AND SOME. UP WE WANT TO CONTINUE
LOOKING AT.
THESE.
.
THESE INITIATIVES THAT WERE
OUTLINED IN THE AUDIT LAST YEAR
THAT WE WENT OVER FOR THE PAST
TWO YEARS IN OUR SUBCOMMITTEE.
TWO LOOK AT POTENTIAL
OPPORTUNITIES TO TO REDIRECT.
NOT TO DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
OR SOMEWHERE ELSE IN THE BUDGET.
.
HEALTH CARE BUT TO REDIRECT.
TO. THE REDIRECT TO YOU SEE FOR.
ENROLLMENT EXPANSION.
OUR PREFERENCE WOULD BE FOR NEW
FUNDS TO EXPAND ENROLLMENT IN
ORDER TO BE ABLE TO BEST SERVE
THE STUDENTS THAT WE DO AN ROLE
AND TO CONTINUE THE VARIOUS
RESEARCH ACTIVITIES OF PUBLIC
SERVICE THAT YOU SEE UNDERTAKES.
IF THE UC OP BUDGET A SCALED
BACK IT WOULD MEAN THAT WE WOULD
HAVE FEWER. PUBLIC SERVICE
PROGRAMS AND ALSO OUR RESEARCH
MISSION.
MIGHT SUFFER.
YEAH.
WHERE WHERE THAT RESPONSE THAT
IS STILL OUR DESIRE TO TO TO TO
DO WHAT I OUTLINED JUST A
MOMENT?
ALRIGHT THANK YOU SIR.
COMMENTS WE COMMITTEE MEMBER
SEAMEN.
OKAY THANK YOU LOW PROCEED WITH
ISSUE NUMBER TWO.
BOB THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
CONTINUES STATE INVESTMENT IN
THE INTEREST OF CALIFORNIA.
TO OPEN HERE A FEW QUICK FACTS
ABOUT THE UNIVERSITY OF THE UC
SYSTEM IN ROLES APPROXIMATELY
TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY THOUSAND
STUDENTS AT ITS TEN CAMPUSES.
AND AWARDED SEVENTY TWO THOUSAND
DEGREES AND TWENTY SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN.
AND IRRATIONAL FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND STUDENTS ARE SERVED BY
USED EXTENSION PROGRAMS THESE HE
WILL RECEIVE THREE POINT FIVE
BILLION IN STATE GENERAL FUND
AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN.
DESPITE GROWING CONCERNS
REGARDING LONG TERM ECONOMIC
GROWTH THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL INCREASES FUNDING FOR
HIGHER EDUCATION.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
INCREASES THE UC BUDGET BY THREE
PERCENT.
A TOTAL INCREASE OF NINETY TWO
POINT ONE MILLION.
AND MAINTAINS THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN PRACTICE OF
BUDGETING SEPARATELY FOR THE UC
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT AND THE
EASY PATH PROJECT.
ON THE SUBJECT OF TUITION THEIR
MINISTRATIONS OPPOSED TO TUITION
INCREASES THAT THE UC. THE UC
SHOULD FOCUS INSTEAD ON REDUCING
ITS COST STRUCTURE TO ENSURE
THAT STUDENTS AND FAMILIES HAVE
ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE QUALITY
EDUCATION THANK YOU.
IF YOU TURN TO PAGE EIGHT OF
YOUR AGENDA PROVIDES ON A MORE
THOROUGH SORT OF BUDGET.
DISPLAYED FOR YOU SEE AND
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
AND THIS IS A BUDGET DISPLAY
THAT WAS VERY INTERESTING UP
PAGE EIGHT PAGE EIGHT OKAY.
MY APOLOGIES IF I SAID THE WRONG
NUMBER THERE.
.
IF YOU OF THAT THIS IS A BUDGET
THAT THE REGENTS DISCUSS THEY'VE
NOT ADOPTED AT THEY HAVE ADOPTED
SOME COMPONENTS OF IT BUT IT'S
LARGELY SOMETHING THAT THE
REGION'S HAVE DISCUSSED AND. ARE
CONSIDERING ADOPTING AND IN MAY.
WHAT WHAT THIS TABLE DOES SHOW
ON THE LEFT HAND SIDE IS
AVAILABLE FUNDS SOURCES THAT THE
UNIVERSITY BELIEVE IS
ANTICIPATING TO HAVE? NOT JUST
GENERAL FUND BUT OTHER FUN
SOURCES SUCH AS TUITION FROM
STUDENTS ARE VERY SAVINGS THE
UNIVERSITY INTENDS TO.
ANCHOR AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN.
FUNDRAISERS LIKE THAT AND ON
THE RIGHT HAND SIDE.
S. PLAYS HOW THE UNIVERSITY
INTENDS TO SPEND THOSE FUNDS
OFFER COMPENSATION INCREASES.
I ENROLLMENT GROWTH STUDENT
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES THINGS OF
THAT NATURE.
OUR THIS BUDGET IS A LITTLE
DIFFERENT THEN THE GOVERNORS A
PROPOSAL IT IT IT IT IT
DISSIPATES MORE FUNDING THAN THE
GOVERNOR.
IS PROPOSING FOR EXAMPLE AT
THIS BUDGET DOES ASSUME A
TUITION INCREASE
IT ALSO SEEMS ADDITIONAL STATE
GENERAL FUND BUT.
WHEN WE LOOK AT THIS IN JANUARY
WE TRY TO SORT OF GAUGE UNDER
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET HOW MUCH
WOULD YOU NEVER YOU SEE HAVE TO
WORK WITH AND. WE GET SHOULD
HAVE ABOUT THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS TO WORK WITH AN EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN.
AND IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT COULD
THEY DO WITH A THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS
WE ESTIMATED THAT COULD COVER A
LOT OF THE COST INCREASES THEY
ANTICIPATE AND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
THAT INCLUDES ALL OF THE. SORT
OF WHAT THEY CALL THEIR
MANDATORY COSTS THAT MANDATORY
COST INCLUDES THINGS LIKE
BENEFIT COST INCREASES.
SOME BASIC SERVER COST
INCREASES
AND AT SOME COMPENSATION
INCREASES SPECIFICALLY FOR.
REP FOR REPRESENTED STAFF.
BUT COULD ALSO COVER A LOT OF
THE ENROLLMENT GROWTH THAT THE
UNIVERSITY IS ANTICIPATING.
AND SO THAT WAS WELL STUDENT
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AND EVEN
AFTER THAT WOULD LEAVES OF ABOUT
SEVENTY MILLION DOLLARS LEFT
OVER FOR OTHER SET OF
PRIORITIES.
THAT THE UNIVERSITY HAS
IDENTIFIED SUCH AS COMPENSATION
INCREASES FOR FACULTY AND ON
REPRESENTED STAFF SOME
ADDITIONAL ROMAN GROWTH ACADEMIC
EXCELLENT PROGRAMS THINGS OF
THAT NATURE THEY CAN FIND ALL OF
THOSE ADDITIONAL. OF PROGRAMS
BUT IT'S A THAT HAVE TO
PRIORITIZE AND.
OF THAT AMOUNT WOULD DAYS TO
REFUND UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET.
I DO THINKING ABOUT FUNDING FOR
YOU SEE EITHER A FEW APPROACHES
YOU CAN TAKE WHAT APPROACH YOU
COULD TAKE HIS OF IT AND I THINK
IT'S A GOOD APPROACH THE
COMMITTEE HAS TAKEN IN PAST
YEARS A SORT OF. YOU KNOW USE
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET A SORT OF
A STARTING POINT AND IF YOU
THINK OF THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
AS A STARTING POINT I THINK OUR
POINT HERE IS THAT. UNDER THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
YOU SEE SERVE HAS A WORKLOAD
BUDGET THEY HAVE ENOUGH TO SORT
OF KEEP THE LIGHTS ON SEARCH
SPEAK.
AND SO THE ONE WAY TO THINK
ABOUT THIS IS WHAT ADDITIONAL
COST INCREASES BEYOND THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
WOULD BE LIKE TO SORT OF FIND
HOW MUCH MORE ENROLLMENT GROWTH
WHAT COMPENSATION INCREASES
THINGS OF THAT NATURE. YOU CAN
ALSO YOU DON'T HAVE TO START THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL YOU COULD
START FROM SORT OF THE GROUND UP
AND TOOK A LOOK AT THESE COST
INCREASES AND SAY WHICH OF THESE
OUR HIGHEST PRIORITY. AND HOW
WOULD WE LIKE TO.
.
JULY COST AMONG THE VARIOUS
FUNDS SOURCES AND IN THAT
PRACTICE WE THINK YOU MIGHT FIND
THAT SOME OF THESE. AREAS ARE OF
HIGH PRIORITY TO YOU SOME OF
THESE AREAS MIGHT NOT BE. FOR
EXAMPLE IN PAST YEARS WE'VE
NOTED CONCERNS WITH THE ACADEMIC
EXCELLENCE PROPOSAL THAT YOU SEE
HAS MADE IT'S IT'S A IT'S A
PROPOSAL THEY'VE MADE FOR THE
PAST FEW YEARS. AND IN GENERAL
WE FOUND THAT PROPOSAL HASN'T
HAD A LOT OF JUSTIFICATION A LOT
OF BACK UP AND HOW CAMPUSES
WOULD SPEND THE FUNDS.
THEY PROVIDED A FEW EXAMPLES OF
HOW THEY MIGHT USE THOSE FUNDS
BUT IT'S ULTIMATELY UP FOR THE
CAMPUS IS TO.
BECAUSE OF THAT
WE'RE CONCERNED AND IT MIGHT NOT
EXACTLY MEET YOUR PRIORITIES AND
YOU COULD PROBABLY DOESN'T MAKE
THAT FUNDING A LITTLE MORE. A
LITTLE MORE DID SORT OF ENSURE
THAT ITS MEETING YOUR PRIORITIES
FOR THE SYSTEM.
I'M AND AS YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT
FUNDING LEVELS WE ALSO RECOMMEND
THAT RATHER THAN SERVE THINK
ABOUT WELL HOW MUCH OF THIS IS A
FACING CHRIS HOW MUCH OF THIS IS
A TUITION BY OUT YOU COULD THINK
MORE AGAIN. CAREFULLY ABOUT BY
COST INCREASES YOU'D LIKE TO
SORT OF SUPPORT.
AND THAT MIGHT PROVIDE A LITTLE
MORE DETAILED AND MORE FOCUSED
DISCUSSION.
.
FOR EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
I DID WANT TO TOUCH ON MOMENT
ISSUES JUST A LITTLE BIT BECAUSE
I KNOW THAT THIS IS A TOPIC OF
INTEREST TO THE LEGISLATURE. I'M
WE DID I JUST WANT TO REMIND THE
COMMITTEE YOU PROBABLY REMEMBER
THAT THE SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
BUDGET DID SEVEN ROMAN TARGET
FOR THE EIGHTEEN NINETEEN YEAR.
SO THAT A MOMENT TARGET IS IN
PLACE AN ORDER DEFINE THAT YOU
SEE REDIRECTED SOME. FUNDS
WITHIN THEIR EXISTING SUPPORT
BUDGET TO SUPPORT THAT GROWTH
I'M AND YOUR AGENDA ON PAGE
SEVEN PER AT THE BOTTOM OF PAGE
SEVEN PROVIDES A HIGH LEVEL
SUMMARY OF.
WHAT FUNDS YOU SEE SPECIFICALLY
IS HOPING TO REDIRECT TO
INTENDING TO REDIRECT FOR A
MOMENT GROSS?
I ONE VERY TECHNICAL THING JUST
A POINT OF THE COMMITTEE EIGHT
MILLION OF THAT COMES FROM THE.
OFFICE THE PRESIDENT'S BUDGET
AND WE RECOMMEND THAT IF YOU IF
YOU APPROVE OF THIS PLAN THAT
YOU SUBTRACT THAT AMOUNT FROM
THE YOU CO P. LINE ITEM AND
TRANSFERRED TO THE CAMPUSES THAT
WOULD ALLOW YOU SEE THIS OUR
SHIFT THE FUNDS BACK TO THE
CAMPUSES.
I DO THINKING FORWARD ABOUT YOUR
DECISIONS REGARDING NINETEEN
TWENTY AND AND BEYOND THAT.
I'M WE JUST THINK THOSE
DISCUSSIONS ARE WRAPPED UP IN
SOME OF YOUR.
CONSIDERATIONS FOR FRESHMAN
ELIGIBILITY MY UNDERSTANDING IS
YOU YOU HAD OF THAT PRETTY A
DETAILED DISCUSSION ON THAT ON
AND THE CSU HEARINGS I WANT GO
THROUGH THAT AGAIN. I WAS VERY
SIMILAR TO YOU SEE WE DO THINK
THAT THEY ARE DRAWING FROM
BEYOND THEIR THEIR SERVE MASTER
PLAN PULLS.
I'M AND SO AGAIN A SORT OF A
QUESTION FOR YOU OF WHETHER OR
NOT YOU LIKE TO EXPAND
ELIGIBILITY OR OR SCALE BACK
ELIGIBILITY AND THAT. WILL HAVE
AN EFFECT ON WHAT YOU DO FOR FUN
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY.
REGARDLESS THREE DECISIONS WE DO
THINK THERE'S AN ADVANTAGE THE
LEGISLATURE SORT OF ADOPTED FROM
A POLICY THAT WOULD GUIDES FOR
FUTURE OUT YOUR ENROLLMENT
DECISIONS WE DO THINK THERE'S
ADVANTAGE WHETHER OR NOT YOU
WANT TO. INCREASE OR DECREASE
THE TO SORT OF HAVE A FORMAL
POLICY IN PLACE.
THANK YOU.
S. UP OKAY.
YOU SHOULD HAVE IN FRONT OF YOU
A PACKET TITLED EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN BUDGET REQUEST
AND I WAS THINKING I WOULD JUST
GIVE YOU A LITTLE BIT OF CONTEXT
FOR OUR BUDGET REQUESTS AS WE
MOVE FORWARD THE FOR.
THE SECOND SLIDE TO THEIR HOUSE
TO UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
OVERALL BUDGET. AND ON THE RIGHT
HAND SIDE OF THE PAGE YOU'LL SEE
OUR THE TOTAL BUDGET FOR
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA IS.
A MASSIVE COMPARED TO MOST STATE
AGENCIES WHERE THIRTY FOUR AND A
HALF BILLION DOLLARS. OF THIS
OUR MEDICAL CENTERS ARE ABOUT A
THIRD.
AND.
COR FUNDS THAT WHICH ARE THE
FUND THAT.
BOB PAY FOR CAMPUS OPERATIONS
THAT PAPER THE INSTRUCTION.
FOUR PERCENT OF THE TOTAL UC
BUDGET AND YOU'LL SEE THOSE
REPRESENTED ON THE LEFT HAND
SIDE OF THE PAGE.
COR FUNDS ARE CURRENTLY MADE UP
ABOUT FORTY PERCENT FROM STATE
FUNDS AND WITH THE REMAINDER
COMING FROM PRIMARILY STUDENT
FEES.
A THIRTY EIGHT PERCENT FROM
TUITION.
AND.
.
ALMOST NINETEEN PERCENT FROM.
NON RESIDENT TUITIONS WE GET
OVER JUST ABOUT A BILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR FROM NON RESIDENT
SUPPLEMENTAL TUITION.
SO THAT'S.
THOSE THAT'S THE CONTEXT WITHIN
WHICH YOU'LL BE MAKING SOME OF
THE BUDGET DECISIONS AND TOTAL
COR FUNDS AND SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN.
ARE ABOUT THREE POINT FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS.
SO ONSITE THREE YOU HAVE A
DIFFERENT REPRESENTATION OF
WHAT'S SHOWN ON PAGE EIGHT OF
YOUR AGENDA THESE ARE THE.
PROPOSED CHANGES IN REVENUES AND
EXPENDITURES FOR THE UC SYSTEM
IN NINETEEN NINETEEN. THIS WAS
INITIALLY PRESENTED TO THE
REGENTS AT THEIR JANUARY MEETING
BUT THEY DECIDED TO HOLD OFF ON
VOTING ON IT BECAUSE IT INCLUDED
A TUITION INCREASE AND THEY
REQUESTED THAT WE COME BACK THAT
THE LEGISLATURE. FOR A BUYOUT OF
DOT TUITION INCREASE.
THE UC SYSTEM HAS CERTAIN
MANDATORY COSTA WE MUST PAY FOR
THIS INCLUDE. OUR OUR.
.
OUR. CONTRACTUALLY NEGOTIATED.
PAYING CROESUS FOR UNIONS THEY
INCLUDE MERITS FOR FACULTY.
OF A CERTAIN HEALTH BENEFITS AND
RETIREMENT BENEFITS FOR.
BUT FOR RETIREES AND CURRENT
EMPLOYEES. THAT REALLY SHOULD BE
FUNDED.
.
AND NON SALARY PRICE INCREASES
THEIR REGULAR INFLATION R. COSTA
OCCURS ON.
THINGS THAT ARE PURCHASED BY
THE UNIVERSITY.
AND THESE TOGETHER TOTAL ABOUT
HUNDRED. AND THIRTY SIX MILLION
WHICH IS MORE THAN WHAT THE
GOVERNOR HAS PROPOSED IN HIS
BUDGET AND WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL
TOTHE GOVERNOR. FOR THE FUNDS
THAT WE HAVE BEEN PROVIDED IN
THE.
PROPOSED DANTON BUDGET BUT WE
DO NEED ADDITIONAL FUNDS.
WE'RE ALSO REQUESTING OR WE ARE
ALSO HOPING FOR A.
.
THREE PERCENT INCREASE FOR
FACULTY AND NON REPRESENTED
STAFF.
.
UC FACULTY SALARIES ARE AT THIS
POINT EIGHT POINT FOUR PERCENT
BELOW OUR MARKET COMPARISON
INSTITUTES.
AND THAT'S NOT ACCOUNTING FOR
THE TWENTY PERCENT.
COST OF LIVING HIGHER COST OF
LIVING IT WITH IN CALIFORNIA
THAN IN MANY OF THE OTHER PLACES
TO WHICH WE. LOSE OUR FACULTY.
SO WE REALLY DO FEEL THAT WE
NEED TO OFFER OUR FACULTY A PAY
INCREASE IN OUR TO RETAIN THE
BEST AND THE BRIGHTEST MINDS.
ALSO OUR FACULTY ARE A GOOD
INVESTMENT FOR THE STATE AS THEY
BRING AND. JUST LAST YEAR THEY
BROUGHT IN TWO POINT NINE
BILLION IN FEDERAL GRANTS TO THE
STATE THAT WOULD NOT HAVE COME
INTO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WITHOUT OUR FACULTY.
AND THE RESEARCH THAT THEY
CONDUCT SO THE MORE WE HAVE
BRIGHT FACULTY WHO CAN GET THOSE
GRANTS INTO THE STATE. THE MORE
THEY'RE SORT OF PAYING FOR THEIR
OWN OPERATIONS AND PROVIDING A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF BENEFITS
THROUGH THEIR RESEARCH. WHICH
ENDS UP HELPING THE PUBLIC.
.
ALRIGHT SO.
THE NEXT.
SLIDE INCLUDES OUR ACTUAL
ADDITIONAL BUDGET SORRY ON
WASN'T SPEAKING IN THE MIKE. THE
NEXT SLIDE SLIDE FOR INCLUDES
OUR.
ADDITIONAL BUDGET REQUESTS ON
TOP OF THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WE
ARE REQUESTING A SEVENTY MILLION
DOLLAR BUYOUT OF STUDENT TUITION
AND STUDENT SERVICES BEING
INCREASES.
US SIXTY MILLION OF THAT IS
TUITION AND TEN MILLION THIS FOR
STUDENTS SERVICES FREE.
I WERE ALSO REQUESTING TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TO ADDRESS
THE IMPACTS OF REGION RECENT.
A.
ENROLLMENT GROWTH ABOVE WHAT WAS
FUNDED BY. THE STATE TEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR NEW ENROLLMENT
GROWTH IN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN ON
TOP OF THE FUNDS THAT WILL BE
REDIRECTED. FROM. WITHIN UC'S
BUDGET INCLUDING DATE MILLION
DOLLARS FROM YOU CO PIECE
BUDGET.
AND THIRTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
FOR CRITICAL DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE PROJECTS.
AND SLIDE FIVE SHOWS ADDITIONAL
CONTACTS FOR.
WHAT?
?
HOW YOU SEE HAS BEEN FUNDED FOR
THE LAST
SEVENTEEN YEARS OR SO? BACK IN
TWO THOUSAND TWO THOUSAND ONE WE
RECEIVED SEVENTY FIVE PERCENT
ARE FUNDING FOR CAMPUSES FROM
THE STATE.
WITH STUDENT BEES COVERING
ABOUT TWENTY FIVE PERCENT.
NOW STUDENT FEES ARE COVERING
ABOUT SIXTY PERCENT OF OUR
CAMPUS OPERATIONS IN THE STATE
IS CONTRIBUTING ABOUT FORTY
PERCENT.
SO WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THE
THREE PERCENT INCREASE PROVIDED
BY THE GOVERNOR IT APPLIES TO
THE FORTY PERCENT.
OF OUR CAMPUS OPERATIONS IT
DOESN'T APPLY THAT THE SIXTY
PERCENT OF PAYS FOR OTHER FUNDS.
SO IN FACT THE THREE PERCENT
INCREASE ENDS UP BEING WAY LESS
THAN INFLATION BECAUSE IT'S
ABOUT ONE POINT THREE PERCENT
GROWTH ON OUR ENTIRE CORPS
BUDGET. FOR THE CAMPUS AS.
WHICH IS WHY WE WERE PROPOSING A
TUITION INCREASE TO ALSO GET.
THE INFLATIONARY COST PAID FOR
BY THE OTHER COMPONENT OF THE
BUDGET COVERED.
AND WE'RE HOPING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WILL BUY OUT THAT.
BUT TUITION INCREASE THE
AVAILABLE COR FUNDS PER STUDENT
SHOWN THERE ON THE LEFT. HAVE
GONE DOWN.
WHEN ADJUSTED FOR INFLATION AND
ALSO BECAUSE YOU SEE HAS ADDED
NINETY TWO THOUSAND NEW STUDENTS
SINCE TWO THOUSAND.
SO THE PUMP FUNDS AVAILABLE PER
STUDENT HAVE GONE DOWN
DRAMATICALLY. EVEN THOUGH OUR
STUDENTS ARE PAYING A LOT MORE
NOW TO ATTEND THE UNIVERSITY
THEM PREVIOUSLY.
OUT OF THE BARS THERE ON SHOWN
ON THE LEFT ALSO. WE HAVE TO PAY
FOR CERTAIN COSTS.
DOT.
OTHER.
.
OTHER UNIVERSITIES MIGHT NOT
HAVE TO PAY FOR BY INCLUDING.
US CS USE SO WE ARE COVERING ON
BOND PAYMENTS OUT OF OUR OWN
BUDGET OUR CORE BUDGET PAYS FOR
BOND PAYMENTS.
ON OUR CAMPUSES UP THREE HUNDRED
FORTY SIX MILLION ESTIMATED IN
CURRENT YEAR COMING OUT OF FUN
STUFF WOULD OTHERWISE GO THE
STUDENTS. ARE PAYING FOR A PASS
CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECTS.
THAT DEBT WAS SHIFTED ONTO THE
UC BUDGET. BOKKEN I THINK TWENTY
TEN. AND WE ARE NOW.
PAYING FOR THAT.
ALSO RECOVER OUR THE PAYMENTS
INTO THE UC RETIREMENT PROGRAM
OUT OF OUR.
OWN FUNDS COR FUNDS ARE
CONTRIBUTING ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED
NINETY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
CURRENTLY.
ONE POINT SEVEN BILLION COMING
FROM ALL OF OUR FUNDS.
GOING INTO UC RP ANNUALLY.
AND OF COURSE ENROLLMENT HAS
GONE UP DURING THE SAME PERIOD
OF TIME.
SLIGHT SIX PROVIDES YOU WITH
SOME CONTEXT ON OUR TUITION
AMOUNTS.
OF FOR THE LAST SEVENTEEN YEARS
OR SO. UP IF WE DO RECEIVED THE
BUY OUT OF TUITION STUDENTS
WOULD ACTUALLY SEE A SMALL
DECREASE.
IN THEIR TUITION AMOUNTS BY
SIXTY DOLLARS ANNUALLY BECAUSE
CURRENTLY.
WE HAVE A CHARGE CALLED FOR A
LAWSUIT CULT LIQUID I THINK THAT
WE ARE STILL PAYING OFF FOR.
AND THE LAST PAYMENT ON THE
LAWSUIT WILL BE MADE IN FALL
TWENTY EIGHTEEN. AFTER THE
LAWSUIT IS FULLY PAID OFF THE
REGION'S WERE GOING TO CONTINUE
THE CHARGE BUT THEN PUT IT THE
WORD INSTRUCTION.
THAT WAS THE REGION'S PROPOSAL
FOR THE TUITION INCREASE.
AND WE'RE HOPING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WILL BY IT OUT SO
THAT WE CAN PUT THOSE FUNDS TO
WORK CAMPUS INSTRUCTION. AND
HIGHER HIGHER MORE LECTURERS AND
FACULTY WITH THAT.
OUR TUITION AND STUDENT
SERVICES BE FUNDS ARE CRITICAL
TO MEETING THE. NEEDS OF THE
UNIVERSITY TO PROVIDE A QUALITY
EDUCATION FOR OUR STUDENTS.
AND TO SLIDE SEVEN. THIS ARE
REFLECTS THE OUR REQUEST FOR THE
ADDITIONAL TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS. DO THEY CARE STUDENTS
THAT WERE BROUGHT IN ON TOP OF
THE TARGET SET BY THE
LEGISLATURE. IN AUG TWENTY
FIFTEEN AND TWENTY SIXTEEN.
SO THE LOW LET'S JUST THE BUDGET
BILLING WHICH FOR THOSE YEARS.
STATE AT THAT THE UC HAD TO
ENROLL AT LEAST
OF FIVE THOUSAND AND THEN TWO
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED NEW
STUDENTS.
OUR CAMPUSES.
.
MADE A LOT OF OFFERS BECAUSE
THEY WANTED TO MEET THOSE.
MEET THAT ON ENROLLMENT TARGETS
AND WE ENDED UP ENROLLING.
UP ABOUT TEN THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED A NEW. CALIFORNIA
RESIDENT UNDERGRADS DURING THAT
TIME AND WE ARE REQUESTING.
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TO.
COVER THE MARGINAL COST OF
INSTRUCTION FOR THOSE STUDENTS
SO THAT. WE CAN HIRE MORE
LECTURERS AND FACULTY AND.
STUDENT SUPPORT STAFF. TO REALLY
OFFERED THEM THE SAME QUALITY OF
SERVICE THAT.
PRIOR GENERATIONS IN PRIOR YEARS
OF STUDENTS HAD AT UC.
WHEN MOVING ON IN THE
PRESENTATION TO SLIDE EIGHT.
THE IMPACT OF NOT HAVING
MARGINAL COST OF INSTRUCTION
COVERED.
FULLY AND THE IMPACT OF HAVING
THE UC CUT.
BY ONE BILLION DOLLARS FROM TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT TO TWENTY ELEVEN
EVEN THOUGH THAT. FUNDING HAS
NOW BEEN RESTORED WE'RE ABOUT AT
THE SAME LEVEL OF FUNDING AS WE
WERE THEN. AND WE'RE ACTUALLY AT
THE SAME LEVEL OF STATE FUNDING
US WE WERE BACK IN TWO THOUSAND.
THE IMPACT IS THAT STUDENT
SATISFACTION
APPEARS TO BE DECLINING MORE
STUDENTS ARE SAYING THAT THEY'RE
NOT CERTAIN IF THEY WOULD COME
TO THE UC AGAIN AND IT WASN'T
THE KIND OF EXPERIENCE. BUT THEY
WERE TOLD THAT IT WOULD BE BY.
THEIR PARENTS ARE.
OF FAMILY FRIENDS WHO WENT
BEFORE THEM.
AND SHOT QUITE.
DISTRESSINGLY BETWEEN TWO
THOUSAND SIX AND TWENTY SIXTEEN
THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS WHO SAID
THEY COULD NOT GET INTO THEIR
MAJOR. WENT UP FROM THREE
PERCENT TO THIRTEEN PERCENT.
THIS IS BECAUSE THE FACULTY ONLY
CERTAIN NUMBER STUDENTS CAN GET
INTO A MAJOR IF THE FACULTY
HAVEN'T BEEN HIRED.
AND.
THERE ARE CERTAIN MAJORS WHERE
STUDENTS WANT TO GO BECAUSE THEY
THINK THAT THAT'S.
THAT WILL LEAD TO A WELL PAYING
JOB AFTER THEY GRADUATE OR IT'S
THEIR PERSONAL INTEREST.
AND THEY REALLY WANT TO STUDY
THAT SUBJECT AREA BUT THEY FIND
THAT THEY GET INTO YOU SEE. AND
THEY CAN'T GET INTO THE MAJOR
AND THAT'S
A VERY DISAPPOINTING EXPERIENCE
ALSO MORE STUDENTS ARE FINDING
THAT THEY FEEL LESS CONNECTED
THE FACULTY.
WHO ARE?
TEACHING THEM BECAUSE THOSE
CLASSES ARE SO MUCH LARGER
INSTEAD OF BEING IN A CLASS WITH
FORTY STUDENTS OR SIXTY STUDENTS
LEARN A CLASS WITH HUNDRED AND
FIFTY OR TWO HUNDRED STUDENTS.
AND THEY DON'T GET ANY FACE TO
FACE TIME PERSONALLY WITH THE
FACULTY MEMBER.
THEY FEEL LESS CONNECTED TO THE.
TO THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
INSTRUCTING THEM.
AND ALSO ON SLIDE NINE.
WHILE WE'RE EXTREMELY HAPPY
THAT.
.
ARE YOU OUR M. STUDENTS HAVE
BEEN GOING UP FROM ABOUT TWENTY
TWO PERCENT IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT TO ABOUT.
THIRTY THREE PERCENT AND TWENTY
SEVENTEEN.
FOR THE FIRST TIME EVER WE SAW
GOD GRADUATIONRATES.
A DROP FOR YOU ARE AND STUDENTS
IN THE LAST ABOUT DECADE.
SO IF YOU LOOK ON THE
SPREADSHEET THERE. ON THE RIGHT
THE AFRICAN AMERICAN FIVE YEAR
GRADUATION RATE TOOK A SLIGHT.
PERCENTAGE.
DROP.
AS DID DE UM AMERICAN INDIAN AND
THE HISPANIC LATINO GRADUATION
RATES ALL DROPPED.
WHEN YOU'RE OVER NEXT
AND DOC MEANS THE. THE TWENTY
TEN THERE MEANS THAT THOSE WERE
THE STUDENTS WHO STARTED STARTED
IN FALL TWENTY TEN.
ITS LOOKING AT THEIR GRADUATION
RATES.
THIS IS A REAL IMPACT ON
STUDENTS.
OF.
OF NOT HAVING THE FACULTY TO
TEACH THEM OR HAVING FEWER
SUPPORT STAFF
DO ADVISED THEM. PROVIDE
FINANCIALLY COUNSELING.
AND SO FORTH.
SO WE ARE SEEING SOME REAL
IMPACTS AND WE WOULD WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THE
LEGISLATURE TO PROVIDE US WITH
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TO
TAKE CARE OF OUR EXISTING
STUDENTS. AND TEN MILLION
DOLLARS TO CONTINUE AND ROLLING
DO STUDENTS IN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
TO PROVIDE MORE ACCESS TO THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SYSTEM.
AND WITHOUT ALL PIXEL QUESTIONS.
MR MEDINA.
BEN COULDN'T COULDN'T PROVIDE
FOR FOR ME.
I'M NOT SURE I UNDERSTOOD
CHARGE.
OUT OF THAT INDICATE. DROP.
YEAH GRADUATION RATES WITH YOU.
WHAT?
YES. WOULD BE THE TRACK WITH A
BIT MORE YEAH I WILL WALK YOU
THROUGH IT SO ON. THE.
A COLUMN ETHNICITY IS OBVIOUSLY
THE ETHNICITY OF THE STUDENT A
SELF STATED TIME TO GRADUATIONS
THE NUMBER OF YEARS IT TOOK THEM
FROM ENROLLING FIRST TO
GRADUATING. AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE COLUMN THAT SAYS TWENTY TEN
THOSE ARE STUDENTS THAT STARTED
IN FALL TWENTY TEN.
.
AND IF YOU LOOK AT THE
GRADUATION RATE THEIR TWENTY TEN
AND THE COHORT THAT STARTED IN
TWENTY ELEVEN. FOR AFRICAN
AMERICAN THE FIVE YEAR
GRADUATION RATE DROPPED
SLIGHTLY.
THE FOUR YEAR GRADUATION RATE
ALSO DROPPED TO SAY.
THE CAPTAIN.
FORTY SIX.
QUIRK QUIRK
TWO THOUSAND NINE.
FOR YOUR RATE IS FORTY SIX.
IS THAT.
FORTY SIX.
SENATE.
OF AFRICAN AMERICAN TO THE WORLD
IN TWO THOUSAND
WE DIDN'T FOR YEAR. THAT'S
CORRECT.
SO IF YOU.
IMPROVED IN TWO THOUSAND TEN.
SO IT DID IMPROVE YES THE FOUR
YEAR GRADUATION RATE AND TWENTY
TWO TWELVE WAS HIGHER THAN TWO
THOUSAND NINE SO THE OVERALL
RATE HAS BEEN GOING UP. BUT WE
DID SEE A SLIGHT DROP IN THE
FIVE YEAR GRADUATION RATE.
AND THE.
IF WE COULD WE LOWER LA I I
WOULD VERY MUCH LIKE TO SEE. A.
THE GRAPH ON PAGE NINE.
OVERLAID. WITH THE.
WITH STATE INVESTMENT
CAN WE DO THAT CAN YOU GET THAT
FOR ME YES I CAN GET THAT FOR
YOU SIR LIKE I THINK THAT WOULD
MAKE A GROUP WHICH.
IN OTHER WORDS I I WANT TO SEE.
HOW?
?
RELATIONSHIP.
BETWEEN THE STATE INVESTMENT IN
YOU SEE.
THE INCREASED
MINORITY.
INVESTMENT AND WE OVERLAYS
THOSE.
TOGETHER.
I THINK WE WOULD SEE A DECLINE.
A IN STATE INVESTMENT IN UC AS
WE SEE. AN INCREASE IN MINORITY
ENROLLMENT
SO IF IF WE COULD PROVIDE ME
WITH THAT YES I WILL PROVIDE YOU
WITH THAT SIR.
APPRECIATE.
ANNA AND I WAS HEARTENED TO
HEAR.
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S.
SAY THAT WE CAN CONSIDER THE
GOVERNOR'S.
.
PROPOSED BUDGET PROPOSAL AS JUST
THAT AS A STARTING OFF POINT.
IT'S VERY HARD TO HEAR THAT.
AND AS A A PLACE FOR MOVING FROM
THERE.
SO I'M HEARTENED
THIS MORNING.
THANK YOU.
MR MARTZ ITCHING THANK YOU.
QUESTION FOR THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA.
DIRECTING YOUR ATTENTION TO THE
GRAPH ON PAGE FIVE OF YOUR HAND
OUT.
ARE THE GRAPH ON THE LEFT HAND
SIDE.
WELL YOU HAVE THE.
.
COR FUNDS
FROM TWO THOUSAND TO.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN.
.
SO THE STATE GENERAL FUNDS.
BOTH IN TWO THOUSAND AND IN.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN IS AROUND
THREE BILLION.
THAT'S CORRECT SIR IN FACT THE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN AMOUNT IS UP
ABOUT EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS MORE
THAN IN TWO THOUSAND. NOT
INFLATION ADJUSTED OKAY BUT.
.
AND TERMS OF. YOUR POINT THAT
THE THE PORTION OF THE STATE
GENERAL FUND DROPPING FROM
SEVENTY FIVE PERCENT.
TO FORTY PERCENT.
AND THAT SEVENTEEN YEAR TIME
SPAN.
THAT AT LEAST IN TERMS OF. THE
NOMINAL DOLLARS TO.
THAT IS.
PRIMARILY BECAUSE OF THE
INCREASING.
BARS THEY INCREASING BECAUSE I
COSTS OF THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA.
SEC WRECKED.
A THAT'S CORRECT SERB BETWEEN.
TWO THOUSAND AND TWENTY
SEVENTEEN THERE WAS OBVIOUSLY
SEVENTEEN YEARS OF INFLATION
CAUGHT ON COSTS FOR THE
UNIVERSITY WE ALSO ADDED. NINETY
TWO THOUSAND STUDENTS DURING
THAT TIME WHO ALL NEEDED
EXPENDITURE AND TWENTY. TEN UC
PUT IN PLACE
OF.
A REINSTATED THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA RETIREMENT PROGRAM
PAYMENTS WHICH ARE NOW FOURTEEN
PERCENT OF PAYROLL FOR THE
EMPLOYER. CONTRIBUTION AND
I BELIEVE IT WAS.
.
IT'S A.
ABOUT IT'S OVER FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN THAT WE HAVE TO PAY.
TOWARD YOU SEE OUR PIECE OF
THERE'S COSTS
THAT CAME ON LINE THAT DIDN'T
EXIST BACK IN TWO THOUSAND FOR
THE UNIVERSITY. IN ADDITION TO
THE UC RP COSTS WE NOW HAVE TO
PAY FOR THE CAPITAL OUTLAY BONDS
WHICH AFTER TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
FINANCIAL CRISIS WERE SHIFTED
ONTO THE UC'S BUDGET. FROM THE
STATE SO WE ARE NOW MAKING DE
INTEREST AND PRINCIPAL PAYMENTS
ON. CAPITOL AWFULLY PROJECTS
CONSTRUCTED FOR THE UNIVERSITY
OKAY I'LL TRY TO KEEP UP WITH
EVEN WITH IT. THERE ABOUT WHAT
ARE THE TOP THREE. ACCOST
DRIVERS FROM TWO THOUSAND TO TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THE TOP THREE
COST DRIVERS I WOULD SAY WERE
THE INCREASED OUR ENROLLMENT BY
NINETY TWO THOUSAND STUDENTS.
THE UC RP YOU SEE RETIREMENT
PROGRAM PAYMENTS WHICH ARE NOW
FOUR HUNDRED NINETY FOUR
MILLION.
ENCOURAGE YOUR.
AND THE BOND PAYMENTS WERE TARA
THREE HUNDRED FORTY SIX MILLION
ANNUALLY.
AND THAT'S FOR THE CAPITAL
OUTLAY.
YES.
AND SO THOSE ARE COMING OUT OF
THAT.
.
LARGELY OUT OF THAT STATE
FUNDING.
SLICE OF THE PIE FOR THE CAPABLY
OKAY AND THEN.
TURNING TO THE ENROLLMENT
GROWTH THE NINETY TWO THOUSAND
ADDITIONAL STUDENTS.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND THAT THAT
INCLUDES BOTH. CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS AS WELL AS OUT OF
STATE AND FOREIGN STUDENTS.
A I BELIEVE SO YES.
.
AND.
AYE IT'S RELATED TO.
YOUR CHART ON PAGE SEVEN BUT THE
NINETY TWO THOUSAND STUDENTS DID
DO YOU WERE.
WELL LIKE I SAID THE CHART ON
PAGE SEVEN IS.
STRICTLY FOR CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS.
YES THOUGH SO THOSE SLIDE SEVEN
ONLY INCLUDES CALIFORNIA
RESIDENT OKAY AND AND THAT
INCLUDES BOTH UNDERGRADUATES AND
GRADUATE STUDENTS.
OH YES THIS IS BOTH OUR CALVET
OF CALIFORNIA UNDERGRADUATES.
ACTUALLY.
I BELIEVE CERT THIS.
CHART IS ACTUALLY FOR
UNDERGRADUATES ONLY.
OUR RANGE.
BUT.
.
IN TERMS OF THE.
AND ROAMING GROWTH.
GOT BEING THE NUMBER ONE COST
DRIVER FOR THE INCREASING.
BAR GRAPHS.
AT IT AT LEAST AND THEN IT IS IS
NOT FAIR TO SAY THAT.
.
THAT THE.
DRAMATICALLY INCREASING TUITION
REVENUES.
AND SIGNIFICANT PART COVERED
THOSE THEN ROAMING GROWTH GIVEN
THAT THIS ALSO INCLUDES ADDED
STAY STUDENTS AND THE THE
FOSTER.
OF THAT'S CORRECT REVIEWS
TUITION INCREASES AND WE'VE
ADDED NONRESIDENT STUDENTS TO
HELP COVER THE UNIVERSITIES
INCREASING COSTS.
THE GOLDEN BAR THERE THAT STATES
YOU SEE GENERAL FUNDS THIS IS ON
SLIDE FIVE. ON THE LEFT THERE
THE UC GENERAL FUNDS IS OUR NON
RESIDENT SUPPLEMENTAL TUITION.
AND A FEW VERY SMALL.
OTHER FUNDING SOURCES LIKE
PATENT REVENUE BUT THERE'S A
BILLION DOLLARS OF NON RESIDENT
SUPPLEMENTAL TUITION DARKENED
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN.
AND SO WE USE THAT WE ENROLLED
THOSE NON RESIDENT STUDENTS.
IN ORDER TO HAVE THE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FROM THEM TO HELP
SUPPORT OUR RESIDENTS STUDENTS.
IF THEY PAY MORE THAN YES SIR
BECAUSE OF THEIR OWN EDUCATION
OKAY. AND THEN.
.
SWITCHING BACK TO THE GRAPH ON
PAGE SEVEN SO.
THE.
CAPS IS ADDING SEVEN THOUSAND
FOUR HUNDRED FULL TIME
ENROLLMENT CALIFORNIA
UNDERGRADUATES AT AND THIS IS
JUST.
FROM TWENTY FIFTEEN TO.
WHAT YEAR?
OF TWENTY FIFTEEN TO FALL.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN OKAY.
AND A JUDGE AT LEAST SAID THEY.
I KNOW CHARTS CAN BE DECEIVING
BUT THIS THIS DOES SEEM TO BE A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE AND.
AND.
CALIFORNIA UNDERGRADUATE
STUDENT ENROLLMENT IS THAT ALL
YET SAY BATTED.
SINCE TWENTY FIFTEEN TO NOW
WE'VE ADDED. TEN THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED CALIFORNIA RESIDENT
STUDENTS.
AND.
I WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT THE
BUDGETS OF TWENTY FIFTEEN AND
TWENTY SIXTEEN.
IT'S WITH.
SLIGHTLY LOWER THAN THE AGREED
UPON MARGINAL.
STATE COST FOR THOSE STUDENTS.
SO WHEN WE ENROLLED THE FIVE
THOUSAND NEW.
CALIFORNIA UNDERGRADS AND
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN OR FOR FALL
FIFTH SIXTEEN BECAUSE WE ALWAYS.
ARE IN ACTUAL INVOLVEMENT IN
ROLLING OFF THE STUDENTS AT BY
YEAR BEHIND FROM WHEN WE GET THE
FUNDS.
BUT WHEN WE'RE SPEAKING ABOUT
GETTING THE FUNDS.
IT WAS ABOUT A HALF THE
MARGINAL COST.
IT'S THE USUAL STATE CHAIR SO WE
GOT FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
STUDENT INSTEAD OF TEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER STUDENT. OUR
CALCULATED COSTS FOR EDUCATING
AN UNDERGRADUATE IS ABOUT
NINETEEN THOUSAND A YEAR. OF
WHICH NINE THOUSAND DOLLARS
COMES FROM STUDENT FEES AND THEN
THE TEN THOUSAND COMES.
HOPEFULLY FROM THE STATE.
NOW.
I AGREE WITH YOU CHAIR THAT.
THAT.
.
YOU KNOW THE NUMBER ONE CONCERN
WE HEAR FROM OUR CONSISTENT WAY
OF JUST SPEAKING FOR MYSELF FOR
MY CONSTITUENTS IT IS YOU KNOW
WHY IT IS SO MUCH HARDER FOR MY
KID TO GET INTO THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA NOW. THEN WHEN
THEIR PARENTS WENT.
EN AND WHICH IS WHY YOU KNOW I.
AGREE WITH THE CHAIR THAT TO
ONE OF OUR TOP PRIORITIES IS THE
ENROLLMENT ACCESS.
VERY.
I I'M I'M HEARING.
MORE MORE FROM THE CURRENTLY
ENROLLED THE UNIVERSITY STUDENTS
THAT.
THE THE THE OVERCROWDING NATURE
OF OF THE CAMPUSES AND SO I I'D
LIKE TO ACTUALLY TURN TO THE LA
JOH. NA I BELIEVE YOU HAD A
STUDY.
MAYBE ONE OR TWO YEARS AGO WERE
WHERE YOU FELT THAT WAY. I
BELIEVE ONE OF YOUR CONCLUSIONS
WITH WAS THAT THE. UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA CAMPUSES ACTUALLY HAD
ENOUGH CAPACITY TO ADMIT MORE.
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS IT IS IS
THAT STILL YOUR OPINION.
RIGHT SO WHAT THAT STUDY DID IS
IT WAS TRYING TO ANSWER WHETHER
OR NOT.
AND A NEW CAMPUS EITHER IT USE
YOUR SEARS HE WAS JUSTIFIED.
AND THE GAUGE THAT WE LOOK AT
BOTH AT THE EXISTING CAPACITY AS
WELL AS.
YOU KNOW WHAT IF THEY WERE TO
CONTINUE TO BUILD OUT THOSE
CAMPUSES BASED ON THEIR SORT OF
LONG RANGE PLANS AND WE FOUND
BASED ON THAT AND YOU CAMPUS
WASN'T JUSTIFIED BUT NOT JUST
WAS NOT JUSTIFIED IN TERMS OF
EXISTING SPACE WE DO THINK
THERE'S SOME EXISTING SPACE
THERE. ON A SEVERAL THE CAMPUSES
HOW ARE HAVE SOMEWHAT LOWER USE
AND THE FALL THROUGH SPRING.
AND THEIR LITTLE CAMPUSES ARE
ALSO THERE ABOUT ABOUT.
THAT THEIR THEIR SUMMER USES
BELOW KIND OF EXPECTATIONS THAT
THE LEGISLATURE HAS CERTAIN
PLACE
SO THERE'S ALSO OF CAPACITY TO
ADD IN THE SUMMER TOO SO THERE'S
SOME SOME WE DO THINK I HAVE
SOME EXISTING SPACE. THAT MORE
STUDENTS HOW DO YOU RECONCILE
THAT WITH YOU PERHAPS ANECDOTAL
LA TESTIMONY THEY'VE HEARD FROM
STUDENTS ABOUT. HOW THEY THAT
THEY FEEL THAT?
DID.%
THE CAMPS IS NOW ARE ARE READY
OVER ENROLLED IN AN OVER ENACTED
YET IT'S HARD TO GAUGE THE THE
DATA WE SEE WITH.
ANECDOTAL EXAMPLES WE I THINK
ONE.
.
EXPLANATION THAT WE THAT WE'VE
HEARD IS THAT.
.
SOMETIMES CAMPUSES ARE.
YOU KNOW VERY BUSY AT PEAK
TUESDAY AND THURSDAY YOU AND IN
THE AFTERNOON. OR THEY MAY HAVE
LESS USED FOR EXAMPLE ON FRIDAYS
THEY MIGHT HAVE LESS USE IN THE
SUMMER SO THAT SO I THINK
THAT'S.
PART OF WHAT POTENTIALLY COULD
BE GOING ON THERE WHEN WHEN WE
CERVANTES ANECDOTES OF
OVERCROWDING AND ON AND IT'S
ALSO IT'S ALSO I'M WITHIN
CERTAIN COURSES TO THERE MIGHT
BE CERTAIN VERY VERY HIGH DEMAND
COURSES WHERE. THERE IT'S HARD
TO GET INTO THERE MIGHT BE OTHER
COURSES WHERE THERE'S LESS
ENROLLMENT DEMAND SO THAT THAT
COULD BE ANOTHER ELEMENT THERE
TO. WHAT IS A UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA'S POSITION AS TO
WHETHER YOU HAVE?
SUFFICIENT CAPACITY TO TO ADD
FURTHER.
ENROLLMENT GROWTH
THANK YOU SIR FOR GIVING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO RESPOND. UP WE
HAVE LIMITED CAPACITY FOR NEW
INVOLVEMENT WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
TWO CAMPUSES THAT HAVE.
.
UNUSED CLASSROOM SPACE THERE ARE
BERKELEY AND LOS ANGELES WHERE
THESE CLASSROOMS AREN'T VERY OLD
BUILDINGS AND ACTUALLY SEAT
FEWER THAN FIFTEEN STUDENTS.
THEY'RE NO LONGER PRACTICAL FOR
THE MODERN UNIVERSITY. WHERE WE
HAVE TO HAVE FORTY FIFTY TWO
HUNDRED STUDENTS IN A SINGLE
CLASS?
THAT'S VERY EXPENSIVE TO RUN A
FIFTEEN STUDENT.
COURSE WE KNOW TO DEVOTE A
FACULTY MEMBER TO THAT SORT WE
REALLY NEED ON THOSE CAMPUSES
FUNDS TO. UP RENOVATE THE INSIDE
OF THOSE BUILDINGS WITH LARGER
CLASSROOM SPACE SO JUST LOOKING
AT SQUARE FOOTAGE THAT'S GOING
ON USED ON TWO CAMPUSES IS NOT
SUFFICIENT. UP I WOULD NOTE THAT
THE OTHER CAMPUSES ARE IT OUGHT
NINETY PERCENT OR ABOVE A
HUNDRED PERCENT SPACE
UTILIZATION FOR THEIR
CLASSROOMS.
THE SPACE UTILIZATION BEING
LOOKED AT MONDAY THROUGH FRIDAY
EIGHT AM THREE FIVE PM SO
THEY'RE RUNNING CLASSES. IN THE
EVENINGS SOME ARE OFFERING NOW
THEM ON WEEKENDS.
.
WE ARE TRYING TO INCREASE SUMMER
ENROLLMENT TO TAKE SOME PRESSURE
OFF OF THE FALL AND SPRING.
WE FIND STUDENTS VERY RESISTANT
TO ENROLL IN SUMMER AND THIS
COULD HAPPEN BECAUSE FEDERAL
FINANCIAL AID UP UNTIL THIS LAST
SUMMER AS NOT AVAILABLE.
SERVICE ENDED FOR AWHILE AND IT
AND CAL GRANTS ARE.
.
A STUDENT CAN CHOOSE
THE NUMBER TERM OR WHICH TERMS
WITHIN THE YEAR TO USE CALTRANS
FOR. MOST CHOOSE TO USE THEIR
CALDERON IN FALL AND SPRING. UP
BECAUSE IF THEY USE THEM IN THE
SUMMER AND THEY'RE EITHER NOT
AVAILABLE IN THE FALL OR SPRING
SO. SOMETHING FOR THE
LEGISLATURE PERHAPS TO EXAMINE
ON WHETHER OR NOT CAL GRANTS
COULD ALSO BE UTILIZED BY
STUDENTS IN SUMMER.
BUT SOME OF OUR CAMPUSES HAVE
PILOT PROJECTS TO TRY AND
INCREASE SUMMER ENROLLMENT AND
IN FACT SAN DIEGO OFFERED FREE
HOUSING FOR STUDENTS AND THEY
STILL DIDN'T GET TAKERS.
SO QUITE RADICAL.
WHO HAD KNOWS THAT THE STEPS
CAMPUS OF TRYING TO GO TO? TO
GET STUDENTS TO ENROLL IN SUMMER
BUT ON THEIR NOT REALLY GETTING
TAKERS FOR THAT.
pALRIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY I KNOW THAT SOMEONE MEMBER
LIMON HAS A HAS A QUESTION IS
WHEN INTERJECT ON TO THINGS THAT
THAT YOU'VE MENTIONED MR MARTZ
ITCHY. SO THE FIRST IS THAT I I
CONCUR THAT THE STATE HASN'T
STEPPED UP AND FUNDING THE THE
YOU SEE.
IN THE LAST DECADE IN.
A LOT WAS TO THE RECESSION WAS
AND IS HER HIDING HER.
MALICE EVEN BEFORE WE WERE HERE.
I DO THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT.
THAT THERE'S ANOTHER BILLION
DOLLARS THAT WE PUT INTO THE UC
FROM THE GENERAL FUND THROUGH
OUR CAL GRANT PROGRAM SO WHILE
TUITION HAS GONE UP.
TREMENDOUSLY THOUGHT ALL
FAMILIES THAT ARE PAYING THAT
FAMILIES ARE. BUT FOR MANY
STUDENTS IT'S THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WRITING A CHECK BE
OUR CAL GRANT PROGRAM SO. IT'S
ABOUT A BILLION DOLLARS THAT WE.
IF TO THE UC EVERY YEAR THROUGH
THE STUDENT COMMISSION.
AND THEN ON THE ON THE IN
ENROLLMENT ISSUE I I YOU KNOW
THIS BECAUSE YOU SAID.
I MISTER MURATSUCHI THIS IS AT
THE TOP PRIORITY AND WE TALK TO
THE CHANCELLOR'S AND AND THEY
HAVE FRANKLY GIVE A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT POSITION THAN YOU.
THEY'RE SAYING THAT THERE IS
CAPACITY WE HAVE TALKING TO THE
PRESIDENT AND YOUR TEAM OVER THE
YEARS AND AND AND YOU HAVE
ALLUDED TO THAT THERE IS
CAPACITY TO GROW. BY A FEW
THOUSAND STUDENTS PER YEAR
GRANTED WE ALSO HEAR THAT.
CURRENT.
PEOPLE ON CAMPUS WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO FOCUS
ON THE.
CLASS RATIOS AND AND OTHER ON
CAMPUS ON.
THAT NEEDS BUT I DON'T THINK
THOSE THINGS ARE MUTUALLY
EXCLUSIVE AND THAT IT'S
CERTAINLY SOMETHING WE GOING TO
CONTINUE. TO TO PRESS ON.
.
ESPECIALLY WITH SOME OF THE
CAMPUS AS YOU NOTED.
MERCED AND RIVERSIDE BUT ALSO
SET UP SOME OF THE OTHERS SAN
DIEGO AND.
DAVIS WE KNOW THAT THERE THERE
IS CAPACITY TO GROW AND AND I'M
LEAVING OUT A FEW OTHER SWELL
AND I WILL COME BACK WITH SOME
OTHER ISSUES BUT AS
SOMEONE I REALLY MUST.
THANK YOU AND. AND AND AS
SOMEONE WHO WORKED THERE.
SPACE IS ALWAYS COVERED AND AND
I MEAN EVERYONE WAS USING
STEPPED LOUNGES.
EXTRA ROOMS AND LIBRARIES TO
HOST A CLASSROOM SO I.
I MEAN THAT'S CHANGED A LOT
WHERE IT'S REALLY HARD TO GET.
A CLASSROOM IF YOU'RE NOT A
REGULAR CLASS.
.
THAT MEETS ON A WEEKLY BASIS AND
YOU NEED IT FOR OTHER PURPOSES.
MY QUESTION ACTUALLY HAS TO DO
WITH HURT NUMBER SIX.
OKAY ON PAGE SIX I.
AND IF YOU LOOK AT THIS CHARTER
YOU COULD IMMEDIATELY SEE THAT
THERE WERE TWO THREE. YEAR
PERIODS
WHERE.
THE INCREASE IN TUITION WENT UP.
SIGNIFICANTLY.
I'M MUCH MORE SO THAN ALL THE
OTHER YEARS ADDED UP.
AND THOSE THREE PERIODS ALSO
COINCIDED WITH ROUGH SPOTS IN
OUR STATE'S ECONOMY. AND THEY
COINCIDED WITH KEY TWELVE SEEN
MAJOR CUTS.
AND I AS YOU LOOK AT THIS YOU
CAN ALSO ANTICIPATE THAT.
WE AS A STATE WILL HIT THOSE
ROUGH PATCHES AS WELL SO IN
ADDITION TO THINKING ABOUT WHAT
THE IMMEDIATE NEEDS ARE. HOW
DOES THE YOU SEE PLAN OR THINK
ABOUT ADDRESSING SOME OF THESE
REALLY ROUGH PATCHES BECAUSE IF
YOU LOOK AT?
BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND TO TWO
THOUSAND FIVE AND TWO DOZEN
NINETY DOESN'T SOLVE.
I MEAN THAT THE BOOK OF WHEN IT
HAD THESE TUITION INCREASES IT
WENT UP
HOW DO WE PREPARE FOR THE NEXT
TIME THIS
HAPPENS ON WILL WE ALSO EXPECT
TO SEE.
AN INCREASE AYE GO UP WITH AND
THAT DRAMATICALLY A EVERYTHING
ELSE IS A FEW DIGITS HERE AND
THERE BUT THEN YOU SEE TWELVE.
A THIRTY FIFTEEN TO TWENTY SIX
PERCENT THAT'S I MEAN THAT THE
BULK OF IT.
OH YES ASSEMBLY MEMBER THERE'S.
THERE ARE SEVERAL YEARS THAT
COINCIDED WITH DRAMATIC STATE
FUNDING CUTS WHERE THE
UNIVERSITY TURN TO THE STUDENTS
TO MAKE UP THE DIFFERENCE.
WE ARE IN THE PROCESS WE'VE THE
PRESIDENT NOW HAS TO THE OF
EXECUTIVE FINANCE COMMITTEE THAT
IS. I'M COMPOSED OF CHANCELLORS
AND CAMPUS AYE NANCE LEADERSHIP
THAT IS THINKING ABOUT LONG TERM
HOTTEST UNIVERSITY ATTAIN.
FINANCIAL SECURITY SO THAT WE
WOULD NEVER HAVE A TUITION
INCREASE OF GREATER THAN FIVE
PERCENT THAT'S THE LONG TERM
GOAL THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO GET
TO. SOME OF THESE.
STEPS INCLUDE THINGS LIKE
REQUESTING THAT IF.
WE GET A FACULTY ENDOWMENT IT
FACULTY ENDOWMENTS USE TO JUST
BEFORE THE FACULTIES RESEARCH.
THAT WE MAKE IT.
A REQUIREMENT THAT THE FACULTY
SALARY A COMPONENT OF IT ALSO
HAS TO BE ON THAT ENDOWMENT.
THAT WOULD THEN FREE UP.
STATE FUNDS FOR OTHER PURPOSES
AND IT WOULD ALSO MAKE THAT
FACULTY POSITION MORE SECURE.
SO THAT'S SOME THAT'S ONE ASPECT
OF WERE THINKING ABOUT WE'RE
LOOKING TO PHILANTHROPY FOR
COMPONENT OF THAT AND.
UNFORTUNATELY I'LL HAVE TO COME
BACK TO YOU LATER WITH UP WITH
ACTUAL WITH PLANS THAT ARE BEING
FORMULATED. I AM I AM I AM I AM
I AM OPTIMISTIC THAT PLANS ARE
BEING DEVELOPED AND I MEAN THE
IDEA THAT IN THE ROUGHEST OF
TIMES FOR THE STATE WHERE WE SEE
CUTS ALL AROUND.
THERE MAY BE A WORLD WHERE WE
WON'T SEE A THIRTY PERCENT
INCREASE.
INTUITION.
AND I KNOW THAT THAT DOESN'T
COME LATELY SO I LOOK FORWARD TO
WHEN THOSE CONVERSATIONS
IMPLANTS COME THAT. AND WE CAN
HAVE WE CAN YOU KNOW BE UPDATED
ON THAT'S BECAUSE I THINK IT'S.
IT'S GONNA HAPPEN WE KNOW THAT
AT SOME POINT
OUR STATE WILL HIT ANOTHER
ROUGH.
YES ONCE ONCE THERE IS A PLAN
THAT.
.
IS SHAREABLE I WILL DEFINITELY
BRING IT TO YOU.
OKAY.
A COUPLE MORE QUESTIONS BEFORE
WE MOVE ON I DID WANT TO TO ASK
ABOUT THE.
LUKE CATHOLIC CREDIT DECISION.
THE FACT FINANCING INCORRECTLY
LOOK QUETTA LA CUENTA YEAH THIRD
ONE GAME SAID THEY WANT.
SO I I UNDERSTAND THAT THAT THE
DECISION THE RATIONALE. I'M SUB
SOMEWHAT CONFUSED ON THE REQUEST
FOR THE ADDITIONAL MONEY IT'S
KIND OF FREE MONEY THAT YOU'RE
ASKING THE STATE TO TAKE INTO TO
HELP. GO THE CAMPUS LEVEL BUT
WHY WOULDN'T WE CONSIDER USING.
THAT.
IS IT A MILLION OR NINE.
IT WERE NINE MILLION. TO EXPAND
ACCESS I GUESS THIS IS THE YOU
THAT THE QUESTION THAT WE'RE
DEBATING HERE IS. TO MAKE IT
BETTER FOR THE STUDENTS THAT ARE
THERE.
FOR TO HELP STUDENTS WHO AREN'T
THERE. GET IN TO THE UC SELF.
IT'S A POLICY CHOICE AND WHY
WOULD WE CHOOSE THAT OVER THE
OTHER.
LET ME MAKE TRIED TO BREAK THIS
INTO TWO PARTS OF THE LIQUID A
LAWSUIT. OF THE PAYMENTS WILL BE
COMPLETED AS I STATED PREVIOUSLY
IN FALL TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND THE
REGIONS. OF WORK GOING TO VOTE
IN JANUARY BUT DELAYED UNTIL MAY
THEIR VOTE TO MAKE THAT
SURCHARGE PERMANENT AND USE IT
VOTER I SAID GET THAT IDEA. SO
THAT'S THAT SEPARATE ISSUE
WOULDN'T ASIAN TURN THE
TERMINATION PARTY ISSUE FOR THAT
YOU'RE REQUESTING US.
FLAT OUT NINE MILLION DOLLARS TO
TO HELP.
ADD A PAYMENT IN THE BUDGET.
TO GO CAMPUS WIDE TO TO HELP YOU
KNOW THE UNIVERSITY NOT
NECESSARILY TO BACKFILL IT BUT.
SCAN ADDITIONAL MONEY SO WHY
WOULD WE DO THAT AS OPPOSED TO
USE THAT NINE MILLION FOR
EXPANSION.
REGARDLESS OF THAT THAT THAT THE
LOOK THE REGENTS DECISION ON THE
LOS.
THE.
BIO WILL HELP THE CURRENT
STUDENTS NOT MAKE IT PERMANENT
ESTA REGIONS HAVE PROPOSED AS
THEY'RE CONSIDERING TO DOING IN
DOING MAY. ALSO FOR EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN INVOLVEMENT WE HAVE
ALREADY CONCLUDED OUR ADMISSION
PROCESS SO BE QUITE DIFFICULT
AND THEN THE MONEY THAT WOULD GO
FOR NINETEEN TWENTY OH FOR
NINETEEN TWENTY DUMB. WE ALWAYS
GO TEARS AHEAD HERE RIGHT.
AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR FORWARD
LOOKING.
STANCE ON THIS AS IT IS MUCH
EASIER FOR THE UNIVERSITY. TO
RECEIVE A SIGNAL FROM THE
LEGISLATURE ON ROMAN BEFORE WE
ACTUALLY ADMIT STUDENTS.
.
WE WERE PLANNING ON USING THAT
THOSE FUNDS FOR HIRING THE
FACULTY.
AND IF WE WERE TO ADMIT MORE
STUDENTS WE WOULD NEED FACULTY
FOR THEM SO I SUPPOSE THIS IS
ONE POSSIBLE FUNDING SOURCE FOR
THAT.
OKAY BELOW REVISIT THAT.
.
IN.
THE OTHER THE OTHER QUESTION IS
IS THAT WOULD CERTAINLY.
WE ARE GREATLY APPRECIATE THE
LAST FEW YEARS THE FUNDS THAT
YOU COULD MUM MORE MONEY ON THE
TABLE UC'S RESPONDED. ENROLLING
MORE QUALIFIED CALIFORNIA KIDS
AT THE SAME TIME AND WE'VE CAP
THE OUT OF STATE. A NUMBER SO
GREAT NEWS FOR CALIFORNIA
FAMILIES TRYING TO GET IN THE
UC.
AND UC HAS GONE ABOVE AND BEYOND
AND KIND OF.
.
YEAH รณ OVER AND OVER AND
ROLLED OVER IT. ADMITTED
ENROLLED WITH THAT THE TAKE RATE
IS IS HIRED THEN WAS AND
ANTICIPATED.
AND SO THAT'S A KIND OF A GOOD
PROBLEM BUT I CUT COMING BACK
INTO AND ASKING FOR MORE
RESOURCES. SO THE CSU DOES NOT
DO THAT RIGHT DAY THEY OVER AND
ROLLED HERE AND THERE AND THEY
HAVEN'T GONE BACK.
AND ASKED FOR KIND OF.
YOU KNOW BACK MONEY SO BOT WHO
WHAT'S THE RATIONALE. WHY?
YOU.
ARE REQUESTING THAT.
Y. CATCH YOU ABSORB IT THROUGH.
THE OVERALL THAT YOU SEE BUDGET
AND WE COLD AGAIN USE THE
RESOURCES THAT YOU'RE ASKING TO
TO GO BACK TO CONTINUE TO GROW
FOR NINETEEN TWENTY.
THE QUALITY ON THE CAMPUSES IS
SUFFERING AND OUR CORE FUNDS ARE
ALREADY.
FULLY UTILIZE TO PROVIDE
SERVICES ON THE CAMPUSES IN THE
PAPER INSTRUCTORS.
A WE HAVE TAKEN AGGRESSIVE STEPS
BEHIND THE SCENES TO SAVE COST
FOR EXAMPLE WE HAVE A NEW
PROCUREMENT PROCESS WITHIN DO
YOU SEE THAT WAS PUT IN PLACE
TOOK. SEVERAL YEARS OF PLANNING
AND ORGANIZING BUT IS NOW SAVING
OVER TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
A YEAR FOR OUR CAMPUSES. SO
THAT'S ONE THING WE'VE DONE TO
TRY AND CONTAIN COSTS SO THAT WE
WOULDN'T. OVER BURDEN THE
CAMPUSES WE'VE ALSO CREATED OUR
OWN INTERNAL.
INSURANCE PULL SYSTEM.
OF WHERE WE INSURE OUR BUILDINGS
NOW AND WE HAVE ALSO MOVED OUR
WORKERS COMP ON TO THIS AS WELL.
UP WHICH OF STAVING OVER FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR. AS A
WE'RE TAKING SOME STEPS TO TRY
AND SAVE COST SO THAT THE
CAMPUSES.
WOULD HAVE RESOURCES FREED UP
TO TAKE CARE OF THE EXISTING
STUDENTS BUT WE ARE FINDING
OURSELVES OVER STRETCHED
STUDENTS CAN'T GET INTO THEIR
MAJORS.
AND WE ARE WEEK DESPERATE NEED
TO HIRE MORE FACULTY.
THE CSU IS REQUESTING MORE FUNDS
ABOVE THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IS
MY UNDERSTANDING AS WELL SO I'M
NOT CERTAIN WHAT THEY'RE
PROPOSING TO USE THOSE FUNDS FOR
WE WANNA MAKE CERTAIN THAT
QUALITY AT UC DOES NOT FALL.
WE.
CONTINUE TO ENROLL STUDENTS
THROUGH THE FINANCIAL CRISIS OF
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT.
DO TWENTY ELEVEN EVEN THOUGH WE
WERE LOSING STATE FUNDS AT THE
SAME TIME.
SO THE CSU.
NOV SCALED BACK THEIR ENROLLMENT
AT THAT TIME SO THEY WERE ABLE
TO RETAIN SOME OF THE DOLLARS
PER STUDENT THAT WE WERE LOSING.
SO THAT MIGHT BE ONE ONE REASON
WHY THEY. DON'T FEEL THAT THEY
NEED THOSE DOLLARS.
OKAY MIXTURE.
ESTIMATES WHICH I THINK IT.
I UP.
THANK EACH I WAS CHAIR AYE
INTENDED TO BRING THIS UP
EARLIER ON.
BUT THEM.
THERE THERE'S BEEN SOME.
ARTICLES RECENTLY THE.
HIGHLIGHTING THE CONCERNED
ABOUT.
IN THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIANS
AUGUST.
DEPARTMENTS.
SLIPPING IN THE WORLD WIDE
RANKINGS THE AND AND AND IN
TERMS OF A.
THE OVERALL QUALITY OF OF OF THE
DEPARTMENTS.
IS IS IT FAIR TO SAY THAT.
.
THAT.
IN TERMS OF CRITICALLY IN TERMS
OF THE RESEARCH BASED RANKINGS.
THAT.
THE PRIMARY.
BUT THE MOST IMPORTANT FACTOR IS
THE QUALITY OF THE FACULTY.
THAT THE UNIVERSE OF
CALIFORNIA'S ATTRACTING
RETAINING.
IN REGARDS TO THOSE RANKINGS.
I THINK YOU SIR OF IT YES THE
RESEARCH OF THE FACULTY WHETHER
WHERE IT'S PUBLISHED HOW MANY
TIMES IT CITED AND WHAT IMPACT
IT ENDS UP HAVING ON THE WORLD.
UP IMPACTS TO RATINGS OF THE
UNIVERSITY AND THE QUALITY.
.
REALLY QUALITY OF EDUCATION IT
IMPACTS OF DIFFERENT WITH THE
GRADUATE EDUCATION BECAUSE A
FACULTY ARE TEACHING THE
GRADUATE STUDENTS. HOW TO
CONDUCT RESEARCH GIVING THEM
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES IN
THEIR LIVES AND ELSEWHERE?
TO GAIN THAT RESEARCH EXPERIENCE
ABOUT YOU SEE UNDERGRADUATES CAN
ALSO WORK IN LABS AND GAIN YOU
VERY UNIQUE EXPERIENCE THAT THEY
DON'T HAVE. IN OTHER UNIVERSITY
SETTINGS
UP WE ARE CONCERNED THAT ONCE.
ONCE RANKINGS BEGINS TO SLIP
ONCE WE LOSE THOSE HIGHLY
QUALIFIED FACULTY TO OTHER
UNIVERSITIES THAT ARE. EVEN NOW
PAYING MORE THAN WE ARE AND THAT
MAY HAVE FAR LOWER COST OF
LIVING.
.
IT'S VERY HARD TO REGAIN.
THAT HIGH STATUS TO REESTABLISH
DOT QUALITY.
BECOMES MORE MORE EXPENSIVE SO
WE WE ARE RESPECTFULLY
REQUESTING THE TWENTY FIVE
MILLION. FOR A.
CONTINUING TO KEEP CLASS SIZES
FROM INCREASING SO THE FACULTY.
DON'T HAVE TO TEACH IT'S VERY
HIGH OF LARGE CLASSES SO THAT
THEY WOULD HAVE MORE TIME.
AWAY FROM GRADING AND SO FORTH
TO DEVOTE THE RESEARCH.
THINK
OKAY.
YOU KNOW THE MORE QUESTIONS I
DID WANT TO NOTE THAT IT'S NOT A
JAN DIES BUT TEN.
I DID ATTEND A LOCAL EVENT LAST
WEEK WITH UC DAVIS.
WORKING TILL I'M ANNOUNCING
THEY'RE GOING TO EXPAND THEIR
PRESENCE IN SACRAMENTO
ESSENTIALLY A SATELLITE CAMPUS
THEY'VE ALREADY HAVE THEIR.
NURSING PROGRAM IN THEIR AND
THEIR MEDICAL PROGRAM HERE DAVIS
AND NOT HAVE TO.
.
NOT THE SECOND ON THE DAVIS
CAMPUS.
AND DOT JUST THINK THAT THIS IS
A YOU KNOW GREAT OPPORTUNITY
HERE BUT ALSO THROUGHOUT THE UC.
THE MORE WE CAN.
DO IN THE SATELLITE LOCATIONS
COURSE.
I FREEZE UP SPACE AT THE MAIN
CAMPUS I'M ROLE MORE
CALIFORNIA'S PROVIDING MORE.
MONEY EXISTS FOR ENROLLMENT
GROWTH SO THAT SOMETHING THAT.
WE'RE REALLY LOOKING INTO
LOOKING TO EMBRACE THE IDEA UC
DAVIS OUTPUT FOR BUT ALSO.
LOOKING GUY YOU SEE WHITES I
THINK THERE'S THESE ARE.
WIN WIN OPPORTUNITIES FOR.
THE SATELLITE CAMPUS AREA PLUS
THE FLAGSHIP CAMPUS.
THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU.
LET'S MOVE ON NOW TO ISSUE
NUMBER THREE.
OFTEN WITH SOME GENERAL CONTACTS
AND THEN DESCRIBE TO ISSUES
RELATED TO THE. I AND TWENTY
SIXTEEN THE VOTERS PASSED
PROPOSITION FIFTY SIX WHICH
INCREASED EXCISE TAX RATE ON
CIGARETTES TOBACCO PRODUCTS
EFFECTIVE ABLE FIRST OF LAST
YEAR.
THE EXCISE TAX INCREASE BY TWO
DOLLARS PER PACK TWENTY
CIGARETTES.
WITH AN EQUIVALENT EXCISE TAX ON
CIGARS BICU CIGARETTES AND
OTHER TOBACCO PRODUCTS.
REVENUE FROM THIS INITIATIVE
FIRST BACK FEELS PROP NINETY
NINE PROPOSITION TEN THE BREAST
CANCER FUND AND STATE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO ADDRESS REVENUE
TO CLIENTS THAT RESULT FROM THE
ADDITIONAL TAX.
AFTER THIS BACK FOR LIQUOR
SPEAKS DELEGATIONS ARE TAKEN OUT
FOR GRADUATE MEDICAL EDUCATION
STATE DENTAL PROGRAM ENFORCEMENT
ACROSS MULTIPLE DEPARTMENTS.
OF THE REMAINING REVENUE EIGHTY
TWO PERCENT IS PROVIDED TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH HILLS
HEALTH CARE SERVICES.
YOU FUNDED MEDICAL PROGRAM
GROWTH AND HEALTH CARE PROGRAMS
AND SERVICES THIRTEEN PERCENT IS
PROVIDED FOR TO TOBACCO CONTROL
AND PREVENTION PROGRAMS
ADMINISTERED BY THE DEPARTMENT
PUBLIC HEALTH. AND THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AND THE REMAINING FIVE
PERCENT IS PROVIDED TO THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA FOR
MEDICAL RESEARCH.
TO CANCER HEART AND LUNG TOBACCO
RELATED DISEASES.
ON NOW TALK ABOUT THE TO YOU SEE
RELATED PROPOSALS.
OUT FIRST THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
REFLECTS
FIFTY SEVEN MILLION TO SUPPORT
THE CIGARETTE AND TOBACCO
PRODUCTS RESEARCH PROGRAM. THIS
PROGRAM FUNDS CANCER RESEARCH AS
WELL STUDIES OF HEART LUNG
DISEASES RELATED TO TOBACCO
CONSUMPTION.
SECOND THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
ALSO REFLECTS FORTY MILLION FOR
GRADUATE MEDICAL EDUCATION IF
THE UNIVERSE CALIFORNIA. THESE
FUNDS WILL SUPPORT RESIDENTS
DEVELOPING THEIR SKILLS IN
FAMILY MEDICINE INTERNAL
MEDICINE OBSTETRICS AND
GYNECOLOGY PEDIATRICS AND
EMERGENCY MEDICINE.
CONSISTENT WITH THE LANGUAGE OF
THIS INITIATIVE.
THESE FUNDS ARE CITIES TO
SUSTAIN RETAIN AND EXPAND ITS
PROGRAMS.
AS YOUR AGENDA NOTES THE BUDGET
AX RELATED GENERAL ADJUSTMENT
AND JONATHAN APPROPRIATIONS TO
THE SEA INSTEAD USING A
PROPOSITION FIFTY SIX FUNDS TO
OPERATE THESE PROGRAMS.
UC DOES NOT ACCOUNT
SPECIFICALLY FOR THE COST OF
ENROLLING MEDICAL RESIDENTS I TO
UNDERSTAND AYE WHETHER THE SHIFT
WOULD HAVE FISCAL IMPACTS WE
USED A YOU SEE THAT OLOGY. THAT
USED OTHER CONTACTS AND WE ARE
CONFIDENT THAT THIS SHIFT WILL
NOT HAVE PROGRAMMATIC IMPACTS ON
THE RESIDENCY PROGRAMS.
THINKING.
ELIOT SO THIS.
ISSUE RELATES TO AN
IMPLEMENTATION DECISION MADE
LAST YEAR BY THE STATE THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NOTED IT I
JUST WANTED TO ENSURE THAT THE
COMMITTEE YOU.
I JUST REMIND THE COMMITTEE OF
THAT DECISION.
AT LAST YEAR THE. STATE
PROVIDED THAT YOU SEE RECEIVE
THE FIRST.
INSTALLMENT OF THE FORTY
MILLION FOR GRADUATE MEDICAL
EDUCATION FROM PROPOSITION
THE SEX.
AND ON WHAT THE LEGISLATURE OF
THE STATE DECIDED TO DO WAS TO
USE THAT OF FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO SHIFT A LIKE AMOUNT
OF GENERAL FUND THAT YOU SEE
ESTIMATED IT WAS SPENDING ON. ON
GRADUATE MEDICAL EDUCATION AND
AND SHIFT THAT GENERAL FUND
INTO.
UC'S GENERAL CAMPUS BUDGET AND
THAT SHIFT WAS SCORED AS PART OF
UC'S BASED INCREASE IN THAT YEAR
GENERAL FUND BASED INCREASE.
THE EFFECT OF TAT DECISION WAS
EFFECTIVELY TO HOLD A RESIDENCY
SLOTS FLAT AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA RATHER THAN CREATE A
NEW PROGRAM AT THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA TO INCREASE
RESIDENCIES.
SO THAT'S WHAT THIS ISSUE ARE
RELATES TO.
I THOUGHT IT BE HELPFUL TO JUST
WALK THE COMMITTEE THROUGH SOME
OF THE OTHER GRADUATE MEDICAL
EDUCATION ISSUES IN THE BUDGET.
.
IT IS PART OF A SEPARATE.
A DEAL MADE OF A LAST YEAR THE
STATE IS PROVIDING A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS OVER THREE
YEARS.
TO THE OFFICE OF STATEWIDE
PLANNING HEALTH PLANNING AND
DEVELOPMENT
ON THAT HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
IS GENERALLY GOING TO.
HOSPITALS FOR MEDICAL RESIDENCY
SLOTS IT'S ON NEXT OF SERVE ON
MAKING UP A LOST REVENUES THAT
THE HOSPITALS HAD RECEIVED AN
AWESOME IS ALSO TO EXPAND
RESIDENCY SLOTS AS WELL.
OTHERS ALSO IN ADDITION TO THAT
IT THIS YEAR THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES IS IN THE
PROCESS OF NEGOTIATING. WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO LEVERAGE
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL FUNDS A TO
REIMBURSE HOSPITALS FOR THE
GRADUATE MEDICAL EDUCATION
COSTS.
IF THAT DEAL.
LET'S GO THROUGH ITS ESTIMATED
TO PROVIDE A FEW HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY TO HOSPITALS
FOR TO REIMBURSE THEIR COSTS.
AND YOU THINKING THROUGH YOUR
DECISIONS FOR GRADUATE MEDICAL
EDUCATION AND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
WE RECOMMEND THAT YOU CONSIDER
ALL THE PROGRAMS THAT YOU HAVE
AT YOUR DISPOSAL AND AND THINK
ABOUT HOW YOU'D LIKE TO. SORT OF
ALLOCATE THAT FUNDING SO FOR
EXAMPLE IF IF YOU'RE INTERESTED
IN PROVIDING MORE FUNDING TO
GRAD GRADUATE MEDICAL EDUCATION.
ONE NATURAL AREA IS THE SONG
BROWN PROGRAM AT THE OFFICE OF
STATEWIDE HEALTH PLANNING AND
DEVELOPMENT THAT'S A PROGRAM
THAT ALREADY EXISTS.
ON AND SO THE THERE THERE'S SOME
ADVANTAGE THERE TO SORT OF
TARGET FUNDING TOWARDS THEIR.
ANOTHER ALTERNATIVE IS TO
PROVIDE MORE GENERAL FUND TO THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA IF THAT'S
SOMETHING OF INTEREST TO YOU
THAT COULD HAVE I COULD SORT OF.
OF OF WAY THAT'S WHAT THAT WAS
DECIDED LAST YEAR IF THAT'S YOUR
DECISION WE WOULD JUST RECOMMEND
THAT YOU GET MORE INFORMATION
FROM THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
ON AND HOW TO ALLOCATE THAT
FUNDING WOULD BE A NEW PROGRAM.
I'M IN SO YOU'D WANT TO GET.
YEAH INFORMATION ON AND HOW YOU
YOU SEE SPECIFICALLY INTENDS TO
SORT OF.
ALLOCATE THOSE FUNDS WERE THAT
NEW PROGRAM TO BE A STEP.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU UNIVERSE CALIFORNIA.
I DON'T THINK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
IF THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSES TO TAKE FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS OUT OF THE UC'S BUDGET
AND PROVIDE US WITH FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS IMPROPER FIFTY
SIX FUNDS. THIS IS.
THE SAME AS AND CURRENT YEAR.
BILLION IN PROFIT THE SIX FUNDS
THAT WAS.
FIVE QUARTERS WORTH A FUNDING
SO WOULD BE FORTY MILLION GOING
FORWARD.
WHAT MAY HAVE CONFUSED A LOT OF
PEOPLE WAS THAT THE?
PROPOSITION FIFTY SIX REFERS TO
GRADUATE MEDICAL EDUCATION THAT
THESE FUNDS WILL BE USED FOR
GRADUATE MEDICAL EDUCATION. THE
TERM OF ART IN THE MEDICAL
COMMUNITY THAT REFERS ACTUALLY
THE MEDICAL RESIDENTS KNOCK
MEDICAL STUDENTS.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
WHEN WE LOST THOSE FUNDS THAT
CAME OUT OF OUR MEDICAL SCHOOLS
FOR THE TRAINING FOR YOUR
TRAINING OF DOCTORS.
WE ARE SPENDING THE FUNDS FROM
PROP FIFTY SIX.
ON OUR MEDICAL RESIDENT
TRAINING.
BUT THE INTENT OF THE
PROPOSITION THERE ARE MANY
PEOPLE WHO THINK.
THAT THE INTENT OF THE
PROPOSITION WAS TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF MEDICAL RESIDENCY
SLOTS IN THE STATE. BECAUSE WE
HAVE A INCREASING NEED FOR
DOCTORS THERE'S A LOT OF
EVIDENCE THAT.
DOCTORS AND A PRACTICING WHERE
THEY IN THE NEARBY AREA WHERE
THEY COMPLETE THEIR MEDICAL
RESIDENCY. I'M BY NOT HAVING
SUFFICIENT SLOTS IN THE STATE
WHERE ACTUALLY LOSING. FOR YOUR
MEDICAL. SCHOOL GRADUATES TO
OTHER STATES WHERETHEY MANDATE
PRACTICING SO. WE LOSE SOME OF
THEM THAT WE HAVE FULLY TRAINED.
A MEDICAL RESIDENT COST BETWEEN
HUNDRED THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND ANNUALLY
DEPENDING ON WHERE THEY ARE
PRACTICING AND TYPE OF MEDICINE
THEY PRACTICE. IF THE CLINIC OF
STARTING A NEW PROGRAM FOR THEM
OR IF THEY ALREADY HAVE EXISTING
SLOTS.
THIS MEANS THAT.
BETWEEN TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY
AND FOUR HUNDRED MEDICAL
RESIDENCY SLOTS ARE BEING LOST
TO THE STATE BY REMOVING FROM
YOU SEE HE FUNDS THAT. USED TO
PAY FOR UC MEDICAL RESIDENCY
TRAINING AND FORCING YOU SEE TO
USE FIFTH PROP FIFTY SIX FUNDS.
FOR THAT TRAINING CURRENTLY.
SO WE ARE REQUESTING THAT THE.
US SWAP BEYOND DAWN AND YOU SEE
BE ABLE TO. USE THE PROP FIFTY
SIX FUNDS TO DISTRIBUTE STATE.
FOR A MEDICAL.
A.
HOSPITALS AND OTHER PROGRAMS
THAT HAVE.
RESIDENCY PROGRAMS
WE'RE PROPOSING TO DEVELOP A
NONPROFIT BOARD COMPOSED OF
FIFTEEN.
THE FIFTEEN SEATS.
DOUBLE BE HELD BY ORGANIZATIONS
THAT ARE PROMINENT IN CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL COMMUNITY PLEASE INCLUDE
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION. A NETWORK OF ETHNIC
PHYSICIANS SCEI YOU CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL AND OTHERS.
.
AND YOU SEE WOULD OF COURSE HAVE
A SEAT ON THIS BOARD.
BECAUSE YOU SEE WILL BE AUDITED
PARTY USE OF THESE FUNDS WE WANT
TO MAKE CERTAIN THAT THEY. GRANT
DISTRIBUTIONS EITHER CONDUCTED
BY UC OR A NONPROFIT WHERE YOU
SEE HOLDS UP A SEAT OR THE CHAIR
POSITION.
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO UP.
ANSWER FOR HOW THOSE FUNDS WERE
SPENT BUT WE. IF YOU SEE IS MADE
WHOLE WE WILL DISTRIBUTE THESE
FUNDS IN A FAIR AND IMPARTIAL
BASES AROUND THE STATE. FOR
MEDICAL RESIDENCY SLOTS AROUND
HOSPITALS AND COMMUNITIES.
THANK YOU I I KNOW THIS ISN'T AN
ISSUE THAT.
.
HAS BROUGHT A LOT OF OF
ATTENTION AND.
YOU KNOW I KNOW THAT TO THE
ADVOCATES WE'RE GOING TO HEAR
FROM AND TO.
SOME OF US HERE FOR THE DICE IT
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE.
THAT THE MEASURE WAS PASSED
BEFORE THE VOTERS.
AND
WE'RE HAVING BAD RECORD AMOUNTS
COMMAND THE BUDGET LAST TWO
YEARS AND WERE MAKING THIS.
YOU'RE TAKING THIS ACTION YOU
KNOW THIS AN ACTION YOU WOULD
TAKE DURING THAT RECESSION WE'RE
SLASHING MONEY.
S. DOESN'T.
LOGICALLY MAKE SENSE DURING THIS
THIS ISSUE SO I WILL CONTINUE TO
ADD TO TAKE A LOOK AT IT.
YOUR THE MAY REVISE MAYBE THE
GOVERNMENT WILL COME BACK WITH A
DIFFERENT PROPOSAL DURING THE
MAY REVISION.
STIR MEDINA. AYE I THINK THAT IT
THIS IS AN ISSUE ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT TO YOU SEE.
RIVERSIDE THAT HAS A NEW MEDICAL
SCHOOL AND I KNOW THAT THERE IS
A CORRELATION BETWEEN THE TIME.
FOR A.
MEDICAL SCHOOL TO ESTABLISH THE
NUMBER OF RESIDENCIES
THAT THERE'S ONLY A SMALL WINDOW
A WINDOW OF OPPORTUNITY. TO. GET
THE NUMBER ESTABLISH OF
RESIDENTS AND AS YOU STATED. TO
AN AREA LIKE THE INLAND EMPIRE A
IT IS CRUCIAL THAT WE HAVE THE
RESIDENTS.
AFTER THEY FINISH.
MEDICAL SCHOOL AT UC RIVERSIDE
IF WE ARE GOING TO HAVE THEM
PRACTICE IN THE INLAND EMPIRE.
GIVE LE OUR GRADUATES OF THE
MEDICAL SCHOOL WHICH WE HAD THE
FIRST CLASS. OF APPROXIMATELY
FIFTY LAST YEAR HAVE TO GO
OUTSIDE THE AREA TO DO THE
RESIDENCY. OTHERS A GOOD CHANCE
THAT THEY WILL NOT STAY IN OUR
AREA TO PRACTICE MEDICINE SO
THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT. A TO THE
INLAND EMPIRE AND I ECHO THAT
THE CHAIRS A.
SENTIMENT THAT WE DO NOT DO
WHAT THE GOVERNOR IS PROPOSING
THAT BUT THAT WE KEEP YOU SEE
HOLE.
THINK I.
THANK YOU AND I WILL HEAR FROM
THE PUBLIC CAN A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THIS.
I AM SEEING NO.
FURTHER COMMENTERS CASH IN ISSUE
NUMBER FOUR.
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT BY
OKAY PLEASE PROCEED.
HI GOOD MORNING IT CHAIRMEN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND
KAREN FLARED AND I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF STATE GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS AT THE UC OFFICE OF
THE PRESIDENT. IF I MAY
INTERRUPT FOR JUST ONE MOMENT
AND SEE IF THE US SERGEANT COULD
ALSO.
PASS OUT A COPY FOR THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST OF WHAT'S
JUST BEEN DISTRIBUTED.
I APPRECIATE THAT VERY MUCH
THANK YOU. AYE SO I WANT TO
START TODAY BY THANKING YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION AND
ALSO.
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND SUPPORT OF UC'S
BUDGING REQUEST BUDGET REQUEST
FOR THIS YEAR MUCH APPRECIATED.
I AS I MENTIONED I'M KAREN
FLIRTY AND THE DIRECTOR OF STATE
GOVERNMENTAL RELATIONS AT THE
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT TODAY I
HAVE WITH ME DAVE FALL TAX WHO'S
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR IN THE OFFICE
OF THE PRESIDENT. BUDGET AND
FINANCE DAVIS RELATIVELY NEW TO
YOU SEE.
JUST A LITTLE OVER A YEAR AND HE
IS RESPONSIBLE IN LARGE PART FOR
MANY OF THE IMPROVEMENTS THAT WE
MADE IN OUR BUDGETING. AT THE
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT THING
AND START BY GIVING SOME VERY
BRIEF CONTEXT ON THE OFFICE OF
THE PRESIDENT. WHAT IT DOES HOW
IT IS FUNDED AND AND FOR
PURPOSES OF THIS ITEM IT'S
IMPORTANT TO DISCUSS HOW THE YOU
CO P. BUDGET WAS FUNDED BEFORE?
AND THE CHANGES THAT WERE MADE
BY THE LEGISLATURE AND AND THE
GOVERNOR IN THE STATE BUDGET
ACTIVE TWENTY SEVENTEEN. JUST AS
AREFRESHER AS YOU KNOW I YOU
SEE IS COMPRISED OF TEN CAMPUSES
FIVE ACADEMIC MEDICAL CENTERS
AND WE'RE ALSO RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE MANAGEMENT OF THREE NATIONAL
LABORATORY SO IF YOU TURN TO
SLIDE TO.
OF THAT JACK THAT WAS
DISTRIBUTED I JUST WOULD LIKE TO
PROVIDE SOME INFORMATION THAT
PUTS THE OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT
IN CONTEXT.
I YOU SEE EMPLOYEES OVER ONE
HUNDRED AND SITE YOUR PAGE TO.
I'M SORRY ABOUT THAT PAGE TO
PAGE TWO.
I YOU SEE EMPLOYEES OVER ONE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY THOUSAND FULL
TIME EQUIVALENT EMPLOYEES.
THE OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT
EMPLOYS APPROXIMATELY ONE
THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED OF THIS
ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTY THOUSAND
OP FULL TIME EQUIVALENT
EMPLOYEES OR ABOUT ONE PERCENT.
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA'S
TOTAL BUDGET FOR EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN IS PROJECTED TO BE
ABOUT THIRTY FOUR POINT FIVE
BILLION.
YOU SEE OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT
TOTAL BILL TOTAL BUDGET IS
PROJECTED JUST UNDER EIGHT
HUNDRED MILLION. SO THAT'S ABOUT
TWO POINT THREE PERCENT OF UC'S
TOTAL BUDGET. HOWEVER.
LESS THAN HALF OF THE U. CEO P.
BUDGET OF EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION.
IS STATE GENERAL FUND SO THE
STATE GENERAL FUND PIECE OF THE
U. CO P. TOTAL BUDGET IS ABOUT
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION ARE
AGAIN THAT'S ABOUT ONE PERCENT.
OF UC'S TOTAL.
SO IF WE TURN NOW TO PAGE THREE.
AYE QUICKLY TO ADDRESS.
WHAT IT IS THAT THE OFFICE OF
THE PRESIDENT DOES OUR
FUNCTIONS?
IN THE BIG PICTURE WERE
RESPONSIBLE FOR COORDINATING
ACTIVITIES THAT FURTHER UC'S
PUBLIC SERVICE ACADEMIC AND
RESEARCH MISSIONS. OUR BEHALF OF
STUDENTS FACULTY STAFF.
PATIENTS
AND THE BROADER PUBLIC
DO THIS THROUGH TWO VERY
IMPORTANT INDISTINCT FUNCTION
ONE IS THE CENTRALIZED AND
ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES.
THESE ARE THINGS LIKE THE SYSTEM
WIDE ADMISSIONS PORTAL STUDENT
SERVICES AND FINANCIAL AID.
I RETIREMENT BENEFITS ACADEMIC
PERSONNEL AND LABOR.
I MANAGEMENT STRATEGIES
INVESTMENT OF A.
MANAGEMENT OF A HUNDRED BILLION
DOLLAR.
INVESTMENT PORTFOLIO. GRANTS
MANAGEMENT BUDGETING FINANCE
CAPITAL STRATEGIES AND RISK
MANAGEMENT.
LEGAL COMPLIANCE AUDIT TITLE
NINE GOVERNMENT RELATIONS PUBLIC
AFFAIRS ENERGY AND
SUSTAINABILITY. INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY HEALTH AND SOME
OTHERS.
THIS PORTION OF THE BUDGET THE
CENTRAL AND ADMINISTRATIVE
SERVICES PORTION ALSO HAS SOME
SUPPORT FOR THE ACADEMIC SENATE.
AND FOR THE BOARD OF REGENTS.
THE OTHER.
COMPONENT IS THE.
SIXTY SYSTEM SIXTY SYSTEM WIDE
ACADEMIC AND PUBLIC SERVICE
PROGRAMS IN THE ACADEMIC AND
PUBLIC SERVICE PROGRAM SECTION
OF THE BUDGET.
I THESE ARE CARRIED OUT
DIVISIONS LIKE ACADEMIC AFFAIRS
WHERE THINGS LIKE ACADEMIC
PREPARATION AND OUTREACH
PROGRAMS WITH LIVE. AYE YOU SEE
HEALTH I IN A DIVISION CALLED
AGRICULTURE AND NATURAL
RESOURCES THAT IS SYSTEM WIDE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
AS WELL AS.
THE NATIONAL LABORATORIES
SO I UNLESS THERE'S SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS ON THAT I WOULD JUST
SAY THAT THE.
OVERALL BUDGET FOR THAT FIRST
COMPONENT
IS THREE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
EIGHT POINT SEVEN MILLION.
THAT WOULD BE THE CENTRAL AND
ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES AND AS I
MENTIONED ONLY A PORTION OF THAT
IS STATE GENERAL FUND.
THE SECOND COMPONENT THE
SYSTEMWIDE ACADEMIC AND PUBLIC
SERVICE BUDGET IS ABOUT FOUR
HUNDRED AND EIGHT POINT EIGHT
MILLION. AND AS I MENTIONED ONLY
A PORTION OF THAT IS STATE
GENERAL FUND SAID THESE NUMBERS
ARE GONNA BE AVAILABLE ON A
SUBSEQUENT SLIDE FOR YOU SO YOU
DON'T NEED TO JOT THOSE DOWN.
AND MISTER BALL TAXES GONNA
BREAK IT DOWN A LITTLE BIT
FURTHER ON IT IS CHALLENGING
WHEN LOOKING AT A UC SYSTEM WIDE
OFFICE TO COMPARE IT TO OTHER
HIGHER EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS.
BECAUSE.
ALL HIGHER EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS VARY A LOT AND
SCALE AND SCOPE THE UNIVERSITY
HAS A VERY BROAD SCOPE BECAUSE
WE DO THE ACADEMIC MEDICAL
CENTER COMPONENT IN THE LABS THE
AGRICULTURE NATURAL RESOURCES.
AND WE ALSO HAVE A VERY BROAD
SCALE BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT OF
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA AND WE
EMPLOY A LOT OF PEOPLE AND WE
HAVE A LOT OF STUDENTS SO.
NONE THE LESS WE DID I HAVE A
CONSULTANT TAKE A LOOK AT THIS
SO THAT WE CAN GET A BETTER
IDEA.
AYE AS PART OF AN EFFORT TO YOU
OPTIMALLY ORGANIZE THE OFFICE OF
THE PRESIDENT TO TRY AND BE. AYE
RIGHT SIZED RIGHT FOCUSED AND
AND PROVIDE THE RIGHT SERVICES
AND WHAT WE DISCOVERED BY
COMPARING US TO TEN OTHER HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS.
THIS CONSULTANT ACTUALLY
INDEPENDENTLY.
DETERMINED.
THAT WHEN IT COMES TO THE
AMOUNT OF EMPLOYEES THAT WE HAVE
AND THE AMOUNT OF SPEND THAT WE
HAVE.
WE'RE JUST IN THAT IN THE
BOTTOM HALF OF WHOM WE COMPARED
OURSELVES TO SO THE COMPARISON
INSTITUTIONS INCLUDED.
PUBLIC RESEARCH INSTITUTIONS
LIKE THE UNIVERSITY BUT ALSO
COMPREHENSIVE FOUR YEAR
INSTITUTIONS AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEMS ALL OF WHOM HAVE
A SYSTEM WIDE CENTRAL OFFICE.
BUT THEY VERY VERY MUCH IN
FUNCTION AND SO WE TRIED TO GET
A BETTER IDEA TO PROVIDE A
COMPARISON.
I WITH RESPECT TO THAT.
IF WE WERE TO RETURN AYE FOR TO
RETURN TO THE SLIDES NOW AND
PAGE FOR.
I JUST WANT TO DISCUSS SOME.
IMPROVEMENTS THAT WE'VE MADE
OUGHT TO UC'S FUNDING MODEL IN
THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS ARE BACK
IN TWENTY ELEVEN TWELVE YOU SEE
ADOPTED IN NEW FUNDING MODEL
THAT WAS INTENDED TO ALLOCATE
STATE GENERAL FUNDS. THAT.
THE STATE PROVIDES TO YOU SEE
AS ONE MAIN ST GENERAL FUND
SUPPORT APPROPRIATION FOR THE
UNIVERSITY.
I THIS WAS CALLED THE FUNDING
STREAMS MODEL WE'VE NOW RE FIND
IT IN COLLEGE RE BENCHING IT'S
BASED ON THREE PRINCIPLES THAT
ARE AND THE BULLETS THERE AT THE
TOP OF THE PAGE.
FIRST IS THAT REVENUES GENERATED
BY A CAMPUS GENERALLY ARE
RETAINED BY THE CAMPUS OF THIS
WOULD BE TO ASH AND FRANCE
STANCE.
I STUDENTS AT EVERY CAMPUS ARE
ENTITLED TO THE SAME LEVEL OF
STATE GENERAL FUND SUPPORT. SET
PRINCIPLE THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT
TO THE LEGISLATURE IN AND WE
SHARE THAT PRINCIPLE. AND
FINALLY THAT YOU CO P. WILL
PROVIDE CERTAIN CENTRAL SERVICES
AND SYSTEM WIDE PROGRAMMING THAT
CAMPUSES PAY A FAIR SHARE OUGHT
TO RECIEVE.
IN THE NEXT PORTION YOU SEE MORE
ABOUT THOSE CONTRIBUTIONS FOR
YOU CO P. SERVICES THAT I JUST
MENTIONED.
I THEY WERE NEGOTIATED AND
LARGELY FORMULA BASED AND
SIMILAR TO THAT FEE FOR SERVICES
MODEL THAT CAMPUSES WOULD PAY TO
THE CENTRAL OFFICE AS AN ANNUAL
ASSESSMENT.
I'M IN IT WAS BASED LARGELY ON
THE AMOUNT OF EMPLOYEES THE
AMOUNT OF AYE SPANS AYE AND SOME
OTHER FACTORS THAT WERE WERE
FORMULA BASED TO TRY AND
DETERMINE WHAT WOULD BE A
REASONABLE ASSESSMENT TO PAY FOR
THE CENTRAL SERVICES.
THE STATE HOWEVER WANTED TO
CHANGE THIS MODEL AND IN THE
BUDGET ACTIVE TWENTY SEVENTEEN I
THEY DID TAKE ACTION.
AND WHAT HAPPENED BASICALLY IS
AYE THE STATE REPLACED THE STATE
GENERAL FUND SUPPORT ALLOCATION
FOR THE UNIVERSITY. WITH THREE
STATE GENERAL FUND
APPROPRIATIONS
ONE IS THE MAIN YOU SEE SUPPORT
APPROPRIATION WE'VE BEEN
DISCUSSING AYE THERE'S ANOTHER
ONE FOR YOU SEE PATH WHICH IS
THE NEXT ITEM AFTER US HERE. AND
ONE FOR YOU SEE OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT AYE CERTAIN FUNCTIONS
OF THE OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT
WHICH IS WHAT WE'RE DISCUSSING
IN THIS ITEM.
AND SO I'M. UC'S ONE GENERAL
FUND SPORT ALLOCATION THEN
BECAME THREE AND WHAT THE STATUS
IT ELIMINATED THE CAMPUSES
HAVING TO PAY AN ASSESSMENT.
BUT IT ALSO REDUCED BY THE
AMOUNT THAT CAMPUSES WOULD
RECIEVE THROUGH THAT MAIN
APPROPRIATION BY AN EQUAL AMOUNT
SO IT IT BALANCED OUT IT WAS
BASICALLY I ONE FOR ONE.
I'M YOU SEE DID OPPOSE THIS
CHANGE AT THE TIME AND IT WAS
DECIDED IN CONFERENCE COMMITTEE
TO MOVE FORWARD OUT WE BELIEVE
THAT THE PRIOR SYSTEM WHERE
CAMPUS CONTRIBUTE.
BASED ON AN ASSESSMENT I MADE
SENSE AND WE THINK IT MAKES
SENSE BECAUSE IT'S A FEE FOR
SERVICES STYLE MODEL WHERE THE
CAMPUSES CAN DETERMINE IN
CONJUNCTION WITH YOU SEE OFFICE
OF THE PRESIDENT. WHAT THEY WANT
TO HAVE PERFORMED AS A CENTRAL
SERVICE AND WHAT THEY DON'T WANT
TO PURCHASE AND SORT OF INPUT
INTO HOW MUCH THEY'RE WILLING TO
TO PROVIDE FOR THOSE SERVICES?
I'M YOU KNOW GOING BACK TO THAT
CAMPUS CONTRIBUTION AS
ASSESSMENT AYE WE THINK WOULD
RESTORE INAPPROPRIATE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN AT CAMPUSES
RESPONSIBILITY FOR FUNDING. YOU
CO P. AND THE CAMPUS ITSELF AND
BY THAT I MEAN. THAT SOME OF THE
CAMPUSES ARE LARGER AND HAVE
ACADEMIC MEDICAL CENTERS FOR
INSTANCE AND HAVE MORE EMPLOYEES
AND MORE STUDENTS.
SO THE ASSESSMENT THAT THEY WERE
PAYING WAS LARGER AYE NOW THEY
DON'T PAY THAT ASSESSMENT AND
SAID THEY'RE SORT OF
DISPROPORTIONATELY BENEFITING
FROM NOT HAVING TO PAY THAT
ASSESSMENT. WHERE SOME OF THE
SMALLER CAMPUSES THAT DON'T HAVE
AN ACADEMIC MEDICAL CENTER I
WOULD HAVE BEEN IN OUR VIEW?
UNFAIRLY PUNISHED
SO WHAT WE HAD TO DO WAS WE HAD
TO CHANGE SOME INTERNAL
ACCOUNTING PRACTICES. TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE CAMPUS IS WERE
HELD HARMLESS IN THIS NEW MODEL
SO THAT THERE WASN'T.
YOU KNOW THERE WASN'T SOME SORT
OF A DISPROPORTIONATE BENEFIT BY
NOT HAVING TO PAY THIS
ASSESSMENT. THAT WOULD GO DOES
SOME OF THE LARGER BETTER
RESOURCE TO CAMPUSES SO ON
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE FEEL
IS.
NOT NECESSARY IT'S A LITTLE BIT
DIFFICULT TO FOLLOW AND IT'S
LESS TRANSPARENT IN SOME WAY SO
I'M WE WOULD LIKE TO RETURN TO
THE PRIOR ASSESSMENT.
IT'S BEEN INDICATED THAT.
BY THE BY THE CHAIRMAN I
BELIEVE AND I DON'T MEAN TO PUT
WORDS IN HIS MOUTH THAT THAT'S
NOT SOMETHING. THAT I HE WANTED
TO FAVOR THIS YEAR AYE BUT IT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE DID I REQUEST.
THROUGH BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND.
THEY DID NOT PUT THAT INTO THE
JANUARY INTRODUCTIONS TO THE WAY
THINGS ARE NOW ARE WITH A DIRECT
LINE ITEM APPROPRIATION FOR THE
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT. A
DIRECT LINE ITEM APPROPRIATION
FOR YOU SEE PATH AND THAT OUR
MAIN SUPPORT APPROPRIATION.
SO I MOVING ON FROM THAT TO
SLIDE FIVE PER PAGE FIVE I JUST
WANT TO TOUCH ON.
A FEW RECENT CHANGES THAT THE
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT THAT
IMPROVE TRANSPARENCY AND BEST
PRACTICES.
THE OUT IT YOU'RE QUITE FAMILIAR
pWITH.
APRIL TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR MADE
THIRTY THREE RECOMMENDATIONS WE
ARE IMPLEMENTING ALL THIRTY
THREE RECOMMENDATIONS TO IT TEN.
ARE DUE ON APRIL TWENTY FIFTH
THE BALANCE ARE DUE IN APRIL OF
TWENTY NINETEEN IN APRIL OF
TWENTY TWENTY. AYE IN ADDITION
WE ARE DOING THIS ORGANIZATIONAL
OPTIMIZATION TO ANSWER RARE
RIGHT ORGANIZED RIGHT SIZED AND
RIGHT SERVICES AN EXAMPLE OF
THAT THAT WE'VE ALREADY
ACCOMPLISHED JUST RECENTLY AND
ACTUALLY IT STARTS ON ME ONE.
SWEET MERGED TWO DIVISIONSAT
THE OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT
WHICH ELIMINATES ONE OF OUR
SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT POSITIONS
SO GOVERNMENT RELATIONS AND
PUBLIC AFFAIRS ARE GOING TO BE
BROUGHT TOGETHER IN ONE DEBATE
AND.
AND WHAT THAT DOES IS THAT
MEANS THAT.
THERE'S NO NEED FOR TWO SENIOR
VICE PRESIDENTS FOR ONE DIVISION
SO I ONE OF THOSE POSITIONS WILL
BE ELIMINATED THAT IS JUST AN
EXAMPLE THIS IS GOING TO BE A
LONG TERM PROCESS TO TRY AND I
REORGANIZED IN A WAY THAT MAKES
SENSE.
WE DON'T WANT TO BE JUST MOVING
DECK CHAIRS AROUND.
ON THE THERESE SHIP WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT.
THESE SORTS OF THINGS MAKE
SENSE THAT'S AN EXAMPLE OF
SOMETHING THAT MADE SENSE AND SO
WE TOOK THAT ACTION.
I YOU'LL HEAR A LITTLE BIT MORE
ABOUT THE EXECUTIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEE SO I WON'T GO INTO
THAT BUT THAT'S A WAY OF GETTING
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT FROM THE
CAMPUSES AT THE OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT. AND THEN THERE'S ALSO
A REPORT THAT'S PRETTY AYE
PENDING OFF FROM AN OUTSIDE FIRM
SCHOENBERG AB SHANK AND THIS IS
RELATING TO ASSESSING AT CERTAIN
SERVICES COULD BE DUPLICATIVE.
BETWEEN THE CAMPUS IS PROVIDING
THEM AND THE OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT PROVIDING THEM AND
THAT REPORT IS DUE LATER THIS
MONTH AS YOUR AGENDA INDICATES
SO. AT THIS POINT I THINK IT'S I
MAKE SENSE TO TURN IT OVER TO
DAVE PAUL TAX WHO IS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT BUDGET AND FINANCE.
AND DAVE IS GOING TO WALK YOU
THROUGH THE ACTUAL.
BUDGET A LITTLE BIT.
THANK YOU KAREN AND THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS.
SO I'LL START ON. PAGE SIX
SHOWING THE UC OP BUDGET. WHICH
AS DESCRIBED JUST EARLIER
ADDRESSES THE CENTRAL
ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES.
AND SYSTEM WIDE ACADEMIC AND
PUBLIC SERVICE FUNCTIONS OF THE
UNIVERSITY.
THE FIGURE SHOWN ARE FROM THE
YOU SEE A P. BUDGET FOR FISCAL
TWENTY SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN. WHICH
THE UC REGENTS APPROVED IN JULY
OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
THE CENTRAL ADMINISTRATIVE
SERVICES PORTION OF THE CO OP
BUDGET TOTALS THREE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY SIX POINT TWO MILLION. OR
ABOUT FORTY TWO PERCENT OF THE
TOTAL SEVEN HUNDRED NINETY SEVEN
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
BUDGET.
THESE COSTS INCLUDE
ADMINISTRATIVE SUPPORT FUNCTIONS
OR CENTRALIZED OPERATIONAL
SERVICES. WHICH ARE PERFORMED
MORE EFFICIENTLY BY HAVING ONE
ENTITY PERFORM THEM ON BEHALF OF
THE ENTIRE SYSTEM.
KEY ACT HERE IN MENTIONED
SEVERAL OF THEM BUT A FEW
EXAMPLES.
FROM DIVISIONS AND FUNCTIONS
ARE ACADEMIC AFFAIRS MANAGEMENT
OF THE APPLY YOU SEE APPLICATION
PROCESS.
OUR INNOVATION AND
ENTREPRENEURSHIP.
DIVISION WHICH MANAGES PATENT
ADMINISTRATION CENTRALLY. AND
PASSES THROUGH ABOUT FIFTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS OF ROYALTIES
OUGHT TO THE CAMPUSES.
AND OUR OFFICE OF CHIEF
INVESTMENT OFFICER WHICH
CENTRALLY MANAGES UC PORTFOLIO.
UP PORTFOLIOS OF INVESTED
INVESTMENTS.
I SYSTEMWIDE ACADEMIC AND PUBLIC
SERVICES PROGRAMS TOTAL FOUR
HUNDRED EIGHT POINT EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS INCLUDING ONE
HUNDRED AND TWO POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS. FOUR DIVISION
AGRICULTURAL AND NATURAL
RESOURCES.
OVER HALF OF THE TOTAL YOU CO P.
BUDGET SUPPORTS
STATEWIDE AND SYSTEM WIDE
ACADEMIC AND PUBLIC SERVICE
PROGRAMS.
THESE INCLUDE SUPPORT FOR
INSTRUCTION INCLUDING ARE YOU
SEE WASHINGTON PROGRAM RESEARCH
SUCH AS THE TOBACCO RELATED
DISEASE IN BREAST CANCER
RESEARCH AND PUBLIC SERVICE
PROGRAMS.
I'M AND ACADEMIC SUPPORT.
LIKE YOU SEE PRESS.
FOR FISCAL TWENTY SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN THE UC OP BUDGET IS
SUPPORTED BY STATE GENERAL FUNDS
WHICH WERE DIRECTLY
APPROPRIATED.
TWO HUNDRED NINETY SIX POINT
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS FOR YOU CO
P..
PLUS FIFTY TWO POINT FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE UC
PASSED CENTER.
FOR YOU SEE OUR P. THIS FUNDING
REPLACE THE CAMPUS ASSESSMENT OF
THE PRIOR YEAR. WHICH WAS THREE
HUNDRED AND TWELVE POINT FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS.
THE BALANCE OF THE SEVEN HUNDRED
NINETY SEVEN.
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS COMES
FROM INVESTMENT INCOME AND
RESTRICTED OR DESIGNATED SOURCES
SUCH AS RESEARCH GRANTS.
NATIONAL LABS INVESTMENT
RETIREMENT ADMINISTRATION PATENT
ROYALTIES AND AND SO FORTH.
SO.
MOVING ON A LINE ADVANCE NOW TO
SLIDE SEVEN.
FOR THAT NOT COMING YEAR FISCAL
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
WE'RE WORKING ON A NUMBER OF
BUDGET IMPROVEMENTS. FIRST.
YOU CEO PAY IS DEVELOPING ONE
CONSOLIDATED YOU SEE OP BUDGET
THAT ELIMINATES THE USE OF ONE
TIME OR TEMPORARY BUDGETS.
NEXT
WE'RE IMPLEMENTING THE CSA
RECOMMENDED BUDGET PRESENTATION.
WHICH INCLUDE SEVERAL
ENHANCEMENTS.
THE BUDGET WILL BE MORE
TRANSPARENT.
TO BETTER SHOW HOW YOU SEE A
PIECE BUDGET SUPPORTS THE
UNIVERSITY MISSION ACROSS
TEACHING RESEARCH AND PUBLIC
SERVICE.
THIS INCLUDES OUR COMPLETION OF
CLEAR DEFINITIONS FOR
ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES
FEE FOR SERVICE AND PASS
THROUGHS.
THESE DEFINITIONS WILL BE USED
TO DEVELOP THE BUDGET.
YOU CO P. HAS INCREASED THE
ANALYTICS
USE TO DEVELOP THE BUDGET
INCLUDING. DEVELOPMENT OF
FINANCIAL FORECASTS TO COMPARE
PROJECTED ACTUAL EXPENSES TO THE
SUBSEQUENT YEARS BUDGET.
INCREASED REVIEW INVARIANCE
ANALYSIS ON ACTUAL COSTS.
WHICH CAN BE USED TO IMPROVE
TARGETS AND THE ACCURACY OF THE
ANNUAL BUDGET.
AND ADDING NEW BUDGET
METHODOLOGIES INCLUDING ZERO
BASED BUDGETING IN AREAS SUCH AS
TRAVEL MEETINGS OUTSIDE
PROFESSIONAL SERVICES. AND
TEMPORARY EMPLOYEES.
YOU SEE APPEARS ADDING REVENUE
BUDGETS THIS YEAR WHICH CAN BE
EXPECTED TO PROVIDE IMPROVED
UNDERSTANDING OF YOU SEE A P.
FUND SOURCES.
AND HOW THEY'RE APPLIED TO
SUPPORT THE OVERALL BUDGET.
THE FY TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
BUDGET ALSO INTRODUCED A PHASED
APPROACH INTENDED TO ENABLE MORE
INPUT FROM OUR DIVISION LEADERS.
DISCUSSION SURROUNDING YOU SEE
OP RESOURCES PRIORITIES AND
TRADE OFF DECISIONS INCLUDED
MORE TRANSPARENCY. WIDER AND PUT
AND GREATER COLLABORATION.
AND I'LL REITERATE.
THAT WE RECONVENE THE EXECUTIVE
BUDGET COMMITTEE ARM WHICH IS
REPRESENTED BY CAMPUS
REPRESENTATIVES THE STUDENT.
SENATE AND OTHERS.
AND WE'VE BEEN MEETING MORE AT
LEAST MONTHLY AYE SINCE LAST
AUGUST.
.
IN ADDITION YOU SEE APPEARS
PLACE GREATER EMPHASIS ON BUDGET
PROCESS DESIGN AND
DOCUMENTATION.
THESE CAN BE EXPECTED TO PROVIDE
VALUE IN DEFINING REPEATABLE
PROCESS SEES AND ASSURANCES THAT
STANDARDS ARE SATISFIED MOVING
FORWARD.
LASTLY YOU CO P. HAVE BEEN
ADDRESSING.
OUR EXISTING BUDGET SOFTWARE AND
SYSTEM TO MAKE INCREMENTAL
IMPROVEMENTS INTENDED TO IMPROVE
THE DATA INTEGRITY.
AND REPORTING.
WHILE WE CONTINUE TO ADVANCE
EFFORTS FOR A NEW MORE ROBUST
FINANCIAL PLANNING AND REPORTING
SYSTEM.
SO I'LL MOVE TO SLIDE EIGHT.
AND SLIDE EIGHT WILL ADDRESS
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT WE'RE
DOING.
FOR THE TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN BUDGET.
I'M
THE BUDGET FOR TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN.
PRESENTS BOTH OPPORTUNITIES AND
CHALLENGES.
AS WITH MOST ORGANIZATIONS
THERE ARE TYPICALLY ANNUAL COST
INCREASES THE PLACE UPWARD
PRESSURE ON COSTS
WHICH MUST BE MANAGED.
YOU SEE A P. BUDGET FOR TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
EXCLUDING YOU SEE PATH.
IT SEEMS THE SAME LEVEL OF STATE
GENERAL FUNDS AS FY TWENTY
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN. AT TWO
HUNDRED NINETY SIX POINT FOUR
MILLION. AS THERE WAS NO THREE
PERCENT ADJUSTMENT PROVIDED IN
THE JANUARY BUDGET INTRODUCTION
FOR YOU CEO PAY.
I'LL ADD THAT A THREE PERCENT
ADJUSTMENT WOULD BE
APPROXIMATELY NINE MILLION
DOLLAR INCREASE.
AND ALSO NOTE THAT THIS LEVEL OF
FUNDING.
WOULD NOW BE FLAT.
FOR A THIRD CONSECUTIVE YEAR.
ROUGHLY AT THE FY TWENTY SIXTEEN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN ASSESSMENT
LEVEL.
THE CONFUSION AROUND SOME OF THE
INCREASE IN THE OP BUDGET I
THINK I IS DRIVEN BY THINGS SUCH
AS RESEARCH GRANTS AND FUNDS
THAT CAN INCREASE THE HARM.
FOR PURPOSES OF SOME OF THOSE
TYPES OF PROGRAMS.
ETHIOPIA'S PLANNING FOR REDUCE
REVENUES ASSOCIATED WITH
REDIRECTION OF A POINT FIVE
MILLION TO BE USED TO SUPPORT AN
INCREASE IN UNDERGRADUATE
ENROLLMENT.
ADDITIONALLY EACH YEAR THERE
COST INCREASES AREAS LIKE
EMPLOYEE BENEFITS AND CONTRACTS
WITH OUTSIDE VENDORS.
THAT MUST BE MET.
I'M WE MENTIONED EARLIER THEY.
ESTABLISHMENT OF A STRATEGIC
PRIORITY FIND PRACTICE WHICH WAS
REVIEWED BY THE UC REGENTS IN
JANUARY. AND THAT CALLS FOR
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
PERMANENT BUDGET.
SUPPORT STRATEGIC AN URGENT
NEEDS.
AN EXAMPLE OF.
OUR THE USE OF THOSE FUNDS ARE
ARE TWO MILLION DOLLARS OF
SUPPORT FOR UC RIVERSIDE MEDICAL
SCHOOL.
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS PRACTICE.
WILL REDUCED ETHIOPIAN SPANNED
BY APPROXIMATELY HALF FOR THESE
PURPOSES.
AFTER THE ELIMINATION OF
PREVIOUS PRACTICE OF ONE TIME OR
TEMPORARY BUDGETS.
HOWEVER IT PUTS PRESSURE ON THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BUDGET.
LASTLY WERE INCORPORATING
RESTRUCTURING CHANGES AND
INCLUDING THE BUDGET IMPACTS.
TO OFFSET THESE UPWARD PRESSURES
YOU SEE A P. HAS BEEN
UNDERTAKING COST SAVINGS
EFFORTS.
WHICH INCLUDE TARGETING LOWER
TRAVEL EXTERNAL SERVICES IN
MEMBERSHIPS.
IMPLEMENTING POLICY CHANGES.
TRAVEL REIMBURSEMENT STIPENDS
STAR AWARDS.
REDUCING THE PRESIDENT'S
INITIATIVE FIND WHICH WAS
BUDGETED PREVIOUSLY AT SEVEN AT
NINE POINT EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS.
BY TWO MILLION DOLLARS WHICH IS
GOING TOWARD.
ENROLLMENT GROWTH.
I SUBSEQUENTLY DISCONTINUING THE
USE OF ONE TIME TEMPORARY
BUDGETS.
WE'RE GOING THROUGH AND HAVE
GONE THROUGH A THOROUGH REVIEW
OF ALL OPEN POSITIONS AND
VACANCIES N ADJUSTING THESE
ACCORDINGLY TO REDUCE BUDGET
VARIANCE.
SALARY SAVINGS.
AND FINALLY ELIMINATING ANY
CONTINGENCIES
ARM AS THESE NOW MUST BE COVERED
WITHIN THE STRATEGIC PRIORITY
FUND.
SO.
TO KIND OF CLOSE WE ARE.
STILL WORKING THROUGH THE BUDGET
WE HAVE SOME REVIEWS THAT WE
STILL MUST GO THROUGH WITH THE
PRESIDENT.
AND OF COURSE WE ARE DRIVING
TOWARD THE.
PRESENTATION OF THE BUDGET TO
THE REGENTS.
WHICH WILL HAPPEN MAY TWENTY
THIRD.
SO WITH THAT I'LL AND THERE AND.
WE'LL TAKE QUESTIONS.
QUESTION
ESTHER MEDINA. A QUESTION
QUESTION TO MR CLARITY. ON RE
BENCHING.
SOMETHING THAT IS.
IMPORTANT TO AYE I THINK SOME
OF THE SMALLER CAMPUSES UC
RIVERSIDE UC SANTA BARBARA UC
SANTA CRUZ.
YOU MENTIONED AND I THINK YOU
STATED IN THE BUDGET.
THAT.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO YOU SEE.
DON'T HAVE IN FRONT OF ME THAT
ALL STUDENTS I HAVE THE SAME
SHARE OF STATE FUNDING.
SO HAVE WE CLOSE THAT GAP IS
THAT GAP.
GONE AND NO LONGER EXISTED WARY
STUDENT UCLA IS BEING FUNDED
MUCH HIGHER.
RATE.
THEN A STUDENT AT UC SANTA
BARBARA UC RIVERSIDE.
THE UC SANTA CRUZ
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR MEDINA
AND I.
I CAN SAY THAT AT THIS FISCAL
YEAR.
AYE EITHER MARKS THE FIRST OR
THE SECOND AND MS BRITANNIAN
CAN.
CONFIRM FOR ME WITH THAT THEY
RE BENCHING PROCESS HAS BECOME
COMPLETE WE ADVANCED IT BY A
YEAR.
ITS IMPLEMENTATION PLAN BY A
YEAR I'M.
PREVIOUSLY.
WHEN WE'RE GOING THROUGH SOME
SOME PRIOR YEAR'S BUDGET
NEGOTIATIONS AND
AND NOW WE CAN STATE THAT YET
STUDENTS AT EVERY CAMPUS ARE ARE
RECEIVING THE SAME LEVEL OF
STATE GENERAL FUND.
SUPPORT ONE CAMPUS TO THE OTHER
THAT CONCERN THAT I REYES TODAY
IS THAT THERE NEEDED TO BE.
I SOME AYE INTERNAL ACCOUNTING
THAT NEEDED TO BE DONE. TO
ENSURE THAT UNDER THIS NEW MATH
ED WHERE THE STATE IS DIRECT
LINE ITEM APPROPRIATING THE
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT BUDGET.
THAT THAT THAT DIDN'T HAVE ANY
NEGATIVE IMPACTS ON THE PER
STUDENT FUNDING FOR FOR EACH
CAMPUS. AYE THERE IS SOME SOME
CHANGE IN BUDGETING THAT THAT
NEEDED TO BE DONE TO ACCOMMODATE
THAT BUT YES IT'S HAPPENING.
WELL I I WOULD APPLAUD YOU SEE
IN AND GETTING THEIR.
I THINK IT WAS VERY.
.
KIND OF A STARK REVELATION TO A
LOT OF FOLKS WHEN WHEN THAT CAME
UP. SO I I APPLAUD. YOU SEE FOR.
MAKING IT MORE EQUAL A ACROSS
THE SYSTEM. AND HOPE THAT THAT.
FUTURE FUNDING MECHANISMS DON'T
DISRUPT THAT.
BECAUSE THE.
IT SEEMS VERY UNFAIR.
THE THE PREVIOUS SYSTEM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
APPRECIATE THAT.
OKAY THANK YOU WE WE HEAR THE.
THEIR REQUEST THANKS FOR THE
UPDATE AND.
WE STILL STAND BY THE ACTION
FROM LAST YEAR'S BUDGET.
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE YOU SEE PAT
.
OKAY.
GO AHEAD.
OUR GOOD AFTERNOON OR GOOD GOOD
MORNING.
MARK SIALKOT UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA I'M YOU SO SHE FACE
PRESIDENT FOR OPERATIONAL
SERVICES.
CHOOSE A SYSTEM WIDE ACTIVITY.
TODAY WE'RE HERE TO.
PROVIDE AN INITIAL BRIEFING ON
YOU SEE PATH WE'VE NOT COME TO
THIS COMMITTEE BEFORE TO TALK
ABOUT YOU SEE PATH.
SO IN THE PRESENTATION THAT'S IN
FRONT OF YOU TODAY.
I'D LIKE TO VERY BRIEFLY
INTRODUCE.
THE NATURE OF YOU SEE PATH
INITIATIVE ARE INTENDED AND
STATE. ARE TO PROVIDE YOU
CURRENT STATUS AND THEN TO LOOK
AT OUR PROPOSED OPERATING BUDGET
FOR FORWARD LOOKING YEARS.
ON SLIDE TO THE DECK OF VERY
BRIEFLY YOU SEE PATH.
IS A SYSTEM WIDE INITIATIVE IN
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA TO
ACHIEVE A COUPLE OF MAJOR
OBJECTIVES THE FIRST OF WHICH IS
TO REPLACE.
ELEVEN VERSIONS OF OUR AGING
PAYROLL SYSTEM ARE WHICH IS BEEN
AROUND FOR THIRTY FIVE YEARS AND
IS IN VARIOUS STATES OF FAILING
HEALTH.
BUT SIMULTANEOUSLY TO ESTABLISH
A SHARED SERVICES CENTER FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIAN PLOYS
SYSTEM WIDE.
IT PROVIDES A NUMBER OF SERVICES
RELATED TO PAYROLL.
HUMAN RESOURCES.
BENEFITS ADMINISTRATION.
AND MANAGEMENT OF THE EMPLOYEE
LIFE CYCLE THE NAME YOU SEE PATH
ITSELF IS AN ACRONYM THAT
CONTAINS A DESCRIPTION OF THE
SERVICES IT PROVIDES. PATH
STANDS FOR PAYROLL ACADEMIC H.
OUR TIME KEEPING AND HUMAN
RESOURCES.
THE UC PATH CENTER IS LOCATED IN
RIVERSIDE CALIFORNIA.
AT AT ITS PEAK STAFFING WE
EXPECT ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED AND
FORTY EMPLOYEES WILL BE
PROVIDING. PATH SERVICES.
UP TO UPWARDS OF TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY THOUSAND EMPLOYEES.
OF THE SERVICES THAT WE
PROVIDING AS PART OF A DEFINED.
AND.
UNIVERSAL.
SERVICE CATALOG THAT EACH CAMPUS
WE'LL USE.
AND WILL PROVIDE COMMON SERVICES
FOR ALL SHE YOU SEE EMPLOYEES.
NOT SO UP MANY OF THE SERVICES
THAT THE YOU SEE PAST CENTER
WILL BE PROVIDING ARE ACTUALLY
HAVE BEEN PROVIDED HISTORICALLY
AT THE CAMPUSES.
BOB BUT THEY'VE BEEN PROVIDED IN
DIFFERENT WAYS IN A DIFFERENT
LEVELS OF QUALITY. UP SO WE ARE
CONSOLIDATING AT THE UC PATH
CENTER.
TO GET THERE. WE STARTED A
PROJECT IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN
TO REPLACE.
AN OLD GREEN SCREEN MAINFRAME
PAYROLL SYSTEM.
WITH.
PEOPLESOFT'S HUMAN CAPITAL
MANAGEMENT APPLICATION AS THE
CORE SOFTWARE FOR THE UC PATH
INITIATIVE.
AND AT THE SAME TIME BEGAN TO
BUILD OUT AT THE UC PATH CENTER
IN RIVERSIDE.
TO DATE WE HAVE.
DEPLOYED YOU SEE PATH
CHU CHU CAMPUSES.
TO THE OFFICE THE PRESIDENT. AND
TO THE ASSOCIATED STUDENTS OF
UCLA.
ALL TOLD THAT'S JUST OVER
SIXTEEN THOUSAND EMPLOYEES WHO
ARE CURRENTLY RECEIVING SERVICES
FROM YOU SEE PATH.
SLIDE THREE THEN SHOWS THE
REMAINING DEPLOYMENTS THAT ARE
IN FRONT OF US TO COMPLETE THE
PROJECT.
IT'S CURRENTLY TARGETED TO
COMPLETE IN SEPTEMBER OF TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN.
THIS SUMMER WE WILL BRING YOU
SEE LA AND SANTA BARBARA INTO
YOU SEE PATH.
WHICH WILL REPRESENT THE FIRST.
YOU SEE HEALTH ORGANIZATION THAT
WILL COME INTO YOU SEE PATH.
AND REALLY AT THAT POINT ARE
COMPLETE.
THE AVAILABILITY OF YOU SEE
PAST SERVICES TO ALL EMPLOYEE
TYPES IN THE UC SYSTEM.
FROM THERE WE HAVE ANOTHER
DEPLOYMENT IN MARCH OF TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN. AND AGAIN OUR
FINAL DEPLOYMENT IN SEPTEMBER OF
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN.
AT THAT TIME WILL BE SERVING
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY
THOUSAND YOU SEE EMPLOYEES.
SLIDE FOUR SHOWS OUR CURRENT
YEAR.
BUDGET AND FORECAST
FOR THE UC PATH CENTER.
THE DIRECT APPROPRIATION IT WAS
GIVEN TO THE OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT THIS YEAR. INCLUDED A
LINE ITEM OF FIFTY TWO POINT
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS FOR YOU SEE
PATH.
ARE THAT WAS ORIGINALLY A
BUDGETED TO.
BE SPENT ENTIRELY ON YOU SEE
PATH CENTER OPERATING COSTS.
BUT.
SHORTLY AFTER THE BEGINNING OF
THE FISCAL YEAR. THE UCLA CAMPUS
DELAYED ITS DEPLOYMENT OF YOU
SEE PATH.
IS WHY YOU SEE THEM ON THE
PREVIOUS SLIDE LISTED IN THE
SEPTEMBER DEPLOYMENT.
THAT DELAY CAUSED US TO
SIGNIFICANTLY. ARE SLOW DOWN OUR
STAFFING RAMP IN ANTICIPATION OF
THAT DEPLOYMENT. AND SO.
CAUSED US TO SEEK TO OUR.
CHANGE OUR FORECAST ON EXPENSES
AT THE CENTER TO ABOUT FORTY
POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS.
THE REMAINING TWELVE POINT TWO
MILLION IS BEING SPENT ON.
KNOWLEDGE TRANSFER ACTIVITIES
FROM PROJECT CONSULTANTS TO YOU
SEE EMPLOYEES AT THE PAST
CENTER.
AND ACCOUNTS FOR THE REMAINING
TWELVE POINT TWO MILLION DOLLAR
SPENT.
SLIDE FIVE THEN SHOWS OUR
FORECAST FOR THE NEXT SEVERAL
FISCAL YEARS ARE IN SHOWS A
FAIRLY SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
GROWTH IN YOU SEE PATH OPERATING
EXPENSE. IN FISCAL YEAR
NINETEEN.
TO ACCOMMODATE THE ADDITIONAL
STAFF WILL NEED TO BRING ON FOR
THE.
DEPLOYMENTS THAT WERE LISTED ON
SLIDE TO.
SO WE EXPECT TO GROW FROM OF
FIFTY FOUR EXCUSE ME FIFTY TWO
POINT FOUR MILLION THIS YEAR.
TO AN OPERATING COST OF SIX
A SEVEN POINT SEVEN MILLION NEXT
YEAR. WILL HAVE A A DEBT SERVICE
EXPENSE ON TOP OF THAT.
TO.
ACCOMMODATE THE INITIAL PROJECT
ALONE OF TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
MILLION.
THAT WAS USED TO FUND THE FIRST
SEVERAL YEARS OF THE PROJECT.
BEYOND THAT THEY AND WE HAVE A
CONDITIONAL SMALL AMOUNT OF
GROWTH IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY. TO
ACCOMMODATE THE FINAL STAFFING
NUMBERS FOR THE FINAL DEPLOYMENT
AND THEM WERE REALLY AT STEADY
STATE.
UP WITH THE ADDITION OF OUR
PRINCIPAL INTEREST PAYMENTS ON
THAT TWO HUNDRED TWENTY MILLION
DOLLAR LOAN. BEGINNING IN FY
TWENTY TWO.
UP SO WE END UP JUST UNDER A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS  YEAR
ANNUAL COST TO PROVIDE. A FULL
LIFE CYCLE OF.
EMPLOYEE SERVICES TO ALL YOU
SEE EMPLOYEES BY FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY TWO.
SLIDE SIX OUTLINES THE NATURE OF
OUR REQUEST.
TO YOU OUGHT TO RETURN THE UC
PATH FUNDING MODEL. BACK TO THE
FEE FOR SERVICE.
THE PIE CHART ON SLIGHT SIX
OUTLINES.
THE FUNDING SOURCES FOR NON
STUDENT EMPLOYEES AT ALL SO YOU
SEE LOCATIONS.
ARE IN IN THIS YOU SEE THAT
STATE GENERAL FUNDS ONLY
ACCOMMODATE.
APPROXIMATELY SEVENTEEN PERCENT
OF OUR PAYROLL EXPENSE ACROSS
ALL EMPLOYEE TYPES.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF OUR OUR
PAYROLL COMES FROM AUXILIARY
FUNDS OF MOST NOTABLY FROM ARE
YOU SEE HEALTH LOCATIONS WHERE
ABOUT NINETY SIX NINETY SEVEN
PERCENT OF OUR PAYROLL EXPENSE.
IS FROM NON GENERAL FUND.
SO WHILE WE REQUEST THIS A
RETURN TO FEE FOR SERVICE.
AND A RETURN OF THE EXISTING
APPROPRIATION FOR PATH.
BACK TO THE CAMPUSES.
WELL AS A WAY OF ALLOWING THE
CAMPUSES TO MAKE THE THE BEST
DETERMINATION LOCALLY ABOUT THE
FUNDS SOURCE TO USE FOR YOU SEE
PATH SERVICES. AS IT'S
APPROPRIATE.
OUT TO THE BUSINESS FUNCTION OF
THE CAMPUS.
WITHOUT THAT IN PLACE OF WHAT
THE LEGISLATURE.
ENDS UP DOING IS SUBSIDIZING IN
SOME FORM
THE PAYROLL EXPENSES OF THE YOU
SEE HOSPITALS. ARE AND OTHER NON
GENERAL FUND IT.
ACTIVITIES IN THE UC SYSTEM.
SO THAT'S THE BASIS FOR OUR
REQUEST A TO RETURN TO THE FEE
FOR SERVICE MODEL.
FINALLY THE OPERATING BUDGET AND
THE PROJECT COME TOGETHER ON
SLIDE SEVEN.
THIS IS THE SINGLE MOST
SIGNIFICANT RISKS THAT WE HAVE
IDENTIFIED TO THE REGIONS. IN
OUR BRIEFINGS OF YOU SEE PATH
FOR THEM.
IF YOU LOOK AT THIS CHART.
IT'S A BIT BUSY SO LET ME
DECOMPOSE IT A BIT FOR YOU THE
X. AXIS.
IS A FUNCTION OF TIME. AND IT
SHOWS YOU THE.
THE NUMBER OF EMPLOYEES AS
LISTED IN THE Y. AXIS.
OF WHO WILL BE SERVED BY YOU SEE
PATH.
THERE ARE TWO OF OVAL SHAPED
NUMBERS THAT SHOW OUR CURRENT
STAFFING IF YOU SEE PATH CENTER.
AND OUR TARGET STAFFING AMOUNT
FOR THE END OF FISCAL YEAR
NINETEEN. THAT'S WHAT BECAUSE
THAT'S THE BASIS FOR THE GROWTH
IN OUR OPERATING BUDGET FOR
FISCAL YEAR NINETEEN.
AS WE ARE CURRENTLY STAFFED.
WE ARE ABLE TO ACCOMMODATE THE
LA SANTA BARBARA DEPLOYMENT WITH
NO ADDITIONAL STAFFING.
BUT IF THE OPERATING BUDGET IS
HELD FLAT.
OR EVEN WITH A THREE PERCENT
BASE ADJUSTMENT.
WE WILL NOT HAVE THE STAFFING
THAT WE'VE IDENTIFIED AS
NECESSARY.
TO ACCOMMODATE THE FINAL TWO
DEPLOYMENTS FOR YOU SEE PATH.
AND SO WITHOUT THAT GROWTH IN
THE OPERATING BUDGET. WE
ESSENTIALLY PUT THE BRAKES ON
OUR ABILITY TO FINISH THE
APPOINTMENT PROJECT.
AND THEREBY EITHER CAUSING US
TO INDEFINITELY DELAY THOSE
FINAL DEPLOYMENTS.
ARE OR TO LOOK FOR OTHER WAYS
TO.
EITHER REDUCE SERVICES OF WHICH
ARE AT THIS POINT.
PRETTY ESSENTIAL TO.
EMPLOYEE LIFE CYCLE MANAGEMENT
OR OTHERWISE DEGRADE THE QUALITY
OF THOSE SERVICES IN TERMS OF
SERVICE LEVELS.
UP SO AGAIN OUR OUR OUR REQUEST
TO RETURN TO THE FEE FOR SERVICE
MODEL.
I IS TIED TO OUR ABILITY TO GROW
THE OPERATING BUDGET IN THE WAY
WE DEFINE WITH THE CAMPUSES.
WE HAVE BEEN FORECASTING THESE
AMOUNTS WITH THE CAMPUSES FOR
SEVERAL YEARS NOW. THEY ARE
PREPARED TO ACCOMMODATE THIS
GROWTH.
AND IT REALLY IS A PREREQUISITE
FOR OUR ABILITY TO COMPLETE THE
PROJECT COMPONENT OF YOU SEE
PATH.
SUCCESSFULLY.
.
MISTER CHAIR THOSE ARE MY
COMMENTS AND I WOULD BE HAPPY TO
TAKE QUESTIONS
OKAY. QUESTIONS.
MR MEDINA GROUP.
CAN YOU TELL ME WHAT WHAT YEAR
DID THE BUILDING OPEN UP THAT
RIVERSIDE.
THAT'S PROBABLY THE ONE
QUESTION I WASN'T ABSOLUTELY
CERTAIN BUT I'M GONNA GUESS TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN
TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN YES.
AND IT'S A BUILDING THAT YOU SEE
PURCHASED.
OF WE LEASE HALF OF THE BUILDING
TO THE UC RIVERSIDE CAMPUS AND
HALF TO YOU SEE PATH.
TO BOTH ENTITIES PAY RENT IN
THAT AND AND AT THIS TIME OF THE
UC PATH. IS DOING THE.
.
ALL THOSE DIFFERENT.
ACADEMIC PERSONNEL TIME KEEPING
HUMAN RESOURCES AND PAYROLL. FOR
THE UC RIVERSIDE THE MERCED
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT. AND.
A A. S. UCLA CORRECT THAT IS
CORRECT AT AND IT AND NONE.
SOMEHOW I IN ADDITION WE ALSO
PROVIDE.
SERVICES IN SUPPORT OF THE
LEGACY PAYROLL SYSTEM FOR UCLA
AND FOR SANTA CRUZ.
BECAUSE THOSE CAMPUSES.
ARE BOTH AS A RESULT OF
REDUCTIONS IN GENERAL FUNDING
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS AND
IN ANTICIPATION OF YOU SEE PATH
DEPLOYMENT. ALLOWED THEIR
PAYROLL DEPARTMENTS TO.
DECREASE IN SIZE GENERALLY
THROUGH ATTRITION SO WE CAME TO
AN AGREEMENT WITH THEM RATHER
THAN TRYING TO HIRE PEOPLE WHO
WOULD ONLY COME ON FOR A FEW
YEARS. WE WOULD TAKE ON THOSE
SERVICES AT THE UC PASS CENTER
SO WE ARE PROVIDING PPS SERVICES
THAT'S THE LEGACY SYSTEM FOR
BOTH UCLA AND FOR SANTA CRUZ
CURRENTLY.
LEGACY IN IN ADDITION YOU SEE
PATH THEN AND I WOULD ASSUME
THAT UC RIVERSIDE WAS DOING ITS
OWN.
PAYROLL ACADEMIC PERSON ON TIME
KEEPING AND HUMAN RESOURCES
ALREADY AT RIVERSIDE YET SO WE
ARE PROVIDING THE SERVICES FOR
ALL EMPLOYEES AT THE RIVERSIDE
CAN BUT THEY WERE DOING AND ALL
THEY WERE DOING IT FOR
THEMSELVES PREFIX FOR THAT
CAMPUS.
SO IN THE LAST FIVE YEARS.
RIGHT SINCE TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN.
AND THE LAST FIVE YEARS SINCE
IT'S BEEN.
THERE.
AND IN REALITY IN REALITY ONLY
MERCED IN THE OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT HAS BEEN ADDED.
IN THE FIVE YEARS THAT THAT THAT
IT'S BEEN IN EXISTENCE
I'M SORRY LET ME CORRECT MY
PREVIOUS NOTS ARE.
IT MAY BE HELPFUL FIVE PROVIDE
A CHRONOLOGY OF OF THE
DEPLOYMENTS WE WENT LIVE WITH
THE OFFICE THE PRESIDENT IN
DISSENT NOVEMBER DECEMBER OF TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN THAT WAS THE
FIRST LOCATION.
TO BEGIN USING YOU SEE PATH.
ARE WE THEN DEPLOYED ARE THE
THAT. LOCATIONS ARE IN
PRODUCTION LAST DECEMBER SO
THAT'S.
MERCED RIVERSIDE ACE UCLA.
BEGAN USING YOU SEE PATH MOVED
OFF THE LEGACY SYSTEM IN
DECEMBER OF TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN.
BOB SO THEY'VE BEEN ACTIVE WITH
YOU SEE PATH FOR ABOUT FOUR
MONTHS NOW OKAY.
AND THEN.
AS YOU SEE IN THE SCHEDULE ON
THE
THE TIMELINE SLIDE.
YOU SEE WHEN THE OTHER
LOCATIONS COME ONBOARD.
I I BRING IT UP BECAUSE I I WAS
AT THE RIBBON CUTTING.
FOR THE UC PATH.
IT'S A BEAUTIFUL BUILDING.
LOTS OF SPACE.
BUT I I'M I'M BRINGING UP THE
THE.
.
THE SLOWNESS.
OF.
OF GETTING. IT OPERATIONAL.
FOR OTHER CAMPUSES.
.
I IF I REMEMBER IT'S PROBABLY
YOU KNOW.
THREE FLOORS SOMETHING LIKE THAT
YOU KNOW A LOT LOUDERSPACE FOR
EMPLOYEES THAT YOU'RE LOOKING
TOWARDS. FOUR HUNDRED AND FORTY.
EMPLOYEES AND TWENTY BUT IT IS
BEEN A SLOW PROCESS FOR YOU SEE.
TO TO MAKE IT OPERATIONAL FOR
THE OTHER CAMPUSES.
CAN YOU SPEAK TO THAT I CAN'T
SPEAK TO THAT AND I APPRECIATE
THE OBSERVATION.
THE UC PATH PROJECT.
INITIALLY WAS SOLD.
.
I SAY SOLD IT WAS.
PRESENTED TO THE REGENTS AS AN
OPPORTUNITY.
UP TO SAVE MONEY AND AND REALLY
FORCE AS A FORCING FUNCTION FOR
OPERATIONAL EFFICIENCY SYSTEM
WIDE.
WE KNEW THAT THE LEGACY PAYROLL
SYSTEM WHICH WE CALL PPS.
FAILING.
OUR WE UNDERSTOOD THAT OUT WE
HAD SIGNIFICANT COMPLIANCE
ISSUES.
OUR IN OUR EXECUTION OF PAYROLL
BASED ON THE FACT WE HAD ELEVEN
SEPARATE VERSIONS OF THE PAYROLL
SYSTEM.
UP SO I BELIEVE THAT THE
ORIGINAL.
LEADERSHIP OF THE PROJECT.
FELT THAT BY QUICKLY
IMPLEMENTING A SOFTWARE
SOLUTION.
WE WOULD FORCE THE ADOPTION OF A
COMMON SET OF BUSINESS
PROCESSES.
THAT TURNED OUT NOT TO BE THE
CASE.
AND AND THE FIRST TWO YEARS OF
THE PROJECT.
WERE SPENT.
ARE IN WHAT I WOULD DESCRIBE AS
A RATHER AGONIZING AMOUNT OF.
FAILURE TO COMMUNICATE BETWEEN
THE CENTRAL PROJECT OFFICE AND
THE CAMPUSES.
I JOIN THE PROJECT IN TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN AS ITS LEADER.
AND AT THAT TIME WE PUT SYSTEM
OR SOFTWARE DEPLOYMENT ON HOLD.
AND WE SPENT ABOUT EIGHT MONTHS
WORKING WITH THE CAMPUS IS TO
DEFINE OUR FUTURE STATE BUSINESS
PROCESSES.
HOW WERE WE GOING TO DO? ALL OF
THE FUNCTIONS OF YOU SEE PATH.
WHERE WOULD A PROCESS INITIATE
WHERE WITH THE HAND OFF TO THE
PATH CENTER BE?
IF WE NEEDED TO HEAD BACK TO
CAMPUS WHAT WOULD THAT LOOK
LIKE.
WE DID THAT FOR A HUNDRED AND
FIVE.
BUSINESS PROCESSES FROM HIRING
DETERMINATION TO.
TOP BENEFITS ADMINISTRATION AND
EVERYTHING IN BETWEEN.
OUR AND WITH THAT CLARITY WE
COULD THEN GO BACK AND ACTUALLY
BE EFFECTIVE AT.
DOING THE WORK ASSOCIATED WITH A
IMPLEMENTING THE SOFTWARE
COMPONENT OF YOU SEE PATH.
ALSO DURING THAT TIME ONCE WE
HAD THE BUSINESS PROCESSES
DEFINED.
WE COULD THEN REALLY LOOK AT.
FINISHING THE PLANNING FOR
STAFFING UP THE PATH CENTER WE
OPEN AT THIRTEEN.
BUT IT WAS WITH A SKELETAL CREW
THERE WAS A A GROUP OF ABOUT
EIGHT PEOPLE FOR THE FIRST YEAR
AND A HALF AT THE CENTER BEFORE
WE REALLY STARTED HIRING PEOPLE.
ARE AND THEY WERE CONCERNED WITH
THE BUILD OUT OF THE FACILITY.
THEY WERE CONCERNED WITH THE
DESIGN OF THEIR COMPONENTS OF
PROCESS.
BOB AND ARE YOU SEE ADMITS THAT
THE EARLY YEARS OF THE PROJECT
WERE CHALLENGING. ONCE WE
BROUGHT THE OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT LIVE.
WE REALLY HAD A PROOF OF
CONCEPT THAT. THIS NEW PAYROLL
SYSTEM WOULD WORK WE WERE USING
IT TO GENERATE PAYROLL FOR YOU
SEE EMPLOYEES. ALBEIT. VERY
SIMPLE KINDS OF PAYROLL BECAUSE
MOST OF THE STAFF
AT THE OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT.
ARE NOT ACADEMICS
STAFF EMPLOYEES.
NOT STUDENTS NOT NOT PHYSICIANS.
SO A RATHER STRAIGHTFORWARD
KIND OF PAYROLL.
A TWO YEARS BETWEEN THE OFFICE
OF THE PRESIDENT DEPLOYMENT.
AND B. DEPLOYMENT WE DID LAST
DECEMBER. WAS TIME THAT WE SPENT
REALLY MAKING SURE THAT WE COULD
HANDLE THE COMPLEXITY OF
ACADEMIC PAYROLL.
BOB YOU HEARD UP THROUGH SOME OF
THE COMMENTS.
FOR HER IN EARLIER
PRESENTATIONS TODAY. ABOUT SOME
OF THE COMPLEXITY OF YOU SEE AND
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT MAKES
PAYROLL ANY RESEARCH INTERESTS
INSTITUTION SO COMPLEX.
THE FACT THAT ANY GIVEN FACULTY
MEMBER CAN HAVE UPWARDS OF THREE
TO FOUR DOZEN GRANTS.
THAT THEY USED TO PAY BOTH
THEMSELVES THEIR RESEARCH
ASSISTANTS AND THEY'RE TEACHING
ASSIST.
AND SO THE DISTRIBUTION OF THOSE
RESEARCH FUNDS.
FOR EVERY SINGLE PAYROLL. CAN
VARY FROM PAY PERIOD TO PAY
PERIOD. AND THE SYSTEM HAS TO BE
ABLE TO ACCOMMODATE THAT SO
BUILDING.
SYSTEM OUT IN A WAY THAT ASSURED
ARE ACADEMICS THAT WE COULD DO
ACADEMIC PAY CORRECTLY.
TOOK THAT AMOUNT OF TIME.
AND MOST OF THAT TIME WAS SPENT
IN TESTING TO MAKE SURE IT WAS
WITHIN TOLERANCES AND FOR US
THAT MEANS PAY HAD COME WITHIN.
FIVE SENSE OF WHAT WE EXPECTED
IT TO BE.
SO WE HAVE MET THOSE THRESHOLDS
WE ARE NOW LIVE WITH ACADEMICS.
IN REALLY THE WORK THAT'S
ASSOCIATED WITH THE REMAINING
DEPLOYMENTS FOR PATH.
IS MORE ABOUT.
ENSURING THAT WE CONVERT LEGACY
RECORDS FOR EMPLOYEES AND LESS
ABOUT BUILDING SOFTWARE TO DO
THE PAYROLL ITSELF WERE DONE
WITH THE BUILD FACE.
NOW WE'RE REALLY FOCUSED ON
SIMPLY TRANSITIONING EMPLOYEES
FROM THE OLD SYSTEM TO THE NEW.
SO IT WAS A SLOW START AND WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT.
AND WE AND WE MADE EARLY
MISTAKES.
BUT WERE AND A POINT THE PROJECT
NOW WHERE.
IT'S A MUCH MORE DEFINED SET OF
PROCESSES THAT WE'RE PURSUING.
AND OUR ABILITY TO.
GET TO THE END OF THE PROJECT.
BUT WE HAVE MUCH HIGHER
CONFIDENCE THAT WILL MAKE IT
WITHIN THE REMAINING BUDGET. AND
WITHIN THE TIMELINE THAT WE'VE
IDENTIFIED.
IT IF I COULD DO IS THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S HAVE.
ANY INFORMATION ON HOW MUCH
MORE IT COSTS.
THAN WAS ORIGINALLY PROJECTED.
TO TO PHASE AND TWO TO DO THIS
TO CHANGE FROM. A DECENTRALIZED
PROCESS
TO WHAT.
SUPPOSED TO BE A COST SAVING.
A PROCESS BY CENTRALIZING HOW
MUCH MORE AS A COSTS THAN WAS
FIRST ESTIMATED.
ANYWAY I DO HAVE SOME OF THAT
INFORMATION.
NOT AT MY FINGERTIPS I'D BE
HAPPY TO FOLLOW UP WITH YOUR
STAFF ON THAT.
BUT I THINK GENERALLY ONE OF
THE CHALLENGES HERE IS THAT I'M
AS AS YOU SEE INDICATED THIS WAS
ORIGINALLY. PRESENTED TO THE
REGION'S AS A WAY TO SORT OF.
YOU KNOW SAVE COSTS THE IDEA WAS
THAT YOU SEE PATH WOULD TAKE
OVER A LOT OF SERVICES PAYROLL
SERVICES OTHER TYPES OF.
HUMAN RESOURCE SERVICES THAT
THAT CAMPUSES WERE CURRENTLY
DOING AND SO THAT WOULD RESULT
IN SOME STAFF SAVINGS.
BUT THAT'S NOT CHANGED CAMPUSES
ARE NOW INDICATING THAT.
.
THEY AREN'T REALLY.
THEY DON'T PRETTY PROJECT TO BE
ABLE SERVING HER THOSE SAVINGS
ITS MORE ABOUT US SERVE COST
AVOIDANCE AND I I HAVEN'T SEEN
ANY SORT OF QUANTIFICATION OF
THAT SORT OF COST OF WHEN IT'S
MOVING FORWARD.
I THINK THAT'S SORT OF ONE
QUESTION FOR THE LEGISLATURE AS
IT CONSIDERS THIS PROPOSAL IS. A
WHETHER OR NOT IT IT AGREES THAT
CAMPUSES CANNOT SORT OF IDENTIFY
THOSE SAVINGS WITH AND THERE'S
BUT DIDN'T WITHIN THOSE BUDGETS
AND. AND IT CAN'T CAN'T ACTUALLY
SERVING GATE WITH YOU SEE PATH
IN A WAY THAT SERVER REVISITS
THE CONSTRUCTS IN RIVERS THAT
SORT OF THEIR ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS.
I THINK I DESERVE ONE QUESTION
FACING THE LEGISLATURE ARE ARE
ARE YOU SAYING IT WON'T BE.
BUT COST SAVINGS.
FOR ARE UNDERSTANDING BASED ON
WHAT YOU SEE HAS PRESENTED IS
THAT A LOT OF THE INITIAL COST
SAVINGS THAT WERE PROJECTED.
WHERE OUT SOMEWHAT OVER
STATEMENTS TODAY TODAY THAT YOU
SEE IN THIS CASE THAT IT'S A
MORE OF A COST AVOIDANCE NOT?
SORT OF THE INITIAL COST SAVINGS
THAT WERE INITIALLY PROJECTED
WHEN IT WAS PRESENTED TO THE
REGENTS.
BUT WHEN IT'S A AT CAPACITY IN
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN WILL IT
COST YOU SEE LESS.
TO RUN OPERATE.
SO MR MEDINA WE WE DOCUMENTED
THE
COST OF DELIVERY OF THESE KINDS
OF SERVICES.
OUR IT TWO POINTS IN THE PAST WE
DID UP A MAJOR INITIATIVE WITH
PRICE WATERHOUSE COOPERS IN YOUR
TWO THOUSAND. AND WE FOLLOWED
THAT UP IN THE YEAR TWO THOUSAND
TEN UNDERSTAND.
PRIMARILY AN F. T. E. LEVEL.
WHAT WAS GOING ON WITH THE
DELIVERY OF THE SERVICES?
BOB AND IN SOME OF THOSE
OF REPORTS.
ARE THERE WERE NUMBERS THAT
IDENTIFIED OF AREAS WHERE. YOU
SEE WAS.
ENGAGED IN A LOT OF WASTEFUL
ACTIVITY IN THE RE WORK.
PAYROLL RELATED ACTIVITIES.
IN THE TWO THOUSAND TEN.
REPORT FROM PWC THE IDENTIFIED
UP TO A HUNDRED MILLION A YEAR.
OF RE WORK COSTS
FOR MISTAKES IN PAYROLL.
SO. GUY I MENTIONED EARLIER THAT
THE COMPLEXITY OF ACADEMIC.
PAY ALLOCATING RESEARCH GRANTS
TO TO PAY.
ARE IS A HIGHLY MANUAL TASK
WHICH WE HAVE NOW ARE
SIGNIFICANTLY AUTOMATED IMPASSE.
THAT MANUAL WORK RESULTED IN A
LOT OF REWORKED BECAUSE THERE
WAS A LOT OF ERRORS IN IT.
SO THERE IS THE REDUCTION OF
REWORK EXPENSE.
BUT I THINK BY WAY OF
ILLUSTRATION IF I MIGHT I'D LIKE
TO SHARE WITH YOU. OF THE
STRATEGY THAT'S IN PLAY AT THE
RIVERSIDE CAMPUS.
AS YOU'VE IDENTIFIED IN HEARING
TODAY.
THEY ARE GROWING THEIR SCHOOL
OF MEDICINE ALONG WITH OTHER
COMPONENTS OF THEIR ACADEMIC
PROGRAMS.
CHANCER WILCOX HAS IDENTIFIED A
RATHER AGGRESSIVE GROWTH POSTURE
FOR THAT CAMPUS WANTING TO GROW
ELEVEN PERCENT IN THEIR ACADEMIC
PROGRAMS OVER THE NEXT FIVE
YEARS.
UP WITH THE RESTRICTION THAT
THEY GROW THEIR ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS BY ONLY ONE PERCENT OVER
THAT SAME PERIOD.
UC PATH IS A CORNERSTONE OF THAT
STRATEGY TO LIMIT ADMINISTRATIVE
COST GROWTH.
AS THEY GROW THEIR ACADEMIC
PROGRAMS.
SO IT'S NOT SEEN AS A. COST
REDUCTIONS SO MUCH AS IT IS A
LIMITER.
ON THE GROWTH OF ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS FOR THE CAMPUSES.
WE WILL BE PROVIDING THIS CORE
SET OF SERVICES IN A DEFINED
WAY.
WE'RE REDUCING VARIABILITY IN
THOUGH SERVICES WERE BRINGING
EFFICIENCY THROUGH SCALE.
THAT DOESN'T NECESSARILY REDUCE
OVERALL COSTS BUT IT CERTAINLY
ALLOWS US UP TO PUT CAPS ON ANY
GROWTH IN THOSE THOSE EXPENSES.
AND AS WE FINISH THIS
DEPLOYMENT.
WE NOW HAVE A BASE WHERE WE HAVE
ALL CAMPUS IS USING A STANDARD
SET OF BUSINESS PRACTICES.
THAT BOB FROM MY PERSPECTIVE OUR
THE PREREQUISITE DEFINING
EFFICIENCIES.
YOU CAN GET TO EFFICIENCIES IF
YOU DON'T STANDARDIZE AND WHAT
WE WILL HAVE DONE INITIALLY WITH
PATH.
IS TO STANDARDIZE THE WAY WE
PROVIDE THE SERVICES WITH THE
EXPECTATION AND.
THAT THE CAMPUSES ARE GOING TO
BE.
PUTTING SIGNIFICANT PRESSURE ON
US TO MAKE SURE WE'RE DOING IT
AT THE LOWEST UNIT COST AND
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE PREPARING FOR
ONCE WE GET THROUGH THE PROJECT.
SO IT'S BEEN ROUGH TO GET THERE.
BUT WE'VE BUILT A GREAT
FOUNDATION AND I WOULD OBSERVE
THAT WITH THIS FOUNDATION WE CAN
ALSO THEN LEVERAGE THAT INITIAL
INVESTMENT.
TO TAKE ON OTHER ADDITIONAL
SERVICES.
SUCH AS.
ABOUT TODAY EACH CAMPUS.
HANDLES TRAVEL REIMBURSEMENT.
THEIR OWN WAY. IN TYPICALLY
THROUGH ACCOUNTS PAYABLE.
WELL IF WE'VE GOT THE PATH
CENTER AND WE NOW HAVE A PAYROLL
OPERATION IN PLACE TODAY.
WE COULD SIMPLY MOVE THAT
SERVICE TO THE PATH CENTER.
AND PROVIDE TRAVEL REIMBURSEMENT
AS A NON TAXABLE INCOME
COMPONENT FOR THEIR PAYCHECK.
IT REDUCES OVERHEAD AT THE
CAMPUS IN AT LEVERAGES THE
INVESTMENT WE'VE MADE IT THE
PATH CENTER.
SO THERE ARE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
FUTURE SHARED SERVICES THROUGH
THE PATH CENTER.
BUT WE HAVE TO EXECUTE FINISH
EXECUTING ON THE PROJECT
COMPONENT OF THIS.
SO WE CAN BEGIN TO IND THOSE
EFFICIENCIES IN THOSE POINTS
SCALE.
AND I HOPE THAT ANSWERS YOUR
QUESTION.
IT DOESN'T I AND I WOULD SAY
THAT I APPRECIATE THE
EFFICIENCY.
ARE I'M A LITTLE BIT TAKEN BACK
BY THE AMOUNT OF TIME THAT IS
TAKEN TO GET THERE.
AND NUMBER MEDINA I APOLOGIZE I
I DO HAVE A THERE IS A RECENT
AUDIT OF YOU SEE PATH AND IT
DOES PROVIDE THE DATA THAT YOU
ASKED FOR YOU LAST FOR. HOURS
THE COST ESTIMATE CHANGED OVER
TIME
AND ON THE DO OF IT PRETTY
HELPFUL DISPLAY IN THIS AUDIT.
THAT'D BE HAPPY TO SHARE OF
YOUR STAFF TO AFTERWARDS BUT ON
IT IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN WHEN
THAT WAS PRESENTED TO THE
REGENTS ACCORDING TO THE
AUDITOR.
A YOU SEE HAD ESTIMATED THE COST
OF JUST A JUST OVER THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS.
FOR THE FOR THE TOTAL FOR
PROJECT COSTS.
I'M IN THE ESTIMATED SAVINGS OF
ABOUT.
A SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS MOST OF THE SAVINGS
WOULD BE SORT OF STAFFING
REDUCTIONS.
I'M IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
ACCORDING TO THE AUDITOR'S
RECENT ESTIMATES THE COST HAD.
ABOUT TRIPLED SO IS JUST OVER
NINE HUNDRED FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR YOU SEE PATH.
AND THERE WERE NO ESTIMATED
SAVINGS AS A RESULT OF THAT
ACCORDING TO THE AUDITOR.
AND SO THESE WERE THE FINDINGS
OF THE OF THE RECENT STATE
AUDIT.
THANK YOU.
OKAY MISTER CHAVEZ.
VERY INTERESTED IN THIS.
WHEN I USED TO DO MY OTHER LIFE.
IS THIS A COMPONENT OF THE
ACTIVITY BASED COSTING THAT
WE'VE BEEN ASKING YOU GUYS TO DO
FOR YEARS.
NO SIR. TO MY KNOWLEDGE NO BUT
THE.
YOU SEE REPRESENTATIVE WHO OF
SPOKE TO THAT EARLIER IDENTIFIED
ONE OF THE CHALLENGES YOU SEE
FACES.
IN HAVING DISPARATE INFORMATION
SYSTEMS.
WHAT WE GET OUT OF THIS?
BY HAVING ALL YOU SEE PATH OF
ALL YOU SEE EMPLOYEES IN A
COMMON PAYROLL AND HR SYSTEM.
IS VISIBILITY ACROSS ALL
LOCATIONS AS TO THOSE COSTS.
WHEREAS TODAY. IT'S ELEVEN
SEPARATE SYSTEMS AND WE HAVE TO
DO A LOT OF INTERPRETIVE
GYMNASTICS GET THAT DATA. TO
LOOK IN AN ACT COMMON ACROSS ALL
OF CEMEX U. DIFFERENT QUESTIONS
HER.
SHOULD IT BE.
OPPONENTS OF THE ACTIVITY BASED
COSTING.
SHE'S GOING THROUGH
I BELIEVE YOU SEE PATH WILL
PROVIDE CORE DATA THAT'S
CRITICAL FOR ACTIVITY BASED
COSTING YES.
YOU KNOW WHAT ACTIVITY BASED
COST YES SIR.
SO EVERYTHING IS SAYING IT'LL
SLIDE HERE NUMBER TWOS. THAT I
CONSISTENT BUSINESS PRACTICE DAD
ACCURACY IMPROVE REGULAR CLIENTS
IS ALL PART OF AN ACTIVITY BASED
COSTING MODEL.
IT'S CORRECT AND ULTIMATELY. OUR
THAT MODEL THOUGHT WOULD THEN
HAVE OTHER INPUTS.
OF FROM SPACE PLANNING FROM
ACADEMIC A PROGRAM MODELING. IT
WOULD HAVE THE OTHER COMPONENTS
NECESSARY TO GET TO THE THE DATA
THAT I THINK YOU'RE LOOKING FOR
BUT HAVING THAT COR. ALL
EMPLOYEE AND COST COMPONENT OF
OFFER YOU SEE EMPLOYEES IS IS A
CRITICAL COMPONENT OF THAT YES.
SO YOU WERE YOU HAD MADE A
COMMENT IS AT THAT LEVEL
DIFFERENT SYSTEMS.
THAT TICKET TIME BECOME
INDIFFERENT ROUTE YOUR FUTURE
STATE OF BUSINESS PROCESSES.
THAT YOU IDENTIFIED HUNDRED FIVE
BUSINESSES PROCESSES HE HAD TO.
WORK TO GET HERE.
WITH THE OLD SYSTEM THE PPS.
AND YOU HAVE CHANGED YOUR
DYNAMICS OF.
MENTOR STRAIGHT HAVE GROWTH TO
THE MEDICAL I THINK YOU SAID
THEY'RE GOING TO GO UP ELEVEN
PERCENT. OVER THE I GAVE THE
EXAMPLE OF RIVERSIDE AND SAN
YOUNG YOU WERE GOING ON A CRUISE
MINISTRATION COST BY ONE PERCENT
PERCENT THAT'S THERE BUT THE
SAVINGS.
THAT'S ACTUALLY A DEFINITION OF
THE ACTIVITY THAT YOU'D BE
DOING.
AND IN THAT CONNECTOR TO BASE
MODEL.
IS SO YOU YOU WOULD BE LOOKING
AT OTHER.
THINGS THAT THE UC DOES.
TO REDEFINE THEIR BUSINESS
PRACTICES THAT YOU'VE JUST LAID
OUT HERE.
TO FIND SAVINGS AND I DO HOPE
ALL INTENT WE DOING THIS WAS TO
PUT.
MORE MONEY IN THE EDUCATION OF
THE CHILD OTHER STUDENTS AND
LESS MONEY AND.
ACTIVITIES.
THAT'S WHY WE WANTED YOU AS YOU
DO IN THE FIRST PLACE.
SO.
I'M SOMEWHAT CONCERNED.
AS A MEMBER WHO'S BEEN A FOR SIX
YEARS THEN YOU JUST. BRIEF AN
ENTIRE
PROJECT DISCUSS KNOWS.
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
AND YOU DID A LINE THE TWO
TOGETHER SO THAT MAKES ME THINK.
THAT SOMEBODY IT UC'S JUST
SMILING AT ME. AND NOT REALLY.
TAKING SOMETHIN THAT COULD HELP
THEM.
TO DO WHAT THEY SHOULD BE DOING.
AM I THINK I'M WRONG.
CHAVEZ I BELIEVE THE THE YOU SEE
IS.
LIKE ALL LARGE INSTITUTIONS NOT
ALL COMPONENTS SPEAK EQUALLY
WELL WITH EACH OTHER. I HAVE
HEARD AND HAVE FOLLOWED THE
ACTIVITY BASED COSTING.
PILOT WORK THAT'S BEEN DONE IN
A COUPLE OF CAMPUSES.
I WOULD ALSO OBSERVE THAT YOU
SEE HAS AN OPPORTUNITY TO THINK
STRATEGICALLY ABOUT ITS DATA.
AND HISTORICALLY YOU SEE DATA
HAS BEEN LOOKED AT. A IN A
COUPLE OF DIFFERENT WAYS THERE
IS STOVE PIPED.
VERY MUCH SO I KNOW THAT OKAY.
I ARE IT WAS ALREADY THERE I I
WON'T BELABOR THE OBVIOUS SO
THE.
.
SO IF YOU COULD TAKE THIS BACK
AT THE LONGER BE GONTIER TO
ABOUT ME.
AND THE NEXT TIME
ABILITY KNOWN ACTIVITY BASED
COSTING AS
BUT THE IF
IF YOU CARED AT THE UC SYSTEM IN
THE PAST. AND YOU CAN ONLY DO
THIS OF IT COMES FROM THE
REGION'S ALL THE WAY DOWN.
THAT THEY SAY WE ARE GOING TO.
EMBRACE SOMETHING THAT WE TEACH
AT OUR BUSINESS SCHOOLS
AT THE UC SYSTEM.
SO THIS IS A ROCKY CHAVEZ SAYING
THAT YOU GET YOUR BUSINESS
MODELS ARE BEING TAUGHT YEARS
YOUR SCHOOLS WHEN YOU GIVE
SOMEBODY AN MBA.
UNDER THE UC SYSTEM THEY'RE
GOING TO KNOW EXACTLY WHAT AN
ACTIVITY BASED COSTING MODEL IS.
SO YOU TEACH IT.
BUT WE DO NOT WANT TO PRACTICE
IT.
IN OUR EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS
THOUGH YOU CAN JUST GO WILL OUT
ACTED BASED CASA EDUCATIONS
DELUSIONS AND THEY'LL GIVE YOU A
SERIES OF UNIVERSITY SYSTEMS
THAT DO THAT.
SO.
.
BUT IT ONLY WORKS
YOU CAN READ THOSE TWO.
IF AT THE HIGHEST LEVEL.
EMBRACED AS A VISION FOR THE TOP
DOWN SO YOU DON'T HAVE STILL
PIPES.
BECAUSE ALL STOVE PIPES ARE
INHERENTLY INEFFICIENT.
AND YOU NEED TO BREAK THEM DOWN
SO THAT YOU HAVE AS YOU SAID
CORRECTLY HER EARLIER. HOW DO
YOU SHARE?
FIRST I YOU HAD TO COMMON TERMS
AND HOW DO YOU SHARE THE DATA
FROM THIS COME TO TERMS.
TO FIND THE.
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SAVE MONEY
WHICH WERE TRYING TO DO IN THIS
COMMITTEE.
SO. IF YOU CARRY THAT MESSAGE
BACK LIKE I SAID I'LL BE GONE.
BUT THAT'S WHERE YOU NEED TO BE
GOING FOR THIS AND I THINK OKAY.
THANK YOU GUYS SING NO MORE
COMMENTS ON THAT.
PARENTS OF THE PATH.
SYSTEM I I JUST WANT TO ASK ONE.
LOGISTICS MAYBE THIS COULD BE
FOR YOU OR SAY HARRIS OR KAREN.
IT'S MORE ON ON THE. THAT THE
FINANCING OF IT SO AS A STAFF
NOTED. THAT THIS IS ALL. PAID
FOR IT WITH THE. GENERAL FUND
FOR THE THERE ARE YOU SEE.
A POOR FUND AND. THERE ARE.
MEDICAL PROGRAMS OF COURSE PART
OF THIS SO.
WOULD BE AN OPPORTUNITY TO TO
SPLIT THAT.
AND HAVE IT THOSE PROGRAMS PAY
FOR IT AND ONLY HAVE THE.
.
HAVE THE NON GENERAL FUND
PROGRAMS.
PAY FOR THEIR FARE SHARE TENSELY
FREEING UP MONEY WE COULD USE
FOR.
ENROLLMENT GROWTH.
THE OTHER TOPIC WE ALWAYS GO.
SO IN IN THE REQUEST THAT WE GOT
FOR WE HAVE SUBMITTED A BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL SPECIFICALLY FOR
YOU SEE PATH THAT WOULD RETURN.
THE EXISTING ALLOCATION OF
GENERAL FUNDS THAT WE RECEIVED
THIS YEAR BACK TO THE CAMPUSES
WITH THE APPROPRIATE BASE.
ADJUSTMENT.
OUR AND ALLOW US TO RETURN TO
THIS FEE FOR SERVICE MODEL THAT
WE IDENTIFIED. THAT.
PLACES THE DECISION ON THE
FUNDS SOURCE TO PAY FOR PATH AT
THE CAMPUS LEVEL.
SO FOR EXAMPLE.
I GET THAT BUT WHAT ABOUT THE
MEDICAL CENTERS SO ARE.
CAMPUSES ARE OR OF.
VERY GUARDEDAND JEALOUS OF
THEIR GENERAL FUNDS AND THE
EXPENDITURE OF THOSE FUNDS TO
THE HIGHEST VALUE SO YOU KNOW
YOU'RE SAYING YOU'RE YOU'RE RTF.
TAKE IN THE CONSIDERATION AND
YOU WILL ENSURE THAT.
YOU ONLY USE AS.
AS IT NEEDED AMOUNT OF GENERAL
FUND.
THAT THAT IS CORRECT AND WE
COULD ALSO SHOW YOU THE PREVIOUS
YEAR'S.
FUND SOURCE DISTRIBUTION FOR
PAYMENT IF YOU SEE PATH BECAUSE
WE HAD BEEN ON A FEE FOR SERVICE
MODEL. BEFORE THE CURRENT FISCAL
YEAR.
SO WE WE CAN DEMONSTRATE HOW
THOSE FUNDS CAME TO THE OFFICE
OF THE PRESIDENT TO PAY FOR YOU
SEE PATH BUT NUMBER MCCARTY ONE.
PAGE YOU MIGHT FIND INTERESTING
IT'S ACTUALLY IN THE.
POWER POINT THAT YOU JUST
RECEIVED ON PAGE SIX
ON THE UC PATH POWER POINT THAT
THE THIRD OR FOURTH YOU SEE
POWER WHEN I GOT HER HEAD WAS
THE LAST WHEN YOU RECEIVED A
NOTICE OF LIKELY ON YOU SEE
PATH.
THERE'S A THERE'S A PIE CHART
THERE YES AND MY UNDERSTANDING
IS THAT IS WHAT YOU SEE.
SAYS IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN WHERE
THE SH THOUGH THE STATE AND NON
STATE SHARE OF YOU SEE PATH
COSTS FOOD THAT'S ABOUT FORTY
TWO PERCENT COR FIFTY EIGHT
PERCENT NON CORE. SOMEONE OPTION
YOU COULD CONSIDER IS LOOK IS
LOOK AT SORT OF THOSE COST
INCREASES AND ADJUST THAT DOWN.
YOU KNOW FORTY TWO PERCENT OR
SOME SORT OF COST SHARING RATIO
LIKE THAT HOW THE REMAINING COST
INCREASE SHARED BY CERTAIN THE
NON CORE PORTION OF YOU SEE THAT
WOULD AGREE THAT. YOU SEE
GENERAL FUND MONEY WE CAN FOCUS
ON THE PRIORITIES CORRECT SURE
IT YEAH IT'S A LITTLE BIT.
IT'S A LITTLE BIT COMPLICATED
TO THINK ABOUT BECAUSE YOU'RE
SORT OF THERE'S A LITTLE BIT OF
FUN SWAPPING THEIR.
ONE OPTION IS A SORT OF A JUST
DOWN THE BASE LEVEL IF YOU JUST
ON THAT SORT OF FIFTY TWO
MILLION DOLLAR BASE YOU MIGHT.
YOU KNOW REDIRECTS THOUGH THOSE
FUNDS BACK TO THE.
THE CAMPUS IS BUT IF YOU WORD IT
SORT OF SHARE THAT FIFTEEN
MILLION DOT IF YOU'RE LOOKING AT
SORT OF A FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLAR
INCREASE.
AND THAT'S SERVING THAT A
SAVINGS YES THAT'S ABOUT FORTY
TWO PERCENT OF THAT THAT WOULD
BE NEW GENERAL FUND AND THEIR
MEANING OF THAT YOU COULD YOU
COULD CONCEIVE OF ITS OTHER
FUNDS THAT YOU CAN. PRIORITIZE
FOR OTHER THINGS LIKE
ENROLLMENT.
OKAY THANK YOU.
SINGER FURTHER QUESTIONS WE
WILL.
HOLD THIS ISSUE OPEN.
ISSUE NUMBER SIX.
I GUESS I'LL JUST I'LL JUST ASK
YOU A SIMPLE QUESTION SAY I.
MEAN YOU CAN JUST WE WILL GET
THROUGH THIS SO IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN WE WEEKLY I'M.
TOOK AN ACTION TO PUT ONE TIME
MONEY THE GENERAL FUND TO
SUPPORT THIS EFFORT TO. HELP LCF
BUT LCF THAT PLUS STUDENTS.
GET INTO THE UC ESSENTIALLY.
WHO THEIR REPORT BACK IN OUR
ANALYSIS FROM ALEJO SAID WE HAD
LIMITED?
LIMITED RESULTS IN SO I GUESS
THAT THE QUESTION YOU CAN ANSWER
IS.
WHAT COULD WE DO IF ANYTHING IF
WE WANTED TO?
TO TO ACHIEVE THE GOAL THAT WE.
SOUGHT OUT AND TWENTY SIXTEEN TO
ENROLL MORE.
LCF AT PLUS STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS IN THE UC.
THINK YOUR TERM MCCARTY AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
.
WITH THE ENROLLMENT COMPONENT
THERE WAS A LITTLE BIT OF A
TIMING ISSUE WITH HOW UC ADMITS
WHEN WE RECEIVED THE FUNDS AND
WHEN THEY WERE SENT TO CAMPUSES.
AND WHEN STUDENTS ARE ACTUALLY
ADMITTED SO WE ASK THE ALL OF
THE CAMPUSES TO WRITE PROPOSALS
FOR HOW THEY WOULD SPEND THE
FUNDS THAT THEY RECEIVED. THEY
WERE GOING TO RECEIVE BETWEEN
TWENTY AND FORTY PERCENT OF THE
TWENTY MILLION WOULD BE SPREAD
FOR BETWEEN THE CAMPUSES FOR
ENROLLING NEW STUDENTS FROM LC
FF PLUS HIGH SCHOOLS.
THEY DIDN'T GET THOSE FUNDS
UNTIL JANUARY TWENTY SEVENTEEN
WHEN THE.
APPLICATIONS FOR FALL HAD
ALREADY CLOSED.
SO THAT'S WHY FOR FALL TWENTY
EIGHTEEN YOU DIDN'T REALLY SEE
THE IMPACT OF THOSE FUNDS ON THE
RECRUITMENT OF HEALTH CFF
STUDENTS.
.
THE RECRUITMENT OF STUDENTS
CONTINUED ALL THROUGH THE SPRING
AND THE FOLLOWING FALL AND WE
ANTICIPATE SEEING IMPACT.
FOR FOOTBALL TWENTY. ODD YEAH
FOOTBALL TWENTY EIGHTEEN SORRY
IS FOR BALL TWENTY.
A.
YES BUT THIS COMING FALL WE
ANTICIPATE SEEING IMPACT FROM UP
THE USE OF THESE FUNDS I GUESS
RIGHT NOW STAFF OF STUDENTS.
DID IT WORK.
SO THERE WERE SOME YOUNG GRABS
YES SIR ON THERE WERE SOME
PROGRAMS THAT WERE HIGHLY
EFFECTIVE SORT CAMPUSES.
CAME UP WITH THEIR PLANS FOR
SERVE THEIR STUDENTS IN
DIFFERENT WAYS.
THE DIFFERENT CAMPUSES.
BOB LOOKED TO THINGS THAT THEY
THOUGHT COULD REALLY ASSIST
THEIR STUDENTS OFF FOR EXAMPLE
UC DAVIS HIRED AN ACADEMIC
ADVISER.
WHOSE JOB WAS RATHER THAN THE
PASSIVELY WAIT FOR STUDENTS TO
MAKE IT APPOINTMENT.
ACTIVELY MADE APPOINTMENTS WITH
STUDENTS FROM LCF OF HIGH
SCHOOLS WHO AFTER THEIR FRESHMAN
YEAR WERE ON ACADEMIC PROBATION.
AND MET WITH THOSE STUDENTS
DISCUSSED THEIR INDIVIDUAL
CONCERNS WITH THEM AND DIRECTED
THOSE STUDENTS TO CAMPUS
RESOURCES THAT WOULD HELP THE
STUDENT.
AND WHAT WE FOUND IS THAT OF
THE POPULATION THAT THIS
ACADEMIC ADVISER MET WITH
THERE'S A TWENTY EIGHT PERCENT
REDUCTION IN DROPOUT COMPARED TO
OTHER STUDENTS WHO WERE ON
ACADEMIC PROBATION FROM LCF OF
HIGH SCHOOLS. SO CLEARLY THERE
WAS SOME IMPACT THEIR THAT
STUDENT CONTINUATION WAS
INCREASE.
I UCLA USED SOME OF THE FOR
FUNDING FOR LOOKED A LEARNING
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM WHICH IS A
SERVER APPEARED TO PEER
MENTORING PROGRAM.%
DRUG PROGRAMS INCREASED FROM
SEVEN HUNDRED STUDENTS TO THREE
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED STUDENTS
QUARTERLY A PARTICIPATION. AND
WHAT WE FOUND.
IS STUCK PERSISTENCE RATES AND
THAT PROGRAM WENT UP BY THREE
PERCENT OR THE FOR THE STUDENTS
AS A WHOLE WHO PARTICIPATED
VERSUS. OUR STUDENTS FROM LCF OF
PARTICIPATE IN THAT PROGRAM. SO
WHAT WE'RE FINDING IS THAT SORT
OF FACE TO FACE CONTACT
INDIVIDUAL ATTENTION FOR THE
STUDENTS.
ARE REALLY POSITIONS WHETHER
PURE MENTORS OR US. WHO ASSISTED
STUDENT IN FIGURING OUT HOW THE
NAVIGATE? THE UNIVERSITY THAT
THEY HAVE BEEN ROLLED IN SEEM TO
BE REALLY HELPING AND
PERSISTENCE RATES.
OTHER. A ACTIONS TAKEN BY
CAMPUS UC MERCED WHICH OUGHT IS
SOMEWHAT REMOTELY LOCATED. IS
DEVELOPING AN ONLINE ORIENTATION
FOR NEW STUDENTS WHO CAN'T
TRAVEL THERE BEFORE SCHOOL
STARTS. AND ATTEND AN IN PERSON
ORIENTATION SO THAT THEY CAN
TAKE THE ORIENTATION ONLINE FIND
OUT WHERE ON CAMPUS DIFFERENT
SERVICES ARE LOCATED AND IF THE
STUDENT HAS A QUESTION WHERE TO
GO TO RECEIVE THOSE QUESTIONS
ANSWERED.
SO.
WE DO BELIEVE THAT THESE FUNDS
HAVE HAD AN IMPACT WE'RE STILL
STUDYING IT BUT. DEFINITELY IT
APPEARS THAT INCREASING ACADEMIC
ADVISING AND ALSO FOR CERTAIN OF
EXPRESSWAY STEM FIELD MAJORS.
INCREASING EARLY ON PEER TO PEER
ADVISING IT WITHIN THOSE MAJORS.
APPEAR TO BE OUR TUTORING.
APPEARS TO HAVE AN IMPACT IN THE
PERSISTENT RATES
THE STUDENTS.
OKAY THANK YOU.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
SEEING NONE THANK YOU FOR THEIR
REPORTS.
WE'LL NOW GO TO PUBLIC COMMENTS.
PLEASE LINE UP. IN THE.
.
CENTER THERE.
PLEASE.
KEEP YOUR COMMENT TO ONE MINUTE
OR LESS PLEASE
SIXTY SECONDS OR LESS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN GREG
EARNER WITH CARBON RECEIVERS ON
BEHALF OF EXPAND IF ADDICTS.
I'M WE'VE BEEN WATCHING WHAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS BEEN
DOING IN RELATION TO THE OPIOID
CRISIS. THEY'VE WRITTEN RECENTLY
ALLOCATED A HALF
A BILLION DOLLARS AN EXPANDED.
WHAT THAT MONEY CAN BE USED FOR
INCLUDING RESEARCH AND TO NON
OPIOID PAIN RELIEVERS AND PAIN
MANAGEMENT?
UC DAVIS IS IN A PARTICULARLY
GREAT POSITION WITH SOME A SMALL
STATE INVESTMENT TO PULL DOWN A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF THIS
MONEY.
UC DAVIS
HAS THE CENTER FOR ADVANCING
PAIN RELIEF AN EGG AND A
PARTNERSHIP WITH VETERINARY
MEDICAL SCHOOL.
THAT IS LOOKING AT BOTH OF THESE
AREAS.
WE WOULD LIKE THOSE SUBCOMMITTEE
TO CONSIDER
A SMALL STATE INVESTMENT AND PUT
THE UC SYSTEM. IN A POSITION TO
LOOK TOWARDS THE FUTURE OF
BEYOND OPIOIDS AND LOOKING AT
WHAT WE CAN DO IN THIS AREA.
A PROVIDE THE COMMITTEE WITH
MORE INFORMATION REGARDING THIS
BUT WE LOOK FORWARD YOUR
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
BARELY AFFORDING BASIC NEEDS AND
HOUSING COSTS PACKED BY THE
HUNDREDS IN LECTURE HALLS WITH
NO VENTILATION AND SITTING ON
THE FLOOR OF SOME OF MY
DISCUSSION SECTIONS.
I'D BE LYING IF I TOLD YOU THAT
I DIDN'T OUT MY DECISION FOR
COMMITTING TO UC BERKELEY.
THESE EXPERIENCES WERE NOT RARE
IN MY FIRST SEMESTER AT POWELL
AND ARE CERTAINLY NOT UNIQUE TO
ME. MY NAME IS ALICE SMITH AND
I'M A FIRST YEAR UNDERGRADUATE
STUDENTS.
AND ALMOST SCHOOL SPIRIT AND
PRIDE SOMETIMES I FEEL LIKE I
CARE MORE ABOUT MY SCHOOL THAN
HE CARES FOR ME.
I'M THANKFUL FOR THE MENTAL
HEALTH RESOURCES AT THE STUDENT
HEALTH CENTER BUT WHEN I TRIED
TO SCHEDULE AN APPOINTMENT AT
THE BEGINNING OF THE SEMESTER.
THE SOONEST SOMEONE COULD SEE ME
WOULD BE IN A FEW WEEKS.
WHEN I TRY TO SCHEDULE AN
APPOINTMENT CLOSE TO FINALS IN
THE HEIGHT OF MY ANXIETY THE
SOONEST SOMEONE COULD SEE ME
WOULD BE NEXT SEMESTER.
MENTAL HEALTH RESOURCES ACADEMIC
RESOURCES BASIC NEED SECURITY I
COULD GIVE YOU DIATRIBE AFTER
DIATRIBE GRANT AFTER RANTS ABOUT
THE RESOURCES STUDENTS NEED AND
THE OBSTACLES WE FACE.
I AM PROUD TO BE A UC STUDENT
AND TO SEE SO MANY STATE
LEGISLATORS TO BE YOU SEE ALUMNI
BUT IT'S CLEAR THAT OUR
EXPERIENCES. ARE DIFFERENT FROM
YOURS
AS OUR REPRESENTATIVES I HOPE
YOU CONSIDER YOU SEE STUDENTS
CONSIDER YOUR UC EXPERIENCE
CONSIDER OUR CHALLENGES WHEN YOU
DECIDE WHETHER TO SUPPORT AN
INCREASE IN HIGHER EDUCATION
FUNDING.
GIVE.
US STEAMED AT CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS AMY
HINDSIGHT I'M A MOM AND THE
HIGHER EDUCATION DIRECTOR OF THE
RE CLEAN CA HIGHER EDUCATION
COALITION. AT PRESENT THE UC
RETIREMENT SYSTEM. IS BEING
ERODED BY A WRONG HEADED
APPROACH TO ADDRESSING FUNDING
CONCERNS NAMELY ALLOWING A FOUR
OH ONE K. OPT OUT FROM THE
DEFINED BENEFIT PENSION WHICH
WILL ULTIMATELY LEAVE IT LIKE
ACTUAR EARLY ON SOUND. AS YOU
SEE IS THE LARGEST EMPLOYER IN
CALIFORNIA IT WOULD STAND TO
REASON THAT THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ECONOMY MAY BE INTERESTED IN
MAKING SURE THAT ITS RETIREES
ARE ABLE TO RETIRE WITH DIGNITY.
WE URGE THE STATE TO FUND THE
STATE PORTION OF YOU SEE OUR S.
SO THAT ATTACKS ON THE PENSION
WILL BE WALKED BACK. AND THE
THREE UNIONS HER CURRENTLY IN
BARGAINING OVER THIS ISSUE ASKED
ME LOCAL THIRTY TWO NINETY NINE
CNA AND UP THE CW A LOCAL NINETY
ONE NINETEEN. CAN REST ASSURED
RIGHT NOW ALL THREE UNIONS ARE
CURRENTLY COLLECTING STRIKE
AUTHORIZATION PLEDGES AND ARE
HOLDING STRIKE VOTES IN THE
COMING WEEKS.
WE CONTINUE TO STAUNCHLY OPPOSED
TO TWO POINT FIVE PERCENT
TUITION AND FIVE PERCENT FEE
INCREASE THE UC REGENTS ARE
SCHEDULED TO LEVY AGAINST
STUDENTS TO MAKE UP FOR THE LOT
JOB THE STATE IS REFUSING TO
DEAL.
IMPOSING MODEST TUITION
INCREASES OVER A PERIOD OF
SEVERAL YEARS CONTINUES TO ADD
FINANCIAL BY ADDITIONAL
FINANCIAL BURDEN ON STUDENTS AND
THEIR FAMILIES. THE HYPHAE HIGH
AID MODEL HAS FAILED AS IS
EVIDENCED BY THE STUDENT DEBT
CRISIS WE DEMAND STUDENT DEBT
RELIEF AND A REPUDIATION OF THE
HI FI HIGH EIGHT MODEL IN FAVOR
OF ACTUAL. PUBLIC INVESTMENT IN
OUR HIGH PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHEN MCCARTYOTHER
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND MY
NAME IS LINDSAY HENDRIX AND I A
MENU TRANSFERRED TO UCLA FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ME COLLEGE.
ATTORNEYS HERE A WAS ONE OF MY
BIGGEST DREAMS AND WHEN I SEE
RECEIVED MY ACCEPTANCE LETTER
ALMOST EXACTLY A YEAR AGO TODAY
I CANNOT EVEN DESCRIBE. THE JOY
AND EXCITEMENT I FELT.
HOWEVER STUDIES HILL A HAS BEEN
FILLED WITH ONE OF THE MOST
INCREDIBLE EXPERIENCE OF MY LIFE
BUT. IT IS ALSO HAD MANY EXPECTS
BACK TO CHALLENGES.
CHALLENGES LIKE HAVING TO SIT ON
THE FLOOR STAND DURING LECTURE
MISS OUT ON NEW MATERIAL BECAUSE
OF OVERSTRETCHED YEAS AND HAVING
TO DROP MY SECOND MAJOR BECAUSE
OF WILD THE IMPACT OF CLASSES.
THIS ALL NEGLECT TO MENTION THE
VERY REAL POSSIBILITY THAT I
WILL SOON HAVE TO PAY MUCH MORE
FOR THE SAME EXPERIENCE.
THE UC SYSTEM IS SOMETHING THAT
I AND SO MANY OTHER TRANSFERS
BOTH FROM COMMUNITY COLLEGES AS
WELL AS OTHER HIGHER EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS HAVE HISTORICALLY
STROVE TO BE A PART OF.
WITHOUT MAJOR CHANGES IN
INCREASES TO YOU SEE STATE
FUNDING I DO NOT THINK THAT THIS
WILL REMAIN TRUE AND MANY
TRANSFER STUDENTS WILL PROBABLY
LOOK ELSEWHERE TO CONTINUE THEIR
EDUCATION.
THANK YOU TO THE MEMBERS THAT
HAVE ALREADY SHOWN THEIR SUPPORT
POLICE THE BUDGET PASSED
PARTICULARLY AND NUMBER MCCARTY
FOR GIVING CONSIDERATION TO
OTHER.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS AMANDA
ELLIOTT NAM A CURRENT FRESHMAN
AT UCLA.
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR MY
PARENTS WERE BOTH STUDENTS AT
UCLA WHERE THEY MET.
IS FALL QUARTER MY MOM WAS INNER
WHITE MINISKIRT WHITE COWBOY
BOOTS BECAUSE THIS WAS THE
EIGHTIES HOME MY DAD WAS OUTSIDE
WASHING HIS CAR.
MY MOM WALKED BY HE SAID. A BIT
Y. GONNAMEXICO MOM SAID NO.
BUT THEY GOT DINNER.
AND NOW I'M HERE.
YOU SEE BRINGS PEOPLE TOGETHER.
IT BROUGHT MY PARENTS TOGETHER.
I HAVE TO ANSWER ATTENDED THE
UC.
AND YOU COULD SAY I COME FROM A
PRETTY BIG UCLA FAMILY.
I GOT MY FIRST UCLA SWEATSHIRT
AGE TEN WATCHED UCLA FOOTBALL
GAMES ALL THROUGHOUT MY
CHILDHOOD ON TV.
UCLA FOR ME WASN'T JUST WHERE MY
FAMILY BEGAN.
FOR ME IT'S ALSO BECOME A
FAMILY.
FOR SO MANY OTHER PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE ON
CALIFORNIA.
THE UC SYSTEM IS A FAMILY.
WHENEVER I SEE THAT UCLA LICENSE
PLATE ARE YOU STILL A BASEBALL
CAP.
I KNOW THAT THAT'S A FRIENDLY
FACE.
THE UC FAMILY HAS GROWN A LOT
OVER THESE PAST FEW DECADES
WHICH IS A GREAT THING.
IT MEANS MORE OPPORTUNITY MORE
ACCESS TO HIGHER EDUCATION FOR
MORE CALIFORNIA STUDENTS.
IT MEANS MORE EDUCATED WORKERS
FOR CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY.
HOWEVER.
WE HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO EXPAND
ACCESS AND CAPACITY FOR AS MANY
STUDENTS AS WE BEGAN TO ARE ALL.
MY PARENTS ARE ALWAYS SURPRISED
TO SEE HOW MANY NEW DORMS AND
DINING HALLS ARE BUILT ON UCLA'S
CAMPUS BUT IT STILL ISN'T
ENOUGH.
FOR ONE MY FINALS LAST QUARTER I
SAT ON THE FLOOR FOR TWO HOURS
WHILE I TOOK MY FINAL BECAUSE
THERE JUST WASN'T ROOM IN THE
CLASSROOM.
FOR EVERY STUDENT.
I CURRENTLY LIVE IN A DORM WITH
TWO OTHER STUDENTS
IN A DORM THAT WAS INTENDED FOR
TO STUDENTS ALONE.
I GOING TEARS SEMESTERS WITHOUT
MEETING MY TEACHER'S FACE TO
FACE BECAUSE THE LINE TO GET
INTO OFFICE HOURS IS SO LONG
THAT STUDENTS CAN'T EVEN SPEAK
ONE ON ONE WITH THEIR TEACHERS.
NUMBERS LEGISLATURE.
THE UC IS A FAMILY BUT IMPACTS
EVERYONE IN THIS ROOM.
AND SO MANY CALIFORNIANS.
THE UC FAMILY GIVES BACK TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE AND WE ASK YOU
TODAY TO GIVE BACK TO THE UC
FAMILY THANK YOU.
I GIVE DOUBLE TIME BUT THIS
REMIND WERE TRYING TO KEEP.
ONE WINNER LESS THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY MEMBER
IS. ALL JUST BE AN RA FOR THE
FREE HOUSING.
ALL JUST CAMP OUT IN THE TWENTY
FOUR HOUR LIBRARY ON CAMPUS.
ALL THIS HIGH CONTENT IN
PEOPLE'S PARK.
MY NAME IS YOU RYAN I'M A
SOPHOMORE AT UC BERKELEY.
AND I LIVE IN THE LIVING ROOM OF
MY APARTMENT.
I'M NOT ON THE LEASE AND I COULD
BE AFFECTED BY ANY BOOK AT ANY
POINT TIME BY THE LANDLORD.
THE BAY AREA AND YOU SEE HOUSING
CRISIS AFFECTS EVERY ASPECT OF A
STUDENT'S LIFE. FINANCIAL MENTAL
AN ACADEMIC.
PROXIMITY TO CAMPUS FOR STUDENTS
LIVING AWAY FROM HOME AFFECTS
WHETHER STUDENT CAN PHYSICALLY
GET TO CLASS.
THE SKYROCKETING PRICES AFFECT
THE NUMBER OF JOBS THE STUDENT
HAS TO TAKE TO HELP THEIR
PARENTS PAY FOR TUITION RENT
BOOKS.
TRANSPORTATION COSTS FOOD.
THE LIST IS ENDLESS.
ALL THE SEXUAL WEARING AN
ADDITION TO CLUBS AND SPORTS NOT
TO MENTION THE MENTAL CAPACITY
REQUIRED TO PERFORM. TO PAR
ACADEMICALLY IS INCREDIBLY
TAXING.
ULTIMATELY AS A STUDENT. AN
EMPATHIZING WITH THE HOUSING
CRISIS I ASK THAT THE BUDGET
REQUEST GO DIRECTLY TO UC
CAMPUSES TO HELP FUND VARIOUS
PROGRAMS WHICH BENEFIT RESOURCES
THAT CONTRIBUTE. TO STUDENTS
HEALTHY COLLEGE EXPERIENCE THANK
YOU.
HELLO.
MY NAME IS CHRISTIAN I'M A
SECOND YEAR ECONOMY COUNTY MAJOR
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF SADDAM
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SANTA
BARBARA.
WE ARE THE UC SYSTEM HAVE
CREATED SUBSTANTIAL RESULTS
THROUGH RESEARCH REPORT IN.
THEIR WORK CLASS FACULTY IN
QUALITY OF EDUCATION AND THEIR
TO MANY YOU SEE STUDENTS
DESTINED TO CREATE AN INNOVATIVE
FEATURE FOR EVERYONE.
BUT AS A YOU SEE WE HAVE SOME
PROBLEMS THAT NEED TO BE NOTED.
SUCH AS FOOD INSECURITY.
HOMELESSNESS AMONG STUDENTS THE
OVERCROWDED CLASSROOMS AND THE
CONSTANT STRUGGLES THAT STUDENTS
SHOULD A BASE.
IF YOU SEE IS A WORLD CLASS
PUBLIC UNIVERSITY SYSTEM.
WHY ARE WE EXPERIENCING THESE
PROBLEMS?
AS A STUDENT WHO WAS REJECTED
FROM THE SCHOOL THAT I CURRENTLY
GO TO A FIRST GENERATION FROM
ALL THE BLOOD SWEAT AND TEARS I
PUT INTO MY EDUCATION.
IT IS SIMPLY LUDICROUS THAT WE
ALL SEE THE STRUGGLES THERE
REMAIN PROMINENT TO CONSIDER A
MODEST YOU SEE STUDENTS.
ESPECIALLY DOT OF UC SANTA
BARBARA.
WE NEED TO ADDRESS THESE ISSUES
AND IT IS WITHIN EACH OF YOU.
THAT CAN HELP US OUR STUDENTS
WATER BEACH OF THIS WORLD.
HELP OUT FEATURES.
INVEST ENOUGH FEATURES.
HIRE MAME JOHNSON I'M THINKING
IF THE COLD MAGI UCSD.
FIRST OF ALL I COULD THINK OF
ONE HERE WHO DECLARED THE
SUPPORT FOR THE UC BUDGET
REQUEST.
SO WHAT I GOT YOU BY THE HEAD
THEY ASKED ME
TALK ABOUT MY OWN LIFE AND HOW
I'VE BEEN.
HOW I'VE BEEN AFFECTED BY THE
TUITION INCREASE?
BUT I REALLY DON'T HAVE A LOT OF
THE I'M HERE REPRESENTING THE
NINETEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
NINETEEN THOUSAND STUDENTS AT UC
SANTA CRUZ.
WHO HEREBY BY WELL I MEAN BY
THAT BY THE TIME YOU SEE I HAVE?
SO WE WILL ALSO I HAVE THREE
FRIENDS RIGHT NOW THAT I WAS
TALKING TO A COUPLE DAYS AGO ONE
IF MY ROOMMATE. IS A FIFTY YEAR
SUCH A FIFTY ABOUT MAJOR AT UC
SANTA CRUZ.
THE REASON IS FIFTH YES HE
COULDN'T GET THE CLASSES HE NEED
WE RECORDERS AND OF ALL THE HEAT
HAS TAKEN FIFTH YOU.
LUNATICS WE HAVE A MY FRIEND
WHO IS CURRENTLY ACTING CLASS.
I'D SKIP CLASS TODAY IT'S AN
INTRO TO COSMO. FOR LINUX MAC
GALAXIES INSTALLERS.
SO SHE WANTS WE ARE CAN WE HAVE
A CLASS BOOK THAT COST ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY ONE DOLLARS TO
GET THE ACCESS CODE TO DO THE
HOMEWORK AND QUIZZES. BUT SHE
CAN'T AFFORD THE BOOKS AND ONLY
RESULT THAT THOUGH WHEN WE
QUESTION THE PROFESSOR THE
PROFESSOR SAID WHILE YOU HAVE
PUT A FOURTEEN DAY. FREE PERIOD
YOU CAN DO YOUR QUIZZES AND HOME
DO ENOUGH TIME.
AND WELL OF COURSE THAT WOULD
WOULD HOPE STUDENT AT ALL NO
AFFECT THE RATES AT THE END.
AND THEN I HAVE MY OWN A FRIEND
OF MINE WHO SITS ON HOUSING
COMMITTEE WITH ME.
SHE'S A SINGLE MOM. TO KEEP TWO
DAUGHTERS AND WALKS TWO PART
TIME JOBS.
AND WHEN I ASKED HER WHY SHE
SAYS THAT. IN ORDER TO SHOW
EXCELLENCE TO HOOK DAUGHTERS WHO
WANTS TO BE HERE.
SO.
OR.
HI EVERYBODY THANK YOU MY NAME
IS WENDY SEE ONCE I'M A THIRTY
YEAR AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA SANTA CRUZ I WANNA
THANK EVERYBODY.
FOR ALLOWING US TO SPEAK TODAY
AND ESPECIALLY WANT TO THANK THE
STUDENTS WARS SKIPPING CLASS AND
SKIPPING WORK TO BE HERE TODAY
TO EXPLAIN TO YOU WHY YOU NEED
TO FUND THE. UC SYSTEM I WANNA
BEGIN TELLING YOU THAT WHAT I IF
YOU WOULD'VE ASKED ME TODAY IF I
WERE TO COME TO A YOU SEE I
WOULD HAVE SAID NO. FIRST
THOUGHT BECAUSE I HAD A TERRIBLE
EXPERIENCE MY FIRST YEAR I PUT
MY EMISSIONS TO USE YES YOU GOT
REVOKED DUE TO A MISSING A FORM
THAT I WAS NEVER AWARE OR INFORM
TO TURN AND AND THEREFORE. MY
ADMISSIONS GOT TAKEN AWAY
LEAVING ME WITH NO SECOND
OPTIONS FOR MY FUTURE.
MOVING FORWARD TO FINALLY
GETTING MY ADMISSIONS GIVEN BACK
TO ME BECOMING A WINTER ADMIN I
WAS PUSHED INTO I WAS. THROWN
INTO A SMALL DOUBLE AND DUE TO
THAT I FELL OFF MY BUNK BED
BECAUSE THE BUNK BED.
HOME HOWTO LADDER THAT WAS NOT A
TOUCH PROPERLY AND I ENDED UP
BREAKING MY WRIST. SO THAT WAS
MY FIRST EXPERIENCE AS A FIRST
YEAR AND DUE TO THAT I HAD
SKIPPED CLASSES BECAUSE I WAS ON
PAIN MEDICATION I COULDN'T STUDY
BECAUSE I WAS IN SO MUCH PAIN.
AND AT THE SAME TIME MY MY
SCHOOL COULD NOT PROVIDE ME WITH
THE RESEARCHERS I NEEDED BECAUSE
THERE WAS LIMITED FUNDING FOR
THIS ABILITY RESOURCE CENTER TO
PAVEL VAN PICK ME UP WHENEVER
NEEDED. I'M TELLING YOU THE
STORY NOT FREE TO FEEL SORRY FOR
ME I'M TELLING YOU THIS BECAUSE
WE NEED TO FIND THE UC AND WE
NEED TO PROVIDE MORE RESOURCES
FOR STUDENTS ON CAMPUS. TO AVOID
THESE TYPE OF SITUATIONS.
WE ARE ALWAYS WERE ALWAYS
HUNTING ROSE TELLING FUTURE
STUDENTS THAT THE UC SYSTEM IS
THE BEST PUBLIC EDUCATION BUT IF
WE HAVE TO BE IF WE WANT TO BE
THE BEST WE HAVE TO PROVIDE THE
BEST. AND WE CURRENTLY NOT DOING
THAT SO THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MAX
LUBIN I'M A MASTER'S STUDENT AT
YOU.
UC BERKELEY I ALSO LEAD RISE
CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE AN
INDEPENDENT NONPROFIT ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION REPRESENTING MORE
THAN TEN THOUSAND COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SERIOUS YOU AND YOU SEE
STUDENTS ACROSS THE STATE. OUGHT
TO THANK THE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE WHO SIGNED ON TO JOSE
MEDINA IS BETTER. CALLING ON.
PRIORITIZING THE BUDGET ASK FOR
YOU SEE BUT I ALSO WANT TO SAY
IN A STATE WITH A SIX POINT ONE
BILLION DOLLAR. BUDGET SURPLUS
THIS YEAR
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS MORE FOR
YOU SEE IS NOT NEARLY ENOUGH.
IT'S NOT NEARLY ENOUGH WE'VE CUT
MORE THAN A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION FROM UC BERKELEY'S
BUDGET ALONE. IS NOT NEARLY
ENOUGH ON HOW FAR CAMPUS IS
FACING FOOD INSECURITY SIDE
NEARLY ENOUGH WHEN MOST OF OUR
STUDENTS DON'T KNOW WHETHER
THEY'RE GONNA HAVE A ROOF OVER
THEIR HEAD. TONIGHT OR LATER
THIS MONTH.
SO I WANT TO WORK WITH YOU.
THIS IS OUR SIXTH IS MY
PERSONAL SIXTH TRIP TO
SACRAMENTO THIS SEMESTER.
WE'VE ORGANIZED OUR STUDENTS
FROM ACROSS THE UC TWO OUT.
OUTNUMBER NON STUDENTS IN NEARLY
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THESE
HEARINGS.
WE'RE DOING OUR PART WE NEED YOU
TO COME VISIT US AT YOU SEE.
SEE WERE EXPERIENCING BEFORE YOU
DECIDE HOW MUCH WE SHOULD BE
INVESTING IN YOU SEE STUDENTS
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
I MY NAME IS STATES LARRY'S I AM
A THIRD YEAR STUDENT UC DAVIS.
AND I'M ADVOCATING WITH RISE
CALIFORNIA SO I RECEIVE
SCHOLARSHIPS NETWORK TWO PART
TIME JOBS BUT I STILL HAD TO
TAKE OUT MULTIPLE STUDENT LOANS
TO PAY FOR COLLEGE AND. THIS
SHOULD BE THE CASE CALIFORNIANS
SHOULDN'T BE IN THOUSANDS OR
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS OF
DEBT JUST TO GET THEIR BACHELORS
DEGREE. HIGHER EDUCATION
CALIFORNIA SHOULD BE FREE THE
WAY IT WAS FOR A HUNDRED YEARS
AND I HOPE THAT AS OUR PUBLIC
SERVANTS YOU'LL WORK TO DEFEND
STUDENTS AND PREVENT THE
MONETIZATION OF CALIFORNIA'S
PUBLIC UNIVERSITY SYSTEM. ALSO
HIGHER EDUCATION IS THE PRIMARY
PLATFORM THAT ALLOWS LOW INCOME
AND MINORITY STUDENTS ACCESS TO
OPPORTUNITIES AND PAVE THEIR
PATH TO SUCCESS AND THAT
INCLUDES ME.
WHEN YOU'RE CONSIDERING FUNDING
FOR THE UC SYSTEM PLEASE THINK
OF THE REAL IMPACT ON US THE NEW
GENERATION OF CALIFORNIA'S
LEADERS THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
MY NAME IS HUNTER STERN I'M A
FIRST YEAR UC SANTA CRUZ OF.
THE UC'S.
FOR.
PRESSURE.
TWO OVER ENROLL IN THE UC SYSTEM
COUPLED WITH POOR FUNDING HAS
THREATENED THE PRESTIGIOUS.
STATUS OF THE UC SYSTEM
CAMPUS IS TRYING TO KEEP PACE
WITH THE ENROLLMENT TARGETS
WITHOUT.
THE NECESSARY ADDITIONAL FUNDING
ARE FORCED TO MAKE DECISIONS
THAT SUBSTANTIALLY REDUCE THE
QUALITY OF.
OF THE EDUCATION OFFERED FOR
EXAMPLE.
AT UC SANTA CRUZ THE VAST
MAJORITY OF STUDENTS ENROLLED IN
CALCULUS FOR ENGINEERING ONE TWO
AND VECTOR CALCULUS.
MUST TAKE THOSE CLASSES ONLINE
WHICH HAS.
A MARKEDLY NEGATIVE AFFECT ON
STUDENT ENGAGEMENT AND MORALE.
WE STUDENTS AND POOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA TO ADEQUATELY FUND
THE UC SYSTEM SO THAT IT MAY.
MEET ENROLLMENT QUOTAS
SET. THE STATE WITHOUT.
SACRIFICING ITS WORLD CLASS
STATUS.
CLOSE FAMILY MEMBERS THANK YOU
FOR LETTING ME SPEAK TODAY.
MY NAME IS KAREN ELLIOTT I'M A
FIRST YEAR POLITICS MAJOR UC
SANTA CRUZ.
AND THANK YOU FOR PUTTING ALL
THE EFFORT DAY ARE INTO TRYING
TO ENHANCE.
AND EXPAND THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA APPRECIATED.
THIS IS IMPORTANT TO ME AS A
STUDENT. AND IT IS IMPORTANT TO
THE STATE'S ECONOMIC FUTURE.
CALIFORNIA'S CURRENTLY THE SIXTH
LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD.
AND THE MAINTENANCE OF THE
STATUS IS DEPENDENT.
ON WHETHER WE CAN FILL THE ONE
POINT ONE MILLION JOBS THAT WILL
REQUIRE A COLLEGE EDUCATION BY
TWO THOUSAND THIRTY. THAT ARE
CURRENTLY PROJECTED TO BE.
NOT FILLED UP BY THE PUBLIC
POLICY INSTITUTE.
OF CALIFORNIA.
AND IT IS FOR THIS REASON THAT
WE ARE CURRENTLY OVER ENROLLING
STUDENTS AND WE ARE FEELING THE
PRESSURE OF OVER ENROLLMENT YOU
SEE WIDE.
NOW ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY OF
AUTHORED AB TWENTY TO FORTY
EIGHT.
WHICH REQUIRES.
SINCE TAKE FIFTEEN YOU
INSENSITIVE TWELVE UNITS
AND I.
APPRECIATE THE SENTIMENT THAT
YOU WERE.
PUTTING FORTH AND THIS BILL.
ANITA HAS GOOD INTENTIONS.
I BELIEVE.
ITS A GOOD EFFORT TO TRY AND
ALLEVIATE OVER IN ROME AND MAKE
SINCE GRADUATE FASTER.
HOWEVER.
I FEAR THAT I COULD HAVE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE QUINCES.
BECAUSE THEIR STUDENTS TO WORK
BUT THEMSELVES THROUGH COLLEGE.
THEIR STUDENTS WHO WERE TAKING
TWELVE UNITS BECAUSE THERE.
STEM MAJORS THEY'RE TAKING.
CLASSES LIKE ORGANIC CHEMISTRY
IN HIGH LEVEL CALCULUS CLASSES.
THAT DO NOT EQUATE TO MIND
NINETEEN UNITS OF POLITICS
CLASSES.
THEIR TIME INVESTMENT IS GREATER
AND I FEEL THAT.
THE.
THE NUMBER OF UNITS ARE YOU TAKE
IS AN ARBITRARY NUMBER. IS NOT
NECESSARILY PAN TO.
THE TIME COMMITMENT THAT WAS
STUDENT MAKES.
SO INSTEAD.
I BELIEVE THAT WE SHOULD BE
FOCUSING ON A. B. THIRTY ONE
FIFTY THREE. WHICH WOULD EXPAND
SUMMER CAL GRANT.
FOR TWO ADDITIONAL SUMMER
SESSIONS.
AND THIS WOULD ALLOW STUDENTS.
PERSONAL THE SMEARS WHAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS ALREADY
DONE. BY SUPPLYING FINANCIAL AID
STINSON SUMMER.
AND.
IT WOULD STUDENTS.
STUDENTS DON'T TAKE LOWER
NUMBERS OF UNITS BECAUSE.
THEY DON'T THEIR LAZIER THEY
DON'T WANT TO OR.
WHATEVER WHAT HAVE YOU RIGHT.
THEY TAKE LESS UNITS BECAUSE.
THEY HAVE TO.
LIKE STUDENTS ARE MOTIVATED TO
TRAIN GRADUATE AS FAST AS THEY
CAN. BY THE WOMEN DEBT. THAT
THEY'RE FACING.
OKAY.
HOW TO ASK YOU TO? WRAP IT UP
GREAT COMMENTS OR TWO AND HALF
MINUTES THANK YOU I APPRECIATE
YOU GUYS TIME THANK YOU FOR.
BEING HERE TODAY IN FRIDAY'S OR
TWO YOU CAN THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS BRIAN ASTORIA
AND I'M A MEMBER OF YOU SEE
ESSAY AND I'M STUDENTS AND
AGENCY.
ALONG WITH MY PEERS BEHIND THE
WORST YEARS FROM UC BERKELEY AND
WE'RE HERE TO ASK FOR YOU TO
FUND YOU SEE.
COMMITMENTS I'VE BEEN TO A FEW
THESE HEARINGS BUT MR MCCARTY
EARLIER HAVE TO SAY SOMETHING
THAT HURT THROUGHOUT THESE
HEARINGS.
THE MAIN THING THEIR
CONSTITUENTS AT HOME CARE ABOUT
IS THAT THEIR CHILDREN GET UC'S.
VERY VALID AND I BELIEVE THIS
OVERLAPS WITH HESITANCE BRASS
DEPLETE MONEY YOU SEE.
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT IS NOT OUR
FAULT OUR FAULT THE UNIVERSITY
ADMINISTRATORS AND PRACTICES
THAT PUT US AND INCOMING
STUDENTS AND SUCH FORMAL
SITUATIONS. HAVE WORSENED
HOUSING AND FOOD INSECURITIES AT
EACH CAMPUS IS NOT OUR FAULT.
I ALSO WANT TO CLARIFY IN
KISSIMMEE HAVE BEEN MISCONSTRUED
AYE WE'RE NOT HERE TO ADVOCATE
ON BEHALF THE YOU SEE WE ARE
HERE TO ALKI I'M HAVE STUDENTS.
ESPECIALLY THE MARS LISTA
POPULATION AT EACH CAMPUS.
WITH THAT SAID I HOPE YOU CAN
CLARIFY REFLECT ON WHY THE BLAME
IS ONLY PUT ON YOU SEE WHEN THE
STATE HAS COME. SISTERLY
DIVESTED FROM HIGHER EDUCATION.
MR MCCARTY YOU'D KNOWLEDGE THAT
OVER THE PAST DECADE HAS BEEN
THE CASE BUT THE RECESSION WAS
AT FAULT. HOWEVER OVER THE PAST
FOUR DECADES
STATE FUNDS PER STUDENT HAS
BALLING CLOSE TO SIXTY FIVE
PERCENT.
WE ARE PUSHING FOR MORE ROLL IT
OR MOMENT IS MORE IMPORTANT THAT
YOU CAN MIND THE QUALITY OF
EDUCATION IS DETERIORATING. WITH
OTHER RESOURCES TO MEET THE
STUDENTS.
YOU SEE CALPERS BEACON HELP US
BY PUTTING THE UC THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS KATE LARSEN I'M A
FIRST YEAR STUDENT AT UC
BERKELEY. MY MOTHER CRIED WHEN I
TOLD HER THAT I WANT TO GO TO UC
BERKELEY THESE WERE NOT TEARS OF
JOY. EVEN THOUGH BERKELEY WAS
THE ONLY SCHOOL THAT I COULD
ATTENDING GRADUATE WITH MINIMAL
THAT'S AND IT WAS ALSO THE BEST
SCHOOL THAT I GOT INTO SHE KNEW
THAT I WOULDN'T HAVE PERSONAL
ATTENTION FROM MY PROFESSORS.
SHE KNEW THAT I WOULD HAVE TO
SIT ON THE FLOOR OF MY LECTURE
HALLS THAT HAVE FIVE HUNDRED
STUDENTS IN THEM. BE AND SHE
KNEW THAT I WOULD GET WAIT
LISTED FOR THE LAST TWO CLASSES
I NEED TO DECLARE MY MAJOR. THAT
I WOULDN'T BE GUARANTEED ON
CAMPUS HOUSING EVEN AS A
FRESHMAN.
THESE ARE THE REALITIES OF
OVERCROWDING CAMPUSES A LACK OF
HOUSING OF CLASS SPACE OF
RESOURCES.
THIS WASN'T THE CASE FOR
PREVIOUS GENERATIONS FOR YOUR
GENERATION AT UC CAMPUSES
CURRENTLY ENROLLED YOU SEE
STUDENTS AND THE NEXT GENERATION
ARE WORTHY OF THE SAME GREAT YOU
SEE HAS PASSED EATONS. AND WE
WILL DO GREAT THINGS FOR THE
STATE THE PUBLIC GOOD AND OUR
COMMUNITIES IN RETURN FOR THE
STATE'S INVESTMENT.
PLEASE NOTE WE ALL SAY
INVESTMENT NOT FUNDING WE ARE
NOT JUST REQUESTING A ONE TIME
BAILOUT WE WANT THE STATE TO PUT
ITS TRUST IN THE FUTURE THAT
ACCESSIBLE EDUCATION PROVIDES.
THANK YOU TO THOSE OF YOU WHO
SIGNED I'M ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEDINA AS LETTER AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PROMISES TO HELP THE
STUDENTS PLEASE ACT ON YOUR
PROMISES. WE DON'T HAVE MONEY OR
AN ARMY OF LOBBYISTS TO PERSUADE
YOU BUT WE AS STUDENTS ARE WORTH
THE INVESTMENT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ANGIE
CHEN I'M A SECOND YEAR STUDENT
AT UC BERKELEY WE'VE TALKED A
LOT ABOUT CAMPUS MAINTENANCE
COURSE AVAILABILITY AND STUDENT
TO FACULTY RATIO BUT I JUST WANT
TO EMPHASIZE THAT THESE AREN'T
JUST STUDENT ANECDOTES. THESE
ARE CONCRETE ISSUES THAT HAVE
REALLY REAL IMPACTS ON THE
QUALITY OF EDUCATION I HAVE MY
CLASSES IN COSTUMES WITH BROKEN
CHAIRS AND CHALKBOARDS THAT
DON'T WORK. NEXT WEEK I'M
ROLLING MY FALL SEMESTER COURSES
THE MANY OF THE CLASSES I NEED
FOR MY MAJOR AND FOR GRADUATION
ARE ALREADY FILLED UP.
AN INCREASE ENROLLMENT HAVE IS
RESULTED IN MASSIVE OVERCROWDING
THE DATA SCIENCE COURSE THAT I'M
IN RIGHT NOW IS OVER ROLLED SO
MUCH THAT THEY ACTUALLY HAD TO
TURN STUDENTS AWAY FROM LECTURE
BECAUSE THE LECTURE HALL CAN'T
FIT THE THOUSANDS OF ENROLLED
STUDENTS IN THAT CLASS.
IT'S CLEAR THAT THE UC SYSTEM
DESPERATELY NEEDS THIS FUNDING
IS THE INVESTMENT IS INADEQUATE
THE FINANCIAL BURDEN FALLS ON
THE STUDENTS
I JUST WISH THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WOULD PRIORITIZE
IMPROVING AFFORDABILITY
RESOURCES AND ACADEMIC SUCCESS
FOR FOR CURRENT STUDENTS. BEFORE
TALKING ABOUT EXPANDING ACCESS
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS JEN DRIVE A I'M
PROBABLY THE ONLY COMPUTER
SCIENCE STUDENTS HERE FROM UC
BERKELEY. ARM AND I JUST WANT TO
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
POINTS THAT WERE MENTIONED ABOUT
OVERCROWDING. NOW I APPRECIATE
THE UC REPRESENTATIVES COMMENTS.
ABOUT.
THE UC SYSTEM AND HOW IT
REFLECTS THE OVERCROWDING THAT'S
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW BUT. I WANT
TO EMPHASIZE THAT.
SHE MIGHT OF UNDERSTATED THE
SITUATION RIGHT NOW.
I WALK INTO MOFFIT LIBRARY ONE
OF THE MOST POPULAR LIBRARIES ON
CAMPUS.
AND IT IS LITERALLY FILLED TO
THE BRIM WITH STUDENTS SITTING
ON THE GROUND BECAUSE THERE'S NO
OTHER PLACE TO STUDY. IMAGINE
WALKING INTO YOUR OFFICE AND
THEY'RE BEING TWENTY PEOPLE
SITTING ALL OVER THE GROUND AND
YOU NOT BE ABLE TO GET YOUR
DESK.
THAT'S RIDICULOUS.
I ALSO SEE IN MY OWN RESIDENTIAL
HOUSE
WHERE. IN THE LAUNDRY ROOM.
PEOPLE TAKE THE CLOTHES OUT OF
THE LAUNDRY MACHINES AND THROW
THEM ALL OVER THE PLACE BECAUSE
THEY'RE SIMPLY NOT ENOUGH LARGER
ROOMS FOR PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO
WAIT THE FULL PERIOD OF THE
LAUNDRY CYCLE. SO THAT THEY CAN
HAVE THEIR OWN LAUNDRY DONE I
SEE PEOPLE DRYING THEIR CLOTHES
IN THE COMMON ROOM OF OUR FLOOR
BECAUSE THERE'S NOT ENOUGH SPACE
IN THEIR OWN ROOM OR NOT ENOUGH
LAUNCH CAPACITY FOR THAT TO
HAPPEN BY ITSELF.
I SAW OR COMEDY ROOM IN THE
FIRST SEMESTER OF MY YEAR BEING
FILLED WITH FOR STUDENTS THIS IS
A ROOM THAT WAS SUPPOSED TO
OFFER STUDY SPACE AND AN AREA
FOR PEOPLE TO SOCIALIZE. BEING
FILLED WITH STUDENTS
OVERCAPACITY BECAUSE THEY'RE
SIMPLY NOT ENOUGH HOUSING AT UC
BERKELEY
THIS IS ALL A RIDICULOUS
SITUATION AND I HOPE THAT YOU
RECONSIDER SUCH A PROPOSAL TO
ADD MORE STUDENTS. WITHOUT
ACTUALLY ADDING MORE CAPACITY
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS CONNOR HE'S IN
ON AN UNDERGRADUATE AT THESE AT
UC BERKELEY.
INSTANCE SENATOR AT OUR STATE
GOVERNMENT ACC I'M SORRY IF MY
WAS CAN LEARN MOST SICK BUT THIS
IS IMPORTANT FOR ME. ON A
SPECIFIC YOU FOR THOSE OF YOU
WHO ARE STILL ASSUME THIS PUBLIC
COMMENT.
AND AGAIN THIS HEARING I HEARD
ONE OF YOU SAY THAT YOU HEAR
ANECDOTES ABOUT STUDENTS ABOUT
THEIR EXPERIENCES ALL THE TIME.
AND WE ARE STUDENTS MISSING
CLASS ON OUR OWN ACCORD TO
EXPLAIN TO YOU WHAT IS HAPPENING
ON OUR CAMPUSES ON SAID THESE
SIXPENCE XIN OPTUS.
I'VE ACQUIRED CLASS FOR MY MAJOR
THAT HAS GROWN BY FIFTY PERCENT
IN THE LAST FOUR YEARS.
ALTHOUGH DISCOMFITURE SINCE
STUDENTS THE NUMBER OF GRAD
STUDENTS DOCTORS R. T. A.'S OR
GRADERS HAS NOT RUN AT ALL.
SOMETHING HAPPENED THIS YEAR
WHERE THEY COULD NOT COMPETE
WITH THAT AND OPPRESSORS LITTLE
CANCELED MID TERMS.
BECAUSE THAT I'VE GOT NO
FEEDBACK ON MY WORK FOR THE YEAR
THE FIRST FEEDBACK WILL GET IS
MY ACTUAL FINAL.
OR QUALITY OF EDUCATION HAS
DECREASED.
THIS IS A DIFFERENCE IN QUALITY
THAN WHAT YOU RECEIVED WHEN
YOU'RE. WHEN YOU'RE IN COLLEGE.
OUR PROFESSORS HAVE TO CUT
CONTENT AND LECTURE BECAUSE THE
SYSTEMS UNDER FUNDED.
AND WHILE I AGREE THAT THE
SYSTEM SHOULD BE AS SUCCESSFUL
AS POSSIBLE YOU'RE ASKING US TO
DO MORE WITH LESS.
FUNDS FOR STUDENT HAVE CONTINUE
FALL IN THE QUALITY OF OUR
EDUCATION IS FALLING WITH IT.
HELP US FROM THE C..
THANK YOU.
WHO DO BUILT UP?
HI MY NAME'S NEAL I FIRST I JUST
WANTED TO REAFFIRM THAT NONE OF
US ARE BROUGHT HERE BY THE YOU
SEE WERE BROUGHT HERE ON HER OWN
ACCORD. I DON'T WANT TO BE HERE.
I HATE PERSONAL HE WOKE UP AT
SIX IN THE MORNING TO BE HERE
I'VE BEEN TO TO THESE MEETINGS
I'VE BEEN TO REGENTS MEETINGS.
AND I'VE LOBBIED DURING MY
SPRING BREAK FOR YOU SEE FUNDING
I'M HERE BECAUSE IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO ME.
I KNOW THAT YOU'VE ALL OF KIND
OF HEARD ALL THESE DIFFERENT
TESTIMONIES ABOUT HOW WERE
AFFECTED BY LACK OF FUNDING. AND
SO I DID WANT TO ADDRESS THE
FACT THAT BUILDINGS ARE FALLING
APART LITERALLY AT UC BERKELEY.
THERE'S UNBELIEVABLE
OVERCROWDING A LACK OF BASIC
INFRASTRUCTURE LIKE HEATING AND
AIR CONDITIONING AND MAJOR
CLASSROOMS AND BUILDING WE ARE
EVEN GUARANTEEING SUFFICIENT
WAGE INCREASES THAT ACCOUNT FOR
INFLATION OR THE COST OF LIVING
FOR WORKERS. WHO MAINTAIN THESE
FACILITIES?
BUT IT SEEMS LIKE MOST YOU
UNDERSTAND THAT WE CAN'T JUST
TAKE IN MORE STUDENTS WITHOUT
ADDING MORE RESOURCES.
BUT TO ADDRESS WHAT.
ASSEMBLYMAN MCCARTY SAID
EARLIER IS THAT I IN THE IN THE
WHEN IT COMES TO THE ISSUE OF
WASTE.
YES THERE PROBABLY IS WASTE YES
PROBABLY YOU CO P. COULD SPEND
MONEY BETTER ARE YOU KNOW I
STUDENTS WE SAW THE AUDIT. AND
WE WERE DISAPPOINTED BUT AT THE
SAME TIME EVERY PUBLIC SYSTEM
HAS A DEGREE OF WASTE
AND AS HOT POTATO IS PLAYED BACK
AND FORTH. BETWEEN.
BIFF BETWEEN THE STATE AND THE
U. COPD.
STUDENTS ARE THE ONES WHO ARE
ACTUALLY SUFFERING
AND I WANT YOU TO REMEMBER THAT.
AS SOMEONE WHO WORKS CLOSELY
WITH TRANSFER STUDENTS WORKING
IN A STUDENT GOVERNMENT OFFICE
THE ADVOCATES.
FOR TRANSFERS THAT THE UC APPEAL
LEVEL AT THIS AT THE STATE LEVEL
ON AND AT THE CAMPUS LEVEL WE
CAN JUST TAKEN MORE STUDENTS WHO
ARE DISADVANTAGED WHO ARE OF
LOWER INCOME WITHOUT FUNDING THE
SYSTEM FURTHER.
AND SO I'M JUST HONESTLY REALLY
TIRED AND I HOPE THAT YOU
UNDERSTAND WHAT THIS MEANS ALL
OF US AND THAT YOU'VE.
FUNNY YOU SEE NOT JUST FULLY
FUND LIKENESS MCCARTY SAID ON
BUT ACTUALLY FIND WHAT YOU SEE
ESSAY IS PROPOSING. I'M AS AN
INDEPENDENT STUDENT ORGANIZATION
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
AGAIN ONE ONE MINUTE PLEASE.
MY NAME IS JENNIFER BRYCE AND
I'M AN UNDERGRADUATE STUDENT AT
UCLA. I GRADUATED FROM HIGH
SCHOOL OR LESS THAN THIRTY
PERCENT OF MY CLASS CONTINUE
THEIR EDUCATION AT A FOUR YEAR
UNIVERSITY BEFORE COLLEGE MY
SMALL NEIGHBORHOOD WAS ALL I HAD
TO MEASURE MYSELF AGAINST THE
WORLD. HOWEVER MY EASY EDUCATION
HAS GIVEN ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
LEARN FROM EXPERTS AND TO
CONDUCT RESEARCH AYE UCLA HERE
IN SACRAMENTO NMTC. LOANS GRANTS
AND SCHOLARSHIPS HAVE HELPED
FINANCE MY EDUCATION I JUGGLE
TWO INTERNSHIPS.
AND COME FROM A FAMILY THAT IS
STRUGGLING TO MAKE ENDS MEET
FAIR PLAYING OFF PARENT CLASS
YOU GROUNDS MY MOTHER'S YOU
LANDS AS WELL AS MY SISTERS UC
BERKELEY LAB'S. COLLEGES TAUGHT
ME TO EMBRACE UNCERTAINTY I
NEVER NEW OPPORTUNITIES AND
EXPERIENCES TO EXPECT EACH YEAR.
BUT THE QUESTION HAVE SUFFICIENT
STATE FUNDING FOR YOU SEE IS
WHAT UNCERTAINTY THAT WORRIES
ME.
TODAY'S STUDENTS HAVE TO DEAL
WITH INCREASED TUITION MUCH
LARGER CLASS SIZES AND CRUMBLING
INFRASTRUCTURE I'VE HAD CLASSES
WHERE STUDENTS HAVE TO SAY IN
THE AISLES BECAUSE THERE ISN'T
ENOUGH ROOM. I GET TO CLASS
EXTRA EARLY SO I KNOW I CAN GET
A SEAT.
I HAD TEACHERS WHO DON'T HAVE
ROOM SO HOLD OFFICE HOURS WE CAN
DO BETTER. WE MUST PRIORITIZE
AFFORDABILITY STUDENTS ARE NOT
FAULT ENSURING ACCESS YOU SEE
WILL EXPAND THE POTENTIAL FOR
STUDENTS FROM ALL BACKGROUNDS TO
SUCCEED. THANK YOU TO THOSE OF
YOU WHO HAVE DECLARED YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THESE THE BUDGET
REQUEST.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
VICTORIA SOUTH OF ITS AND I AM A
SECOND YEAR AT UCLA FROM THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY. DESPITE BEING A
LIFELONG CALIFORNIA RESIDENT I
HAVE COME TO LEARN IN MY TIME IT
YOU SEE BUT THE MIDDLE CLASS IS
OFTEN OVERLOOKED WHEN DISCUSSING
THE BUDGET AND INVESTING IN
HIGHER EDUCATION. I RECEIVED NO
FINANCIAL AID FROM THE STATE OR
YOU SEE FROM EDUCATION BUT JUST
PUT A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
PRESSURE ON MY PARENTS TO PUBLIC
SCHOOL TEACHERS WHO HAVE GIVEN
OVER FOUR DEDICATE DECADES OF
THEIR LIVES TO PUBLIC SERVICE.
THIS QUARTER I AM SITTING ON THE
FLOOR OF A TWO HUNDRED PERSON
LECTURE HALL A STORY YOU'VE
HEARD FROM AT LEAST FOUR
CAMPUSES JUST TODAY.
I OFTEN DO MY BEST NOT TO
PURCHASE TEXTBOOKS SO I CAN
AVOID INCURRING EXTRA FEES AND I
WORK TWELVE TO FIFTEEN HOURS A
WEEK IN ADDITION TO BEING A
DOUBLE MAJOR WITH A MINOR. TO
TRYING TO EASE THE BURDEN ON MY
FAMILY.
I UNDERSTAND THAT YOU SEE IN THE
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT ARE NOT
PERFECT I'VE SEEN THESE
IMPERFECTIONS FIRST HAND. BUT
THIS BUDGET ASK AS A SYMBOL OF
HARD WORK BETWEEN STUDENTS IN
THE ADMINISTRATION TO SHOW HOW
THIS NEEDED MONEY WOULD BENEFIT
THE STUDENTS. I WANTED TO THANK
CHAIRMAN CARTY FOR CONSIDERING
THESE REQUESTS AND FOR ACTUALLY
CALLING ON MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO FULLY FUND YOU
SEE.
INVEST IN THE STUDENT WHO WILL
BECOME HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS FOR
AGING CALIFORNIANS INVEST IN THE
STUDENT WHO IS TRYING TO ENSURE
THE LONGEVITY OF THE MIDDLE
CLASS.
INVEST IN THE STUDENT WHO WILL
ONE DAY BE SITTING IN YOUR
CHAIRS.
INVESTED MY PEERS AND I THINK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON JERRY MCCARTY IN
MEMBERS OF BUDGET SUB TWO. OF MY
NAME IS RAFI SANDS AND HAVE THE
PRIVILEGE THIS YEAR OF SERVING
AS THE ONLY UNDERGRADUATE MEMBER
OF THE UC BOARD OF REGENTS. MY
FOURTH YEAR UNDERGRADUATE FROM
UCLA.
AND I SPENT THE LAST YEAR
WORKING IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
UC OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT TO
WORK TOGETHER ON A BUDGET
REQUEST THAT STUDENTS CAN
ACTUALLY STAND BEHIND.
AS STUDENTS WE ALSO ARE
SOMETIMES CHALLENGED BY THE LACK
OF OVERSIGHT AT THE UC OFFICE OF
THE PRESIDENT
AND I'LL SAY THAT WE ARE
APPRECIATIVE OF YOUR PROACTIVE
THIS ENSURING THE UNIVERSITY IS
HELD ACCOUNTABLE TO THE PEOPLE
OF THE STATE.
AT THE SAME TIME LET US BE CLEAR
STUDENTS SHOULD NOT HAVE TO BEAR
THE BRUNT OF POLITICAL
INFIGHTING BETWEEN THE STATE AND
THE UC OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT.
THIS A HUNDRED FORTY MILLION
DOLLAR BUDGET QUEST WOULD BE
SPENT A HUNDRED PERCENT ON
CAMPUSES AND COMING TO MUTUALLY
AGREED UPON REQUEST WE HAD
STUDENTS MADE SURE TO SEE THAT
WHERE THIS MONEY IS SPENT IS
CLEARLY AND EXPLICITLY LAID OUT.
AND WE'RE VERY HAPPY TO SEE THAT
FOLLOWING MY REQUEST WITH THE
PRESIDENT THE UC IT PROVIDED US
WITH A SPECIFIC CAMPUS BY CAMPUS
BREAKDOWN OF WHERE FUNDING
INCREASE WOULD BE SPENT. GOING
SO FAR AS TO STATE HOW MANY FULL
TIME EMPLOYEE HIRES WOULD BE
HIRED ON EACH CAMPUS WE WOULD
LOVE TO SHARE THIS WITH YOU IF
POSSIBLE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
LISTENING TO US IN CONSIDERING
THIS BUDGET REQUEST.
GOOD AFTERNOON MICHELLE BACK
WITH THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION. WOULD LIKE TO
STRONGLY URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
RESTORE OUR GENERAL FUND TO THE
UC'S BASED BUDGETS SO THAT
PROPOSITION FIFTY SIX DOLLARS
CAN BE USED FOR THEIR INTENDED
PURPOSE. WHICH IS TO EXPAND
RESIDENCY SLOTS IN THE STATE AS
WAS MENTIONED EARLIER.
IN THE HEARING TODAY WERE
MISSING AN OPPORTUNITY TO
ESTABLISH HUNDREDS OF NEW SLOTS
AND.
THIS WOULD GO A LONG WAY IN
ADDRESSING THE PHYSICIAN
WORKFORCE SHORTAGE THAT WE'RE
EXPERIENCING STATEWIDE THANK
YOU.
BARBARA GLAZER WITH CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION I TOO AM
HERE TO URGE YOU TO RESTORE
FUNDING TO YOU SEE THAT WAS
DEDUCTED AS RESULT OF
PROPOSITION FIFTY SIX.
I FEAR THAT IF THIS MONEY IS
NOT RESTORED THIS YEAR THAT THIS
TREND WILL NOT BE STOPPED AND WE
WILL NEVER REALIZE THE PRIMARY
CARE POSITIONS AND EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT. PHYSICIANS THAT THAT
WE HOPE TO REALIZE FROM
PROPOSITION FIFTY SIX
SO ON BEHALF OF BOTH PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE HOSPITALS THAT TRAIN
RESIDENTS WE URGE YOU RESTORE
THIS FUNDING THANK YOU.
OKAY WHERE MARTIN HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATIONS ALSO
ASKING YOU TO REJECT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL TO CUT
UC'S BUDGET AND RESTORED WITH
PROP FIFTY SIX FUNDING. ARE
EIGHT NONPROFIT FREESTANDING
CHILDREN'S HOSPITALS TRAIN FIFTY
PERCENT OF THE PEDIATRIC
RESIDENTS IN THE STATE. THEIR
INELIGIBLE FOR MEDICARE GRADUATE
MEDICAL EDUCATION DOLLARS AND
THE FEDERAL CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
JIMMY PROGRAM ONLY REIMBURSES
THEM AT ABOUT FORTY PERCENT OF
THE COST OF THESE PROGRAMS THAT
THEY'RE EXPECTED TO MAINTAIN AND
AND KEEP TRAINING. THE POSITIONS
OF TOMORROW PEDIATRICIANS OF
TOMORROW PROGRAMS LIKE THIS ONE
IMPROPER FIFTY SIX ARE GOING TO
BE CRITICAL TO MAKING SURE THAT
HAPPENS. THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR TO MADDEN REPRESENT
THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER THE MAN
CALLED EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS WE
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT LASHER OBJECT IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WE ONCE
AGAIN ASK YOUR SUPPORT IN
REJECTING HIS PROPOSAL THIS
YEAR.
OF THE FORTY MILLION TAKE AWAY
FROM THE UC'S AND REALLY RESPECT
THE WISHES OF THE VOTERS OF PROP
FIFTY SIX WHICH IS TO USE THOSE
FUNDS TO INCREASE RESIDENCY
SLOTS. FOR NOT ONLY PRIMARY CARE
PHYSICIANS BUT FOR EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS AS WELL. I KNOW THE
LA ALL MENTIONED.
SOME DISCUSSIONS AROUND THE
SONG BROWN PROGRAM BUT I JUST
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THE SONG BROWN
PROGRAM IS ONLY FOR PRIMARY CARE
PHYSICIANS THAT DOES NOT INCLUDE
EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS.
SO IF THERE IS SOME
CONTEMPLATION OF INVOLVEMENT IN
THAT I WE WOULD JUST ASK TO BE
GOD KEEP US IN MIND FOR THAT. ON
THE UC'S DID TALK ABOUT A
PROPOSAL WHERE THEY WILL LOOK AT
WORKING WITH AN OUTSIDE ENTITY
POSSIBLY THE CMA FOUNDATION.
WE'RE OPEN TO THAT IN
DISCUSSIONS WITH THEM AND WE
PROCEED OR INCLUSION IN THAT BUT
MOST IMPORTANTLY WE NEED TO
RESTORE THE FORTY MILLION FURS.
THANK YOU THANKS EVERYBODY FOR
THEIR PUBLIC TESTIMONY WITH THAT
WE WILL ADJOURN